GOOD MORNING EVERYONE I'D LIKE
CALL THE.
FIRST HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
SUBCOMMITTEE ON RESOURCES AND
TRANSPORTATION FOR THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN LEGISLATIVE SESSION TO
ORDER. AND DEBT AS WITH EVERY
YEAR THIS YEAR IS SHAPING UP TO
BE A BUSY ONE AND. TODAY WILL
BEGIN WITH OUR FIRST LOOK AT
FIRE PREVENTION FOLLOWING
ANOTHER. TORRENTIAL WILDFIRE
SEASON.
A BUT WE WILL ALSO THIS SESSION
BE LOOKING INTO A FEW OTHER
THINGS INCLUDING.
FLOOD PREVENTION INFRASTRUCTURE
IN LIGHT OF THE EVENTS AT ORACLE
DAM LAST YEAR.
REVISITING TOXIC CLEAN UP
EFFORTS BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL AND IN
PARTICULAR THE FORMER EXIDE
BATTERY PLANTS. AND THE CLEANUP
EFFORTS IN THAT COMMUNITY.
WE'LL BE LOOKING AT ACCESS TO
CLEAN WATER AND QUITE POSSIBLY
GIVEN THE STATE OF OUR SNOW PACK
AND RECORD LOW RAINFALL
EMERGENCY DROUGHT RESPONSE TO
THOSE COMMUNITIES WITHOUT.
ADEQUATE WATER SUPPLIES.
WE'LL LOOK AT SKYROCKETING
NUMBERS OF WHALE ENTANGLEMENTS
ALONG OUR COAST AND HOW WE CAN
IMPROVE. RESPONSE AS WELL AS
DEVELOP PREVENTIVE MEASURES THAT
ALLOW OUR CRAB FISHERY TO
THRIVE.
AND SO I WILL TAKE A LOOK A
PROTECTING AN IMPROVING THE
HABITAT FOR ASSEMBLY THAT I
THINK IT'S BEEN OVERLOOKED FOR
TOO LONG.
ARE A STEEL HEAD AND SALMON
FISHERIES AS WE HEAD INTO THIS
YEAR ARE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
STEEL HAD POPULATION MOST
PEOPLE.
THAT.
DON'T THINK OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BUT THERE IS A
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA STILL HAD
POPULATION THAT POPULATION IS IN
PERIL AND NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
AREAS SUCH OF THE AS THE FEATHER
RIVER. ARE ALSO EXPERIENCING
SERIOUS THREATS ALL DUE TO LONG
TERM DAMAGES TO OUR RIVER
ECOSYSTEMS AND FINALLY WE WILL
ALSO TAKE A LOOK INTO AGAIN. AT
TO IMPROVING OUR RECYCLING
PROGRAMS WHICH IN ITSELF FRANKLY
A SEEMINGLY ANNUAL EXERCISE IN
THIS COMMITTEE THAT SAW FOLLOWED
TO BUY WITH A DANCE WITH OUR
SENATE COLLEAGUE SENT TO. OUR
AND THE ADMINISTRATION BUT HAS
NOT RESULTED IN SIGNIFICANT CHAT
A CHANGE TO A PROGRAM THAT I
DON'T THINK THE GENERAL PUBLIC
KNOWS.
IS
SLOWLY GOING DOWN SO I'M VERY
OPTIMISTIC THAT WILL ACTUALLY
MAKE SOME PROGRESS ON THAT ISSUE
THIS YEAR.
THESE ARE JUST SOME OF THE MAJOR
CONVERSATIONS THAT WILL BE
HAVING DURING THE COURSE OF THE
LEGISLATIVE SESSION AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO NOT ONLY WORKING WITH
MY COLLEAGUES.
HERE BUT HAVING A PRODUCTIVE
DIALOGUE WITH THE SENATE THE
ADMINISTRATION AS WE NEAR OUR
JUNE BUDGET DEADLINE.
OKAY GOING BACK TO WHAT BRINGS
US HERE TODAY.
AND SPEAKING OF DANCES SIDE IT.
THAT.
WE HAVE REPEATEDLY I'D LIKE TO
START BY READING A QUOTE FROM.
A HEARING THIS COMMITTEE HAD. A
COUPLE YEARS AGO ON APRIL EIGHTH
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND THE QUOTAS
ARE CLIMATE CHANGE OUR CLIMATE
IS CHANGING AND THIS POSES A
SERIOUS THREAT TO OUR
ENVIRONMENT. PUBLIC HEALTH AND
ULTIMATELY OUR WAY OF LIFE
OF COURSE HOW QUICKLY AND
SEVERELY THIS THREAD IMPACTS US
LARGELY DEPENDS ON HOW QUICKLY
AND AGGRESSIVELY WE MEET THE
CHALLENGE.
OVER THE NEXT FEW DECADES
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTIONS IN GHG
EMISSIONS WILL BE NECESSARY TO
AVOID THE WORST CONSEQUENCES OF
CLIMATE CHANGE.
MITIGATION EFFORTS WILL TOUCH
NEARLY EVERY ASPECT
OF CALIFORNIA'S INFRASTRUCTURE.
PLANNING AND INVESTMENT.
THAT WAS MY OPENING STATEMENT TO
THAT HEARING BACK IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN WHICH FOCUSED
PRESCIENTLY AT THAT TIME ON ARE
CHANGING WEATHER PATTERNS.
PARTICULARLY IN THE WESTERN
UNITED STATES AS A RESULT OF
CLIMATE CHANGE.
THE HEARING FOLLOWED A NASA
STUDY THAT WAS RELEASED JUST A
FEW MONTHS EARLIER AND THAT
PREDICTED EXTREME WEATHER
PATTERNS AND CAUTIONED THAT
EXTREME DROUGHT FOR THE REGION
IN THE. DECADES AHEAD WOULD
BECOME THE NORM.
AFTER FIVE YEARS OF DROUGHT NOW
LAST YEAR GAVE US AN ABUNDANCE
OF SNOW IN WHAT FELT LIKE A
REPLENISHMENT. OF OUR WATER
SUPPLIES.
BUT AS WE SIT HERE ON FEBRUARY
TWENTY FIRST
WE ARE AGAIN EXPERIENCING RECORD
LOW SNOWPACK AND RAINFALL. AND
WE'RE LEFT CONTEMPLATING ANOTHER
LONG DROUGHT PERIOD JUST AS NASA
PROTECTED THOUGH SEVERAL YEARS
AGO. AND IN THAT APRIL EIGHTH
HEARING WE ALSO LEARNED OF
PROJECTIONS BY LAWRENCE BERKELEY
NATIONAL LABORATORY.
THAT'S NO WATER IN CALIFORNIA
WILL DECLINE BY SIXTEEN PERCENT
OVER THE NEXT TWENTY YEARS
THIRTY FOUR PERCENT BY TWENTY
SEVENTY. AND AN ASTOUNDING FORTY
ONE PERCENT BY THE END OF THE
CENTURY.
FORTY ONE PERCENT FOLKS.
THE SACRAMENTO AND SAN JOAQUIN
RIVERS THE HEART OF OUR WATER
DELIVERY SYSTEM COULD SEE ATTEND
A FIFTEEN PERCENT INCREASE AND
WATER FLOWS BY TWENTY SEVENTY IN
THE MONTHS FROM DECEMBER TO
MARCH. AS RAINFALL. REPLACES
SNOWFALL.
AS A RESULT THERE COULD BE A
THIRTY PERCENT DECREASE IN WATER
FLOWS FROM APRIL TO JULY. AS
THERE WILL NO LONGER BE SNOWPACK
MELTING TO PROVIDE WATER IN THE
SUMMER MONTHS.
WEATHER MODELING SHOWN AT THAT
TIME DETAILED THIS TO BE THE
SAME FOR MANY OTHER RIVER
SYSTEMS THROUGHOUT THE PACIFIC
NORTHWEST AND SOUTHWEST.
WELL TODAY WE'RE GOING TO GET AN
UPDATE ON THIS MODELING FROM ARE
VERY TROUBLING MOTLEY FROM OUR
CLIMATE EXPERTS.
THE INFORMATION HEARING TODAY
WILL FOCUS
ON THE WILDFIRES IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AS WELL THE RECOVERY
WHERE EFFORTS THAT ARE NOW
UNDERWAY AND WHAT THIS ALL MEANS
FOR OUR FUTURE.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT RECORD
BREAKING FIRES AN UNUSUALLY LONG
FIRE SYSTEM EVERY YEAR AND THE
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR SOMETIME NOW.
IN FACT EIGHT OF THE STATE'S
MOST DESTRUCTIVE WILDFIRES
OCCURRED IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
THE FIRES LAST YEAR BURNED INTO
DECEMBER WHICH IS HISTORICALLY
OUTSIDE OF OUR FIRE SEASON.
SUFFICE IT TO SAY THE EXTREME
AND CHANGING WEATHER PATTERNS
ARE CONTRIBUTING IF NOT DIRECTLY
CAUSING THE DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES THAT WE'VE WITNESSED
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS.
FROM YOSEMITE IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
TO LAKE COUNTY IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
AND MORE RECENTLY THE FIRES THAT
RAVAGED
THE COMMUNITIES NAPA SONOMA
SANTA BARBARA AND RETURNED
COUNTIES WE ARE. UNFORTUNATELY
FACING A NEW REALITY.
NO DOUBT ARE CHANGING CLIMATE
HAS SOMETHING TO DO WITH THIS.
OUR POOR FORCE MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES FURTHER EXACERBATE THE
SITUATION AND DECADES OF FIRE
SUPPRESSION OF COST FORCE LANCE
TO GET TO DANCE MAKING THEM MORE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO LARGE AND
DEVASTATING WILDFIRES.
THE IMPACTS OF THESE FIRES ARE
WIDESPREAD.
IN EFFECT A MULTITUDE OF AREAS I
THINK IT'S TEMPTING TO TALK
ABOUT ALL OF THIS TODAY BUT TIME
IS A CONSTRAINT THE HEARING
TODAY'S GOING TO BE. A REALLY A
PRIMER I THINK FOR WHAT WILL. BE
MANY DISCUSSIONS TO FOLLOW AND
THE SUBJECT DESERVES MANY
DISCUSSIONS.
SOAK UP BEFORE WE. ARE OF BRING
UP OUR FOR SPEAKER I'D LIKE TO
WELCOME SENATOR HANNAH BETH
JACKSON THE OTHER OF FOLKS WHO
ARE HERE TODAY TO HEAR THIS
IMPORTANT TESTIMONY. A A SENATOR
JACKSON IS THE CHAIR OF THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT.
COMMITTEE OF THAT RIGHT.
AND DATA AYE SHE MAY WANT IT.
I ADD A FEW WORDS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS A
RECOVERING LAWYERS SWELLS
POLITICIAN I'M ALWAYS HAPPY TO
ADD A FEW WORDS.
THE AND AND ALSO IS THE CHAIR
OF THE JOINT.
COMMITTEE ON EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT.
AND ALSO AS THE HOST SENATOR FOR
THE NINETEENTH SENATE DISTRICT
WHICH WAS THE. LOCATION OF EVERY
MEMBER OF THE THOMAS FIRE.
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE TODAY AND TO.
EXTEND MY WELCOME TO ALL OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND AND
DISTINGUISHED GUESTS WHO ARE.
HERE WITH US THIS MORNING.
I'M. VERY ANXIOUS TO HAVE THIS
DISCUSSION ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S ON
GOING WILDFIRE RISK IN A RECAP
OF THE.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN SEASON WHICH
WAS PROBABLY AMONG OUR WORST.
AND AS WAS MENTIONED.
WE DO POLITICALLY OF RATIONALLY.
LOGICALLY NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE A
CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND THE FACT THAT IT HAS CREATED
OF THESE EXTREME WEATHER
CONDITIONS THAT HAVE LED TO THE
DISASTROUS THROUGHOUT OUR STATE
AND. INDEED MOST IMPORTANTLY THE
LOSS OF
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF LIFE SO.
AS WE.
FOCUS ON HOW OUR STATE AGENCIES
CAO FIRE OH YES CAO RECYCLE ARE
PREPARING FOR THE NEXT
FIRESTORM.
OF WE HAVE MUCH WORK TO DO IN
AND MUST DO SO IN AN URGENT
FASHION.
HEIGHT DO THOUGH HAVE HAVE TO.
GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO OUR OF
FIRST RESPONDERS AND OUR STATE
AGENCIES SUCH AS CAL FIRE OH
YES.
AND CARRY CYCLE FOR THE
EXTRAORDINARY JOB THAT THEY HAVE
DONE BOTH IN TERMS OF A
FIGHTING.
OF THESE WILDFIRES AND THE WORK
THAT'S BEING DONE TO RECOVER
FROM THEM AND I CAN SAY THAT AS
SOMEONE WHO.
.
LIVES IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD WHERE
THE.
DEBRIS FLOWS MUDSLIDES WHATEVER
YOU WANT TO CALL THEM I TOOK THE
LIVES OF FIVE. TWENTY THREE
PEOPLE TWENTY ONE THAT WE KNOW
PASSED AWAY IN A TWO YEAR OLD
AND A SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD WHO'S.
A BODIES HAVE A YET TO BE FOUND.
AND IT IT WAS ACTUALLY SOMEWHAT
IRONIC THAT ON DECEMBER FOURTH
OF LAST YEAR. I JUST ABOUT AN
HOUR AFTER WE CONCLUDED OUR
JOINT COMMITTEE HEARING ON
EMERGENCY.
WARNING SYSTEMS.
RECOGNIZING THAT DURING THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN FIRES WERE
FORTY THREE LIVES UP WERE LOST
THAT THE SYSTEM.
NEEDS IMPROVEMENT THAT ARE NINE
ONE ONE SYSTEM FOR EXAMPLE IS
FORTY YEARS OLD PROBABLY
PREDATES MOST OF THE
TECHNOLOGIES THAT WE SEE TODAY.
AND THE FACT THAT WE REALLY NEED
TO GIVEN THAT THE REALITIES OF
CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE WEATHER
WAS THAT WE'RE SEEING. A NEED TO
UPGRADE THOSE SYSTEMS AN HOUR
AND A HALF LITERALLY AFTER
BANGING DOWN THE GAVEL THE
THOMAS FIRE STARTED. WHICH OF
RICK TABACUM MY DISTRICT FOR
FORTY DAYS.
ARE AS THAT FIRE BURNED ACROSS
THE WORLD THEA FROM EAST TO WEST
IN MY DISTRICT STARTING AND
SANTA PAULA. AND ENDING IN SANTA
BARBARA A DISTANCE OF ABOUT
FORTY MILES AWAY DURING WHICH
TIME I WAS PERSONALLY EVACUATED
FROM MY HOME FOR SIX DAYS. ARE
AND.
WATCHED SOMETHING THAT WE WORD
THAT WAS VIRTUALLY OUT OF
CONTROL MOVE IN THE DIRECTION
THAT. COULD HAVE COST AN EVEN
GREATER LIFE THAN IT DID.
SO.
ULTIMATELY THE FIRE BURNED TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND ACRES IN
DECEMBER. THE LARGEST WILDFIRE
IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY ARE
DESTROYED MORE THAN A THOUSAND
BUILDINGS.
ENDED ITSELF THE FIRE ALONE
CLAIM TO LARGE INCLUDING A CAL
FIRE ENGINEER WHOSE LIFE WE. ARE
HONORED TO MEMORIALIZED.
AND THEN OF COURSE JUST WHEN WE
THOUGHT THINGS WERE COMING DOWN
PEOPLE HAD MOVED BACK INTO THEIR
HOMES.
WE WERE BREATHING A COLLECTIVE
SIGH OF RELIEF.
AS THE FIRE WAS PUSHED INTO THE
BACK COUNTRY AWAY FROM OUR
CITIES AND RESIDENTS.
THE RAINS CAME.
THIS IS THE RAINY SEASON THIS IS
THE TIME WHEN WAS POST EVERY
THIS IS A TIME WHEN WE NEED
RAIN.
UP PARTICULARLY IN MY DISTRICT
WHERE THE LAST OF THE EXTREME
DROUGHT CONDITIONS AREAS IN THE
STATE WE ARE STILL IN EXTREME
DROUGHT.
AND SO HERE WE ARE TODAY.
WANTING RAIN BUT RECOGNIZING
THAT THE HILLSIDES BEHIND THE
ENTIRE CITY OF BEEN COMPLETELY
DENUDED. AND THIS ARE A
NIGHTMARE CURRENT AT THREE
THIRTY IN THE MORNING WHEN MOST
PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY WERE
FAST ASLEEP.
A A RAIN SHELL รณ LANDED OVER
MONUS SETO CALIFORNIA.
IN WITHIN THE COURSE OF FIVE
MINUTES HALF AN INCH OF RAIN
FELL.
A THAT THAT LED TO MUDSLIDES THE
COSTS LARGE AS I MENTIONED OF
TWENTY THREE OF MY NEIGHBORS. OF
SOME OF THE OFWHOM I KNEW. SO.
IT'S PERSONAL IT'S PROFESSIONAL
IT IS IN A A REMINDER OF THE
IMPACTS OF THESE FIRES IN THESE
CONDITIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA FROM THE.
TOP OF THE STATE DOWN THE SAN
DIEGO.
AND EVERYWHERE IN BETWEEN AND
OF COURSE THESE WILDFIRES AND AS
WELL AS THE MUD. MUD FLOWS
DEBRIS FLOWS.
AND I HAVE HAD AN ENORMOUS
IMPACT ON THE STATE'S ECONOMY
ONE OF THE THINGS WE HAVE TO
REMEMBER IS ITS IMPACT ON
INFRASTRUCTURE.
HIGHWAY ONE A ONE ONE OF TO
NORTH SOUTH ROADS A KEY HIGHWAYS
AND STAY CALIFORNIA WAS CLOSE
FOR TEN DAYS.
CREATING HAVOC ON THE ECONOMY OF
OUR STATE SO.
.
I I JOIN WITH SO MANY OTHERS TO
THANK THE HEROISM OF OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS AND EMERGENCY
MERCHANTS IN PERSONNEL ABOUT
BATTLED THE THOMAS FIRED THE
TUBS FIRE THE ATLAS FIRE THE
NUNS FIRE AND ALL THE OTHER
FIRES. THAT HAVE RAVAGED THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITHOUT
THEIR INCREDIBLE WORK.
THESE EVENTS WOULD ALL BEEN
MUCH MORE CATASTROPHIC BUT IT IS
THE CANARY IN THE COAL MINE
WHEATON ME WE MUST WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM. WE KEEP
WORKING I DON'T KNOW WHETHER
WE'RE EVER GOING TO GET UP. THE
LEADERSHIP IN WASHINGTON TO
RECOGNIZE THE OTHER CAUSES OF
CLIMATE CHANGE IF WE'VE GONE
BEYOND THE TIPPING POINTS.
A OF FOR CLIMATE CHANGE WE HAVE
GOT TO BE PREPARED AND EVEN IF
WE HAVEN'T. OF MOTHER NATURE IS
MAKING IT VERY CLEAR TO US RIGHT
NOW.
THAT.
SHE IS IN CHARGE AND UNLESS WE
WORK WITH MOTHER NATURE OF THE
FUTURE IS GOING TO BE QUITE DAM
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU AGAIN
CHAIRMAN BLOOM.
FOR ORGANIZING THIS HEARING AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO THIS VERY
IMPORTANT AND CRITICAL
DISCUSSION.
THANK YOU ON A WELCOME BACK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG FOR ANOTHER
ROUND OF OF OF BUDGET SUB THREE
AND TO WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RICHARD AGAINST IT FROM THE.
AT A JOINT EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
COMMITTEE AND TO WOULD EITHER BE
LIKE TO AND THE COMMENTS.
WITH SURGERY GETS HER FIRST ON A
THANK EVERYBODY FOR BEING HERE
THANK BOTH CHAIRS CENTER JACKSON
SOME REMEMBER BLOOM FOR BRING US
ALL TOGETHER. AS WE KNOW
CALIFORNIA'S THE STATE HAS BEEN
PLAGUED BY MANY DISASTERS FOR
MOST RECENTLY THE FIRES THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT.
AND IT'S GOOD TO HAVE THIS
DISCUSSION TO SEE HOW WE BETTER
PREPARE AND PLAN AHEAD FOR THE
NEXT SEASON SO TO SPEAK. WHETHER
IT'S THE FIRES THE FLOODS AND WE
ALSO.
TALK ABOUT THE EARTHQUAKE WHEN
NAY THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN AS
WELL. SO I JUST LOOK AT HOW WE
CAN LEARN FROM THESE PREVIOUS
DISASTERS HOW CAN BETTER
IMPROVE.
AND JUST A BIG THANK YOU TO ALL
OF FIRST RESPONDERS INSTEAD OF
CALIFORNIA FOR DOING.
TREMENDOUS JOB IN YOUR LIVES ON
THE LINE TO PROTECT US IN
CALIFORNIA SO ON A THANK YOU.
AND LOOK FOURTEEN POINT
DISCUSSION HOW WE CAN BETTER
PROVE OUR RESPONSES TO THESE
DISASTERS SO THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH AUNT.
SENATOR JACKSON I. HAD NOT
REALIZED THAT THE THOMAS FIRE
LASTED A EXACTLY FORTY DAYS AND
I'M ASSN FORTY NIGHTS WHICH.
MAKES IT NOT SURPRISINGLY.
A DISASTER OF BIBLICAL
PROPORTIONS.
AND.
OF THAT HAVING BEEN SAID TO
DISCUSS.
THAT THOMAS FIRE AND MORE I'D
LIKE TO.
INTO INTRODUCE AND WELCOME OUR
FIRST SPEAKER CHIEF CAN PIMLOTT
THAT DIRECTOR OF CAL FIRE.
GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU PAT CHAIRS BLOOMING
AND JACKSON AND MEMBERS OF BOTH
COMMITTEES OF THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE TODAY.
FIRST OF ALL AND REPRESENTS
REALLY ALL OF THE FIRST
RESPONDERS.
IN CALIFORNIA AND OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO RESPONDED.
TWO WAYS YOU'VE VERY WELL
DESCRIBED.
WERE CONDITIONS OF AB EPIC
PROPORTIONS LAST YEAR.
AS.
.
CHAIR BLOOM INDICATED WE'VE BEEN
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE. ALMOST
EVERY YEAR.
IN THE LAST FOUR OR FIVE YEARS
AS WE'VE.
TOGETHER LIVE THE CHANGES THAT
HAVE GONE ON IN IN CALIFORNIA
RELATIVE TO THE CLIMATE AND THE
IMPACT THAT IT'S HAD.
ON ON FIRES ON WATER SUPPLIES
OVER THINGS THAT ARE IMPACTING.
PEOPLE HERE IN THE STATE AND
JUST WHEN WE HAVE.
SIGNIFICANT YOU'RE LIKE TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN WITH THE RIM
FIRE AND THINK HOW COULD IT
POSSIBLY GET WORSE TO HUNDRED
AND. FIFTY SEVEN THOUSAND ACRES.
OF FOREST LAND AND NATIONAL PARK
LAND OUTSIDE YOSEMITE.
BURNED FOLLOWING YEAR WE HAVE
THE KING FIRE NO THE ROUTE OF
COUNTY JUST EAST OF HERE WHICH
WAS ALMOST A HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACRES. THREATENING WATERSHEDS IN
AND AROUND UP AGAINST LAKE
TAHOE.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN WE HAVE
SOME OF THE WORST AND MOST
DEVASTATING FIRES IN THE STATE'S
HISTORY BETWEEN THE BUTTE FIRE.
IN CALAVERAS AND AMADOR COUNTY
AND THEN THE VALLEY FIRE.
IN.
LAKE COUNTY.
AGAIN LIVES WERE LOST.
BURNING UNDER RATES OF SPREAD
IN CONDITIONS CONSUMING
VEGETATION AT UNLIKE
FIREFIGHTERS AND OTHERS HAVE
HAVE SEEN BEFORE.
IN THEN LITERALLY TWO THOUSAND
AND SEVENTEEN THIS WAS THE YEAR
YOU KNOW FOLLOWING AB
SIGNIFICANT RAINFALL WE HAVE BE
IT FOR THE MOST PART HAD
DECLARED AND TO.
THE WORST DROUGHT IN THE
STATE'S HISTORY.
BUT WHAT CAME WITH THAT I JUST
AS YOU INDICATED YOU KNOW THE
CHANGES IN PRECIPITATION
PATTERNS IT IS JUST. JUSTICE
WERE EXPERIENCING TODAY AS WE
TREND BACK TOWARDS.
WHAT APPEARS TO BE DROUGHT LIKE
CONDITIONS AGAIN EXCUSE ME?
OUT WHERE WE SAW. A CHANGE IN
PRECIPITATION PATTERNS IT'S
COMING IN THE FORMS OF RAIN. NOT
SNOW WHAT THAT PRODUCED FOREST'S
IN.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN
WAS A RECORD.
GRASS CROP THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THERE WAS WITH THE
FLASHY FUELS THAT'S THE KINDLING
THAT STARTS.
MR RECEPTIVE FUEL BABBLE THAT'S
WHAT WE STARTED OFF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WITH. ABOUT ONCE.
THE RAIN SUBSIDED AND THE GRASS
DRIED OUT THAT WE HAD NOT ONLY
LIGHT FLASHY FUELS BUT WE HAD.
HEAVY BRUSH WE HAD TREES ALL OF
WHICH HAD NOT RECOVERED FROM
FIVE YEARS OF DROUGHT. AND BY
MAY WE WERE LITERALLY A OFF TO
THE RACES WITH.
FIRES BURNING THROUGH THE
FOOTHILLS THAT WE WERE ALREADY
EXCEEDING. AT THE FIVE YEAR
AVERAGE FOR ACRES BURNED AND THE
NUMBER OF FIRES.
AND BY FOURTH OF JULY.
WE WERE RIGHT AND IT'S A BIT
ANECDOTAL BUT I'VE I FELT FOR A
WEEK ABOUT A DURING THE FOURTH
OF JULY WEEK WE WERE EXPERIENCE
IT SEEMS LIKE A A NEW FIRE EVERY
TEN OR FIFTEEN MINUTES.
IT WAS LITERALLY AT THERE WERE
TIMES WHEN IT WOULD GET SOME
VERY VERY BUSY DAYS.
SO GOING INTO AUGUST.
WE THE STATE WAS WELL AHEAD OF
THE FIVE YEAR AVERAGE IN WELL
AHEAD OF THE PREVIOUS YEAR. OUR
AVERAGE BOTH IN ACRES BURNED.
AND.
IN THE NUMBER OF FIRES AND
WE'RE TALKING BY OVER THOUSAND.
FIRES AHEAD OF THE FIVE YEAR
AVERAGE.
WE OFTEN LOOK TO THE FALL
MONTHS TO SEE WHETHER
CONDITIONS.
START TO TO SUBSIDE THE DAYS
GET SHORTER HUMIDITY IS COME UP
AT NIGHT. BUT HISTORICALLY
OCTOBER.
IT WE WE'VE HAD THE MOST
DESTRUCTIVE FIRES THAT IN THE
STATE'S HISTORY.
DURING THOSE SET THOSE FALL
MONTHS SO WE ARE OFTEN. THE
PUBLIC CAN BE LURED INTO
THINKING THAT MAYBE FIRE SEASONS
OVER THE DAYS ARE COOLER.
BUT IT'S NOT ALWAYS THE CASE
AND TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AS
YOU KNOW. UP PROVE TO BE JUST
THAT.
WE HAD A WEEKEND.
THE FIRST FULL WEEKEND IN
OCTOBER. ABOUT RED FLAG
CONDITIONS.
KNOWS ARE FOR CRITICALLY DRY.
HUMILITY'S AND FOUR WINS.
THAT EXCEED NORMAL.
PATTERNS.
THAT'S WHAT WE EXPERIENCED. IN
THE NORTH BAY FIRES AS THEY
BROKE OUT.
ABOUT NINE THIRTY HERE SO THAT
SUNDAY EVENING.
IN EARLY OCTOBER YEAH AND YES
WE'VE HAD NORTH WINS IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA THOUGH DID THEY.
FIRE IN EAST BAY HILLS.
IN THE EARLY NINETIES THE
TUNNEL FIRE THAT DESTROYED SO
MANY HOMES AND AND TOOK LIVES.
BURN UNDER SIMILAR CONDITIONS
BUT WHAT WE'RE SEEING IN ALL OF
THESE FIRES INCLUDING. THOSE
DESTRUCTIVE FIRES IN OCTOBER IN
THE NORTH BAY IS THAT IT'S THAT
THE INTENSITY. IT'S THE DURATION
OF THE OF THE CONDITIONS AND OF
THE FIRESTORM THAT WE'RE SEEING.
IT'S JUST THAT THEY'RE
HAPPENING WOULD BE SIDE SOME
CASES RECORDED WINS. ARE IN
EXCESS OF EIGHTY MILES AN HOUR.
IN A NUMBER OF.
WEATHER STATIONS ACROSS TO THE
NORTH A PART OF THE STATE. BUT
WE HAD OBVIOUSLY MULTIPLE FIRES
AT STARTING AT THE SAME TIME.
BUT IN A A FORTY EIGHT HOUR
PERIOD BEGINNING THAT SUNDAY.
EVENING THROUGH THE FOLLOWING
MONDAY.
AT NIGHT ARE ACTUALLY IN THE
TUESDAY MORNING THAT THE
NORTHERN REGION OF OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WORTH OF
SACRAMENTO.
EXPERIENCED OVER A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY TO FIRE STARTS.
JUST IN THAT PERIOD WE JUST IN
OUR COMMAND CENTER.
INSANE HALINA WHICH.
RESPONSE TO IMPROPRIETIES HIS
CALLS FOR FIRES IN THAT REGION
AROUND A CINNAMON LIKE NAPA
COUNTIES RECEIVED OVER THIRTY
EIGHT HUNDRED. EMERGENCY CALLS
FOR SERVICE AND THIS IS ON TOP
OF. LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THE FIRE SERVICE AGENCIES IN
AND AROUND SO NO MATTER. NAPA
MEN TO SEE NO.
SOLANO A NEVADA BUTTE.
YUBA COUNTIES ALL OF THESE
COUNTY A LOCAL GOVERNMENT CAL
FIRE WERE ALL EXPERIENCING.
STREAM NUMBER OF CALLS AND SOME
OF THE FOR THE FIRST.
TWELVE TO TWENTY FOUR HOURS OF
THE FIRESTORM.
IN OCTOBER. ARE LITERALLY.
FIRST RESPONDERS PUBLIC SAFETY
PROFESSIONALS LAW ENFORCEMENT
FIRE DEPARTMENTS AND MANY
OTHERS.
WERE LITERALLY FOCUSING ON
EVACUATING AT RESIDENTS FROM OUT
IN FRONT OF THE FIRE. THE TUBS
FIRE FOR EXAMPLE WHEN IT
STARTED.
WELL NORTH AND EAST OF THE CITY
OF SANTA ROSA NEARLY TOOK ONLY
FOUR HOURS FROM THE TIME IT
STARTED UNTIL IT CROSSED.
HI WE WANT ONE AND ENTERED THE
CITY OF SANTA ROSA AND LITERALLY
BURNED.
YOU KNOW TWO MILES INSIDE IN
URBAN SUBDIVISION NOT WILDLAND
URBAN INTERFACE BUT IN URBAN.
SUBDIVISION OP MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT SO THE CHALLENGES WITH AT
NOTIFICATIONS AND AND GETTING
FOLKS OUT.
ALL OF US THAT RESPONDED TO THAT
WERE FOCUSED ON LITERALLY
PUTTING. TAKING PEOPLE OUT OF
HARM'S WAY PUTTING HIM IN FIRE
ENGINES IN PATROL CARS AND
LEGALLY DRIVING THEM. TO
HOSPITALS THIS WASN'T THE NORMAL
CALL NINE ONE ONE THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT IN THE AND WHAT SHOWS
UP AND WE PROCESS IN TRIAGE THE
PATIENT AND TRANSPORT THIS WAS.
EVERY FIRE AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
RESOURCE WAS TAKING INDEPENDENT
ACTION.
TO SAVE LIVES UP ALL THE PUBLIC
SAFETY DISPATCHERS AT THE
SHERIFF'S OFFICE OF THE HIGHWAY
PATROL. CAL FIRE THE FIRE
DEPARTMENTS WERE LITERALLY
TALKING RESIDENTS THROUGH HOW TO
SAVE THEIR OWN LIFE.
THEY WERE TYPING IS LIFE AND
DEATH SITUATIONS WHERE THEY WERE
DEALING WITH THAT. SO THAT
REALLY PAINT THE PICTURE FOR THE
FIRST A YOU KNOW TWELVE TO
TWENTY FOUR HOURS.
ULTIMATELY YOU KNOW AS THE
STATE'S EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
CENTER WAS QUICKLY OPENED THE
PARTNERSHIP AND THE STATE
ORGANIZING.
UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
GOVERNOR AND LOOK WHAT WE'VE
COME TO BE KNOWN YOU KNOW IS THE
SORT OF OF THE THE FOR BETWEEN
THAT THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES CAL FIRE THE CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL GUARD AND THE HIGHWAY
PATROL. JUST SEAMLESS RESPONSE
IN APPROACH TO ENGAGING VERY
QUICKLY HAPPENED.
ON THAT THE VERY NEXT MORNING
IN BRINGING IN ALL. OF THE
SUPPORT OF THE STATE AND MANY
OTHERS TO ENGAGE IN AND TACKLE
THIS CHALLENGE WE WERE ABLE TO
BRING IN FOR INCIDENT MANAGEMENT
TEAMS TO QUICKLY BRING IN ALL
THESE FIRES. UNDER AN
ORGANIZATIONAL STRUCTURE ABOUT
WE ENGAGED OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PARTNERS IN SOME OF THE LOCAL
INCIDENT MANAGEMENT TEAMS TO
DEAL WITH MANY OTHER ISSUES THAT
OCCURRED THAT WERE SENSITIVE
POPULATIONS THAT HAD TO BE.
RELOCATED SUCH AS THE CINEMA
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER OF THE
VETERANS HOME ARE IN YACHT BILL
ALL THIS CREATED SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES THAT WERE WHICH I'M
SURE HERE TODAY IN TERMS OF
COMMUNICATIONS. BUT ISSUES THAT
OCCURRED BECAUSE CELLPHONE
INFRASTRUCTURE ABOUT WAS SO
DESTROYED A DURING THE FIRES.
ALL THESE WERE CHALLENGES THAT
POSED.
YOU THAT WERE DEALT WITH
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS.
ULTIMATELY ENGAGING THE STATE'S
A MUTUAL AID SYSTEM FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING THIS WAS A TEAM
EFFORT. THAT INVOLVED STATE
FEDERAL LOCAL INVOLVED OUT OVER
TWENTY ONE STATES AND THE
COUNTRY OF AUSTRALIA RESPONDING
LEANING FORWARD TO GET RESOURCES
INTO CALIFORNIA.
VERY EARLY ON AND JUST AS THE
OCTOBER AT FIRES WERE.
WE RIGHT IN THE IN THE MIDDLE
OF FIGHTING THOSE FIRES ARE
NGUYEN DEFENSE FORECAST FOR
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND SO WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT THIS BIG
PICTURE.
OF NOT ONLY TAKINGCARE OF THE
FIRES WERE FIGHTING IN THE
RESPONSE WERE DOING BUT ALSO
LOOKING AHEAD TO SEE WHERE OTHER
FIRES ARE GOING TO OCCUR AND
PLAN FOR ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
COMING IN.
TO GET THAT DONE AND DIDN'T
ULTIMATELY WORKED THROUGH THAT
AND IF THERE'S ANYTHING. I'VE
LEARNED.
IN THIS PROCESS THAT MANY OF US
HAVE LEARNED IS THAT THE
RESPONSE TO THE FIRE AND
EMERGENCY ITSELF IS JUST ONE.
HE'S AND I THINK TODAY REALLY
TALKING ABOUT MUCH BROADER PEACE
THIS TRANSITION TO RECOVERY.
IT'S STILL GOING ON OBVIOUSLY
HERE ABOUT TODAY FROM THE
EXPERTS AND THAT'S
THE REAL LEFT HERE IT'S WHEN THE
SMOKE CLEARS IT'S MAINTAINING.
AND SUPPORTING THIS EFFORT TO
TAKE CARE OF PEOPLE AND GET
PEOPLE BACK AND DEAL WITH DEBRIS
REMOVAL ALL OF THOSE THINGS.
VERY COMPLEX
CHALLENGING PROCESS.
SO AS WE WORK THROUGH THAT IN
OCTOBER. FLASH FORWARD TO AGAIN
DECEMBER FOURTH AND SENATE
JACKSON.
HIT HOME I REMEMBER SITTING
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE WITH
DIRECTOR GELLER DUTY AND MANY
OTHERS AND WE INDICATED.
THAT LITERALLY AS WE SPEAK TO
YOU THIS AFTERNOON THERE ARE RED
FLAG CONDITIONS OCCURRING.
ON THE CENTRAL COAST IN THE
SOUTH LAND.
AND YOU KNOW WITHIN HOURS
THE THOMAS FIRE BREAKS OUT IN.
AT E. AS YOU'VE INDICATED GET A
SIMILAR RESPONSE WE BROUGHT
RESOURCES IN FROM ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY. THAT DEALT WITH SOME
VERY CHALLENGING AND A VERY
CRITICAL URBAN INTERFACE.
SITUATION BUT AGAIN MOBILIZE
THE RESOURCES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA MOST A THOUSAND FIRE
DEPARTMENTS ARE IN CALIFORNIA.
ALL OF THEM WERE IMPACTED IN
ENGAGED WHETHER COVERING FIRE
STATIONS AT HOME. WERE SENDING
RESOURCES AUTO TO FIGHT THE FIRE
ALONG WITH CAL FIRE.
AND OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS A AT
THE FOREST SERVICE.
ULTIMATELY SIX FIRES IN THAT
FIRE SIEGE THAT SPANNED FROM
SANTA BARBARA TO SAN DIEGO.
AGAIN ENGAGING NOT JUST OUR
STATE MILITARY PARTNERS THAT WE
DO WORK WITH EVERYDAY BUT ALSO
FEDERAL MILITARY ASSETS FROM OUR
CAMP PENDLETON. ENGAGING WITH
THE FEDERAL EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
AGENCY TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS
OTHER ASSETS FROM AROUND THE
COUNTRY FOR. A SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS AND USING SOME NEW
TOOLS. UP BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS
ALL OF THIS POINTS TO THAT BUT
WE HAVE BEEN SAYING AND LIVING.
FOR THE LAST FOUR OR FIVE YEARS
IS THAT CONDITIONS ARE YEAR
ROUND.
LITERALLY AS WE SPEAK WERE
MOPPING UP AND SPIN AND CONCUR
FINISHING CONTAINMENT ON A
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED ACRE FIRE. IN
THE OWENS VALLEY NEAR BISHOP
THAT THREATEN HOMES. AND LIVES
OVER THE WEEKEND AND ENGAGED
USING RESOURCES THAT ARE NOW
HAVING TO BE STAFFED AND
DEPLOYED YEAR ROUND.
AND THAT'S THE THE REAL CHANGE
AND THE REAL FOCUS NOW FROM THE
RESPONSE PIECE.
THIS IS A YEAR ROUND.
RESPONSIBILITY FOR ALL OF US
SENATE PLACING IMPACTS ON ON ALL
OF US WE HAVE SYSTEMS THAT WERE
DESIGNED. TO RESPOND TO THE PEAK
OF FIRE SEASON AND THEN RESET
DURING THE OFF MONTHS BOEING
AIRCRAFT ARE FLYING NOW. YEAR
ROUND A FIRE ENGINES WE DON'T
HAVE TIME TO BRING HIM IN FOR
THE FULL MAINTENANCE BECAUSE
THEY'RE BEING STAFF BY
FIREFIGHTERS.
YEAR ROUND WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF
FIRE ENGINES STAFF TODAY AROUND
THE STATE NOT JUST A CALIFORNIA
ALONG WITH THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
RUN OF FOLKS THAT ARE OUT
SUPPORTING THIS RESPONSE AS WELL
ARE ALL THAT IS IMPACTING
MAINTENANCE CYCLES A AND AND THE
ABILITY TO. TO TO GET THOSE
THINGS TAKEN CARE OF.
IT IS ALSO.
THE IMPACT. ON OUR ABILITY THEN
TO DO OTHER WORK BECAUSE WERE
RESPONDING WE'RE DEALING WITH
THE EMERGENCY RESPONSE.
BUT THERE ARE SO MANY OTHER
RESPONSIBILITIES OUT THERE TO
GET DONE AS IT RELATES TO FIRE
PREVENTION PA AND OTHER. EFFORTS
SO AS WE LOOK AT THIS UP BIG
PICTURE AND IT WHERE WE GOING
FROM HERE THAT RESPONSE.
IS ONE EQUATION AND
CALIFORNIA'S.
WAS FORTY MILLION PEOPLE NOW AND
WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
PROTECT.
OUR PUBLIC MANY OF THESE PEOPLE
LIVE IN URBAN INTERFACE AREAS
WHICH IS KNOWN. WELL OBVIOUSLY
THE THOMAS FIRE SO MANY
COMMUNITIES WERE THREATENED
ALONG THE CENTRAL COAST WE
ALWAYS NEED A STRONG SYSTEM IN
THE STATE BECAUSE WE WILL ALWAYS
HAVE.
FIRES AND IT'S ONLY GOING TO
CONTINUE TO GET WORSE SO A
HEALTHY STRONG RESPONSE SYSTEM
FROM THE MUTUAL AID SYSTEM OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT PARTNERS.
PACK HELLFIRE WORKING WITH OUR
FEDERAL PARTNERS AND LITERALLY
CONTINUING TO KEEP PRESSURE AS
YOU INDICATED SENATOR JACKSON.
ON OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS TO
ENSURE THEY'RE BRINGING TO THE
TABLE THE FEDERAL RESOURCES.
TIP TO MEET THAT PART OF IT
BECAUSE SO MUCH OF THE.
WATERSHED LANDS ENFORCED IT
LANDS IN CALIFORNIA ARE UNDER
FEDERAL OWNERSHIP.
SO THAT'S OBVIOUSLY KEY BUT THE
SAME TIME INVESTING IN THESE
OTHER ELEMENTS IT'S BEFORE THE
FIRE OCCURS AND AS YOU'LL HEAR
MORE DETAIL WHAT GOES ON AFTER
THE FIRE.
OCCURS.
BUT I WANNA SPEND THE REST OF MY
TIME REALLY FOCUSING ON WHAT ARE
WE DOING.
BEFORE.
THE FIRE OCCURS AND THAT HAS TO
DO WITH ALL THE THINGS RELATIVE
TO FORCED HEALTH FOREST
MANAGEMENT.
FIRE PREVENTION ALL OF THOSE
EFFORTS
THIS LEGISLATURE THIS GOVERNOR
HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS.
INCREASED GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUNDING IN OVER TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS INVESTED
IN FOREST HEALTH. ARE IN THE
CURRENT BUDGET.
BOTH FOR FOREST HEALTH AND FOR
FIRE PREVENTION FUELS TREATMENT
MOSTLY GOING OUT TO.
MANY MANY STAKEHOLDERS AROUND
THE STATE TO ENGAGE IN REAL
PROJECTS.
ON THE GROUND.
TOOK TO REDUCE FUEL LOADING THE
INCREASE.
FOREST AT RESILIENCE.
AND THEN AGAIN A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS IN. THE
CURRENT THAT GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
AT TO GO FORWARD WITH THOSE VERY
VERY SIMILAR.
EFFORTS.
BUT IT'S GOING TO TAKE A LOT OF
EFFORT.
TO GET OUR FORESTS BACK
TO WHERE THEY NEED TO BE TO BE
MORE RESILIENT.
I NOT HAVE THESE STAND REPLACING
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN THOUSAND
ACRE RIM FIRES THAT ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO OCCUR. TREE
MORTALITY THAT'S YOU KNOW NOW
CONSUMED O. OVER ALMOST A
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE MILLION
TREES.
IN THE CENTRAL AND SOUTHERN
SIERRA THAT HAVE SUCCUMBED.
TO AN EPIDEMIC LEVEL OF OF.
BARK BEETLE ACTIVITY AND
MORTALITY AS A RESULT OF THAT.
AS WE TREND BACK INTO DRY
CONDITIONS.
IT PARTICULARLY IN THE CENTRAL
AND SOUTHERN SIERRA WE WILL ONLY
CONTINUE TO SEE.
THE SPREAD OF OF INTENSE LEVELS
OF BARK BEETLE รณ INCREASE AS
IT WORKS ITS WAY TOWARDS A LAKE
TAHOE BASIN AND FURTHER NORTH I
INTO THE. THE SIERRA THE KEY
HERE IS INVESTING USING ALL THE
TOOLS IN THE TOOLBOX.
I KNOW LATER ON THIS MORNING.
.
CHAIR NOVEL WILL TALK ABOUT THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION REPORT
WHICH IS THAT HAS BEEN AN
AMAZING JOB.
FROM AN EXTERNAL PERSPECTIVE
TALKING ABOUT THE CHALLENGES
THAT THE STATE FACES AND REALLY.
UP PROVIDED THAT DISCUSSION
POINT AS TO WHERE WE NEED TO BE
GOING IN THAT'S INVESTING.
BEFORE THE INSECTS BEFORE THE
FIRE. OCCURS SO WE CAN REDUCE.
THE VOLUME OF FUEL BEEN OUR
FORCE WE CAN CREATE. A HEALTHY
RESILIENT FORCIBLE WAS STAND.
THESE KINDS OF FIRES THAT'S A
MORE NATURAL COMPONENT TO THE
FORCE THE CHALLENGES IS.
IN CALIFORNIA AGAIN PEOPLE ARE
LIVING IN THESE URBAN INTERFACE
AREA SO WE HAVE TO BALANCE OUR
FIRE PREVENTION.
AND FUELS TREATMENT IN AROUND
COMMUNITIES.
AND IN OUR USE OF FIRE OR OTHER
TOOLS WITH WHAT WE CAN DO IN
OTHER AREAS. OF THE STATE WHERE
FIRE CAN BE USED MORE READILY.
TO REDUCE FUEL LOADING BUT IT'S
A TEAM EFFORT AND IT'S
INCREASING BY. NO DOUBT THAT THE
PACE AND SCALE BY WHICH WERE
USING.
PRESCRIBED FIRE.
WHAT WE NEED TO INCREASE THE
PACE AND SCALE OF OUR PUBLIC
EDUCATION AT WORK TO ENSURE?
AGAIN THAT WE ARE RELENTLESS IN
EDUCATING OUR POPULATION.
MANY WHO MOVED TO THESE WILD
PLANTS WITHOUT AN UNDERSTANDING
OF THE THE RISKS THAT THEY'RE IN
OUR HOW TO INTERACT IN THE WILD
LAND. RIGHTS HOW TO INVEST IN
OUR PRIVATE. FOREST LANDOWNERS.
.
ABOUT NINE MILLION ACRES OF THE
FOREST LAND IN CALIFORNIA ARE
PRIVATE NON INDUSTRIAL. FOREST
LAND OWNERS THE USER SMALL
FAMILY OWNED IT THE EVAN NINETY
PERCENT OF THEM WERE ABOUT FIFTY
ACRES WORK FIFTY TO A HUNDRED
ACRES.
SO.
ENCOURAGING ENGAGING PROVIDING
THE INCENTIVES WORKING THROUGH.
VARIOUS TOOLS TO ENGAGE OUR
LANDOWNERS IN TREATING THESE
LANDS BECAUSE COLLECTIVELY. NINE
MILLION ACRES TREATED MEANS NINE
MILLION ACRES OF FOREST LAND
THAT'S MORE RESILIENT. THAT'S
NOT CONTRIBUTING TO CARBON
SEQUESTRATION. THAT'S NOT
CONTRIBUTING TO DEVASTATING GOT
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS DURING
CATASTROPHIC FIRES PROTECTING
OUR WATERSHEDS ENSURING WATER
QUALITY. OUR AIR QUALITY
WILDLIFE ALL ASPECTS THAT GO
WITH THAT AND THESE THESE ARE
PUBLIC LANDS USER INDIVIDUAL.
FAMILY LAND OWNERS WHO.
JUST NEED THE TOOLS TO BE ABLE
TO AT AND SOME TECHNICAL ADVICE
TO HELP MANAGE THEIR LAND. THEN
OF COURSE THERE IS THERE'S
INVESTMENT BY OUR COMMERCIAL
LANDOWNERS AND THERE'S THE
FEDERAL LAND OF THAT MAKES UP SO
MUCH OF THE FOREST LAND. ALL HAS
TO BE DONE TOGETHER.
AND WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
ENGAGE IN THESE LANDSCAPE LEVEL
PROJECTS AS WE GO FORWARD SO WE
CAN GET SOME REAL WORK.
DOWN ON THE GROUND WE CAN MAKE A
REAL DIFFERENCE WE GOT TO
LEVERAGE EVERY.
TOOL WE HAVE IN THE TOOLBOX
TOGETHER IT'S NOT CAL FIRE
WORKING BY ITSELF.
THE FOREST SERVICE FOR THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY SEARING ABOUT
A CONCERNS IT'S ALL OF US.
FINDING THOSE KEY PROJECTS I'M
KEY AREAS WHERE WE CAN TRULY
MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
BOB.
THE GOVERNOR WHEN DURING THE
STATE OF THE STATE.
WAS VERY CLEAR.
ABOUT THE NEED TO ENGAGE IN
FORCE MANAGEMENT AND ABOUT HIS
COMMITMENT.
TO GET US THERE. AND TO AS THE
THE WEEKS GO FORWARD WILL BE
HEARING MORE.
ABOUT.
IT REALLY PIVOTING OUR
DISCUSSIONS AT THE TREE
MORTALITY TASK FORCE TO A MUCH
BROADER DISCUSSION. ARE ON FORCE
MANAGEMENT ITSELF ALL THE THINGS
THAT WE CAN DO TO GET AHEAD OF
THIS CHALLENGE AND WE LOOK
FORWARD.
TO MOVING THIS NEEDLE TOGETHER
TO MAKE SOME REAL DIFFERENCE IN
THE STATE BUT IT'S CLEAR.
THAT IF WE DON'T.
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO SEE THE
LEVEL OF DEVASTATION THAT WE'RE
SEEING.
BOB THESE CHANGES ARE BEEN OCCUR
OVERNIGHT SO WHAT'S IMPORTANT IS
THAT AS WE CONTINUE TO INCREASE
OUR PACE AND SCALE.
OF EFFORTS.
AT THE SAME TIME WE.
SURE THAT OCEAN RISES ALL BOATS
ARE AT THE SAME TIME ARE EQUALLY
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO INVEST.
IN ALL PHASES OF THIS SO AS
YOU'LL HEAR LATER THE RECOVERY
ELEMENTS.
BUT CERTAINLY THE RESPONSE
PIECES TO FOR ALL OF US BECAUSE
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE. TO HAVE
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE A IN
THE STATE.
SO WITH THAT I'M OPEN FOR KIDS.
THANK YOU CHIEF.
AS ALWAYS IS.
.
GOOD TO HEAR YOUR ABOUT YOUR
ANNUAL REPORT.
AND I'D LIKE TO WELCOME A MS LOW
MOAN AND TO MUSIC AND WE ARE
CURRY.
TO TO THE HEARING THIS MORNING
AND TO.
ASK A FURTHER ANY QUESTIONS THAT
ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO ASK BEING
MINDFUL OF THE FACT THAT TO WE
HAVE. TO ADDITIONAL PANELS AND
SO WILL.
AFTER. IT WE HAVE TO FINISH BY
ABOUT NOON SO WE'LL JUST HAVE TO
BE MINDFUL OF THAT PLEASE.
UP.
SINCE YOU'RE HEARING YOU'RE THE
EXPERT ON OF FOREST MANAGEMENT.
.
IT SOUNDS LIKE WE HAVE
CHALLENGES.
.
NOT ONLY WITH THE STATE CLEARING
THE LANDS THAT IT HAS
RESPONSIBILITY FOR BUT ALSO WITH
THE PRIVATE SECTOR IN PARTICULAR
I'M INTERESTED IN.
WHAT DOES SUGGESTIONS OR
RECOMMENDATIONS YOU HAVE AS WE
ADDRESS BOTH THE COMMERCIAL AND
THE NONCOMMERCIAL PRIVATELY?
OWNED LAND IN IN TERMS OF TRYING
TO DO MANAGEMENT.
SO THAT WE CAN THEN THE FORESTS
ARM.
AND HELP AVOID SOME OF THESE
CATASTRPHIC ERA FIRESTONE'S.
NO IT IN THAT SIR THE KEY AT AND
I THINK THAT THE THE.
PARTNERS OFTENTIMES AT MAYBE NOT
CLEAR FOR THE PUBLIC IS THAT THE
STATE AND AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
REALLY OWN VERY LITTLE FOREST
LAND IN THE STATE.
IT'S MOSTLY WITHIN FEDERAL
OWNERSHIP AND IT'S MOSTLY.
WITHIN PRIVATE OWNERSHIP EITHER
LARGER. INDUSTRIAL COMMERCIAL
OWNERSHIPS OR THE STUDY ON NON.
INDUSTRIAL A FAMILY FOR A STEP
OWNERSHIPS AND SO THE STATE'S
RESPONSIBILITY CAL FIRE.
WITH MANY MANY PARTNERS.
HERE MANY WHOM AREIN THE ROOM.
AYE WE'RE WE'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR
WHAT WE DON'T CONTROL THE WAY
AND THE PRIVATE LAND WE ARE
RESPONSIBLE TO HELP THOSE
LANDOWNERS WITH THE TOOLS TO GET
THE WORK DONE THROUGH INCENTIVES
AND THROUGH TECHNICAL ADVICE.
THROUGH COLLABORATION.
WITH MANY MANY PARTNERS THE
NGOS AND AND THAT NATURAL
RESOURCE CONSERVATION SERVICE TO
HELP BRING.
BAD LANDOWNER SYSTEMS AND
FEDERAL LANDOWNERS SINCE IT'S
MONEY OUT TO THE TABLE.
WE ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
REGULATING.
THE THE FORCE PRACTICES IN THE
STATE'S A HARVESTING TIMBER
COMMERCIALLY OFF OF PRIVATE
LAND.
THAT YOU KNOW REQUIRES A A
TIMBER HARVEST PLAN AND BE OVER
THERE IS A PROCESS THERE SO
WE'RE CERTAINLY ENGAGED. IN THE
REGULATORY ASPECT BUT IT'S MUCH.
IT'S MUCH BIGGER THAN THAT THE
REAL RESPONSIBILITY IS OUT THERE
TO ENSURE WHAT ARE THE
INCENTIVES HOW DO WE HELP
LANDOWNERS. HELP THEMSELVES.
BECAUSE THE.
WORKING DOING FUELS TREATMENT
ENGAGING IN THE WOODS.
IS COSTLY IT'S TIME CONSUMING.
AND IT REQUIRES UMPS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO INDIA TO MEET
LANDOWNER OBJECTIVES SO THERE
ARE A VARIETY OF TOOLS.
IN THE TOOL BOX TO GET THAT DONE
PRESCRIBED FIRE IS ABSOLUTELY
IMPORTANT THERE. BUT IT'S NOT
THE ONLY TOOL AND IN MANY OF OUR
AREAS OF OUR FORCE CAN'T BE
USED.
WITHOUT FIRST ENGAGING IN OTHER
MECHANICAL TREATMENTS FIRST
BECAUSE THE FIRE THE FORCE ARE
SO OVERGROWN. THAT PUTTING FIRE
EVEN UNDER THE BEST OF
CONDITIONS WILL DESTROY THE
FORCE SO. IT'S A VARIETY OF
TOOLS IT'S THAT THINNING FROM
BELOW TO GET THE DEAD FUELS OUT
FROM OF THE FOR THE UNDERSTOREY
OF THE FORCED. ITS COMMERCIAL
TIMBER HARVESTING BECAUSE PART
OF THIS PROCESS IS ALLOWING
LANDOWNERS TO GET SEPARATE COVER
SOME COST OF DOING THE WORK.
SO GETTING THAT ABOUT THOSE
THOSE THOSE TREES THAT THEY'RE
REMOVING OUGHT TO A MIL TO HELP
GET RECOVERIES THEY CAN REINVEST
THAT. IN MANAGING THEIR FOREST
THE CHALLENGES WE FACE ARE ABOUT
THE ABILITY TO HAVE ENOUGH
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IN THE STATE WOOD PROCESSING
FACILITIES WHETHER IT IS
BIOMASS.
TECH TO GENERATE NEW DABNEY
ELECTRICITY OR HEAT FROM THE BY
PRODUCTS OF OF A FOREST MATERIAL
WHAT'S THE SAWMILLS THEMSELVES
TO ENSURE THERE IS A.
THE APPROPRIATE AMOUNT TO
SUPPORT THE ECONOMY ALL OF THOSE
ARE THINGS THAT ARE THINGS WE
HAVE TO BE LOOKING AT.
AND ENGAGING IN RIGHT NOW FOR
GOING TO REALLY INCREASED THE
PACE AND SCALE. OF OUR
INVESTMENTS IN OUR FORESTS.
LIMON. THANK YOU GET TO SEE YOU
AND AND I I WANNA ALSO ECHO SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT THEY'VE BEEN
GIVING AS A FIRST TERM
LEGISLATOR THERE IS NOTHING LIKE
LEARNING ABOUT FIRES AND NATURAL
DISASTERS LIKE THE CRASH COURSE
THAT AND THINK. THAT THAT I I
LIVED IN WE EXPERIENCED.
AT.
IT IN WERE IN REFLECTING ON AT
THE THOMAS FIRE YOU KNOW WE'VE
WE'VE HAD AND I'VE AND HEARING A
LOT OF CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE
FOREST.
THAT FIRE DID NOT START IN THE
AND.
THAT FIRE STARTED YEAH AND VERY
CLOSE TO OUR URBAN AREA.
AND.
.
IF IT WE IT WITH EVENTUALLY
MOVED TO THE LOS PADRES FOREST
BUT AND IT DIDN'T START THERE
HOW DO WE THINK ABOUT AREAS LIKE
THAT.
AND ARE SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT YOU'RE
SHARING WITH US.
YOU KNOW TRANSFERABLE TO OTHER
AREAS WHERE THE THE START CLOSER
TO OUR CITIES TO OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND THEN THEY KIND OF GET PUSHED
IN THAT DIRECTION FOR REASONS OF
SAFETY.
IS IT IS SOME OF YOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS
SAME ARE THEY.
HE NO DIFFERENT RECOMMENDATIONS
ON HOW WE SHOULD BE THINKING
ABOUT THAT.
VERY GOOD QUESTION SO THE.
THE BASIC PREMISE OF FIRE
PREVENTION AND VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT AND FUELS TREATMENT.
.
APPLIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA'S YOU KNOW IS A VERY
DIVERSE LANDSCAPE. THAT'S
VEGETATION GO WE TALK A LOT
ABOUT ENGAGING IN OUR OUR
FORESTS AND THINNING. IN THE
FORESTED COMMUNITIES.
BUT SO MUCH OF THE STATE IS IN
THE WILD AND URBAN INTERFACE
WERE BLURRED AND THE COMMUNITIES
THAT YOUR TALKING ABOUT WHERE
THE THOMAS FIRE BURNED WHICH.
WASN'T OUT IN A FOREST IT WAS
IAN BRUSH SCRUB.
INTERFACE HOMES AND SO WHILE
WE'RE WE'RE TALKING LESS ABOUT
FOREST THINNING THERE AND FOR IN
ENFORCED RESILIENCE WERE
TALKING.
TRULY THERE ABOUT HOW DO WE
REDUCE FUEL LOADING.
TO REDUCE THE INTENSITY OF
FIRES TO PROTECT HOMES HOW DO
WE.
PUT FIRE PREVENTION PROGRAMS
ARE IN PLACE OR REALLY.
EMPHASIZE THE ONES WE HAVE IN
PLACE WENT TO REDUCE THE NUMBER
A FIRE. PLEASE NINETY FIVE
PERCENT.
OF THE FIRES IN CALIFORNIA ARE
STARTED BY PEOPLE.
FOR A WHOLE HOST OF REASONS IT
YA COME IT THE BOTTOM LINE IS IF
PEOPLE START FIRES WE CAN FIND
WAYS TO. PREVENT THAT YOU KNOW
THROUGH OR REDUCE THOSE STARTS
THROUGH A VARIETY OF PUBLIC
EDUCATION.
LOOKING AT DIFFERENT PRACTICES
SO.
THAT'S A BIG PORTION OF WORKING
IN THE URBAN INTERFACE IS HOW DO
WE LOOK AT WHAT ARE CAUSES OF
FIRES ARE IN THESE AREAS AND AND
REALLY TARGET. A EFFORTS AT
TOWARDS THAT UP TREATING FUELS A
BIG COMPONENT OF THE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION OR CAP AND TRADE.
PROGRAM THIS YEAR IS FOCUSING ON
WHAT WAS FORMERLY THE FIRE
PREVENTION.
FUND AND THAT IS WORKING ON
PROJECTS IN AND AROUND
COMMUNITIES JUST LIKE A IN THE
AREA OF SAN APOLLO IN THOSE
AREAS WHERE THE THOMAS FIRE
STARTED HOW DO WE.
PUTTING FUEL BREAKS HOW DO WE
ENSURE THAT EVERY HOMEOWNER HAS
THEIR DEFENSIBLE SPACE.
AND DEFENSIBLE SPACE DOESN'T
JUST PROTECT THE HOME OR THE
STRUCTURE FROM AN ONCOMING FIRE.
IT ALSO PROTECTS
THE WILD LAND AND OTHER
STRUCTURES FROM A FIRE THAT
STARTS ARE IN YOUR HOME OR A
VEHICLE FIRE. IT MAY OCCUR OFF
TO THE SIDE OF THE ROAD OR SOME
OTHER SOURCE AND SO THE BASIC
PREMISE OF VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
FUELS TREATMENT AND FIRE
PROTECTION.
REALLY APPLIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA IT'S AS WE GET INTO
DIFFERENT FORCED TO COMMUNITIES
DIFFERENT VEGETATION TYPES.
RURAL VERSUS URBAN IT'S HOW WE
APPLY IT AND IT'S BUT THE KINDS
OF PROJECTS THAT WERE DOING.
TO HELP REDUCE FUEL LOADING AND
PROTECT THAT INDUSTRY.
IT IS A QUESTIONS.
MS AGUIAR CURRY PUT I JUST HAVE
ONE CRAP COMMENT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR ALL YOU'VE DONE IT YOU
KNOW EXPENSE. A MS LEHMAN SAID
IT WAS A CATASTROPHIC EVENT THE
BOTH OF US TO HER THOUGHT WE
WOULD BE DEALING WITH. MY
FRUSTRATION WAS DURING THIS TIME
WAS PEOPLE'S LACK OF. PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR TAKING CARE
OF THEIR PROPERTY.
AND.
I THINK.
EDUCATION IS GREAT.
BUT SOMETIMES PEOPLE JUST DON'T
WANT TO DO THAT AND I THINK THAT
ADDED TO SOME OF THE ISSUES AND
HOW THE FIRE WENT THROUGH OUR
AREA BUT. I THINK WE ALL HAVE TO
ADMIT THAT WE'VE GOTTA WORK ON
PERSONAL.
RESPONSIBILITY ON THESE AND SO
I'M HOPING THAT WE CAN.
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO MAKE SURE
THEY CLEAR THEIR AREAS FROM THE
HOUSES.
ABSOLUTELY SPOT ON AND TO OUT
THERE ARE ROUGHLY SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND STRUCTURES
WITHIN THE STATE RESPONSIBILITY
AREA THAT THIRTY ONE MILLION
ACRES THAT CAL FIRE. ALONG WITH
A LOCAL GOVERNMENT PARTNERS
PROTECT.
WE ARE TARGETING TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND INSPECTIONS
PER YEAR SO IT. AT A MINIMUM
EVERY THIRD YEAR WILL BE RE
CONTACTING THE SAME HOMEOWNER
NOW UNDERSTAND THAT. IN SOME
CASES WHERE WE CONTACT IN THE
SAME HOMEOWNER YOU KNOW YEAR
AFTER YEAR BUT WE ARE REALLY
INCREASING NOT JUST PUTTING MORE
FOR PRESCRIBED FIRE ON THE
GROUND AND CHALLENGING OURSELVES
TO DO MORE. WERE ALSO REALLY
CHALLENGING US TO GET OUT AND DO
MORE DEFENSIBLE SPACE
INSPECTIONS TO HAVE THAT
INTERACTION WITH THE HOMEOWNERS
YES WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
PROVIDE CITATIONS OUR GOAL
THOUGH. IS IS TO.
HAVE THEM ALL COMPLIANT AND WE
START WITH EDUCATION BUT WE ARE.
NOT AFRAID TO COME BACK INTO
MULTIPLE INSPECTIONS AND PROVIDE
THEM WITH NOTICE THAT THEY'RE
OUTSIDE OF COMPLIANCE BECAUSE
YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
PROTECTION IT STARTS WITH THE
HOMEOWNERS THE PEOPLE ABOUT
THEIR THEMSELVES.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAU
CHIEF APPRECIATE AS ALWAYS
REPRESENTATION AND LOOK FORWARD
TO DISCUSSING THESE ISSUES WITH
YOU IN MORE DETAIL AS WE MOVE
FORWARD INTO THAT. A BUDGET
HEARINGS AND IF I MAY JUST.
.
THANK YOU AS WELL IN INDICATE TO
THE.
BASED UPON A LOT OF THESE
DISCUSSIONS AND THE TRAUMA OF
HAVING GOT LEARN THIS FIRST
HAND.
RIGHT IN OUR FACES AYE I
INTRODUCED A BILL THIS YEAR S.
B. TWELVE SIXTY IT'S AN OMNIBUS.
TYPE FAR.
.
PREVENTION BILL THAT WE TALK
ABOUT CONTROLLED BURN STANDARDS
AND AIR.
QUALITY OF STANDARDS AND SO
FORTH AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU. AND THE
DEPARTMENT.
AND ALL OF THE RELEVANT
AGENCIES TO TRY TO. UP PUT INTO
SOME POLICY OF IN IN OUR
DISTRICT AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MELONES DISTRICT MIND. IF WE
DON'T PROVIDE THE DEFENSIBLE
SPACE OF A GROUP OF A PAGE. OF
ARBORIST ETCETERA COME INTO OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD AND DO THE WORK FOR
US.
I HAVE TO SAY NOT NECESSARILY AS
WELL AS WE MIGHT LIKE BUT AGAIN
THESE MIGHT BE THINGS WHERE WE
IF WE PROVIDE.
THE.
.
LEGISLATIVE.
AUTHORITY ARE FOR YOU TO DO
THIS WORK US SOMETIMES WE HAVE
TO RECOGNIZE THAT IF ONE PERSON
CHOOSES NOT TO PARTICIPATE. IT
MAY IMPACT OTHER PEOPLE AND SO
THAT THERE IS THAT PUBLIC
RESPONSIBILITY THAT.
WE WEIGH IN THE PROCESS AND I
LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THOSE ISSUES.
THANK YOU THE DEPARTMENT
ADMINISTRATION VERY INTERESTED
INCIDENT OUT ALL OF YOU AND
WE'RE GOING THROUGH THIS IS
CRITICAL AND I JUST WANT TO
CLOSE BY THANKING EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU I KNOW.
BUT IT WAS IT WHERE YOU WANT TO
SPEND YOUR TIME ALL FALL BUT
HAVE THE RELATIONSHIP YOUR
INTERACTION WITH ALL OF US OUT
THERE THE SUPPORT. WAS
PHENOMENAL AND.
WE APPRECIATE THAT VERY.
GREAT THANK YOU AGAIN WE'RE
GONNA PROCEED NOW WITH PANEL
NUMBER TWO.
WE HAVE.
CUT TWO PANELS AND THEN AFTER.
CAR AYE AYE AFTER AFTER OUR
THIRD PANEL ACTUALLY WE WILL.
ENTERTAIN PUBLIC COMMENT.
SO I'D LIKE TO ASK A MARK
GILLARD YUCHI THE DIRECTOR
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES STEP FORWARD AS WELL AS
CAN TO ROSE OUR CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF RESOURCES
RECYCLING IN RECOVERY. AND
DOCTOR JOHN PARRIS THE STATE
GEOLOGIST WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSERVATION AND I BELIEVE EACH
OF YOU HAVE A. PRESENTATION TO
MAKE.
NO.
WELCOME EVERYONE OKAY BOOK GOOD
MORNING.
CHERRY BLOOMING.
CHERYL AND JACKSON THE REST OF
THE JOINT COMMITTEE GREAT TO BE
WITH YOU THIS MORNING AND. ALL I
THINK FROM VERMONT OF WHICH ARE
MY STAMP Y. THAT THAT'S GOING TO
BE SEVERAL LEGISLATIVE HEARINGS
OUT OVER THE COURSE OF THE
COMING WEEKS THAT ARE GOING TO
BE. GOING OVER A LOT OF DETAIL
REGARDING THE RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY.
FROM THESE VARIOUS CATASTROPHIC
GOT WILDFIRES BUT.
TODAY I WANTED TO TALK A LITTLE
ABOUT.
HAD TARGET SOME OF THE RECOVERY
OPERATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN GOING
ON BECAUSE THEY THEY ARE
DIRECTLY RELATE TO THE GREAT
WORK THAT.
OUR PARTNERS AT CAL RECYCLE AND
I CALIFORNIA GEOLOGIC SURVEY AND
ID TNC HAVE DONE. ALL AS WELL AS
CAL FIRE IN MAKING SURE THAT WE.
OF APPROACH ALL OF THESE EVENTS
AND REALLY I AS I SAY A ONE TEAM
ONE FIGHT EFFORT AND.
AND I COULDN'T BE MORE PROUD OR
AND AND AND APPRECIATIVE OF ALL
THE WORK THAT.
THESE ORGANIZATIONS HAVE DONE.
BOB I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT START
OFF THE THE TO REMIND FOLKS THAT
YOU KNOW WHILE WE HAD THESE
FIRES.
THAT THAT STARTED POT WE
ACTUALLY WE'RE DEALING WITH
MULTIPLE WINTER STORM. AYE
DISASTERS.
IN JANUARY AND FEBRUARY WHICH
ACTUALLY RESULTED IN FOUR
SEPARATE PRESIDENTIAL DISASTER
DECLARATIONS AND IN FACT WE
WERE.
REALLY DALY WITHOUT WITH MAJOR
RECOVERY OPERATIONS IN FIFTY OF
THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA WHEN THESE.
FIRE VENTS HAPPENED IN OCTOBER.
IT'S ALSO STAGGERING TO
UNDERSTAND THAT REALLY IN THE
COURSE OF A FOUR MONTH PERIOD
STARTING AROUND.
DEL OCTOBER EIGHTH.
WE A IN CALIFORNIA LOST.
OF A LITTLE OVER ELEVEN
THOUSAND HOMES AND BUSINESSES
ARE IN THAT PERIOD OF TIME WHICH
REALLY SORTS OF FRAMES.
THAT THAT THE COMPLEXITY AND
THE AND THE EXTREMELY OF OF
THESE EVENTS.
.
AND SO ARE GOING TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT TODAY.
I WANNA START OFF BEFORE I GET
INTO THE RECOVERY JUST
HIGHLIGHTING A FEW NUMBERS FOR
YOU ALL WHICH I THINK IS. IS
INTERESTING TO NOTE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
OBVIOUSLY WE KNOW THE NUMBER.
WAS STAGGERING GOT CLOSE TO
EIGHTY NINE HUNDRED STRUCTURES
THAT WERE YOU THERE RIDE DAMAGED
OR DESTROYED THAT'S THAT'S HOMES
AND BUSINESSES.
HERE THERE WERE OVER TWENTY
FOUR WAS THE TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS WHO
REGISTERED FOR ASSISTANCE IN
NOW.
AND IN THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
BAND OVER CLOSER SIXTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS AND.
IN.
AYE INDIVIDUAL ASSISTANCE
SUPPORT FUNDING WAS WAS PROVIDED
TO THESE INDIVIDUALS UP FOR
VARIOUS REASONS ARE AND AND AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN HOUSING ASSISTANCE WHETHER IT
WAS A DIRECT LEASE HOUSING OR.
GET GETTING THEM INTO SOME SORT
OF HOTEL OR LONG TERM IN TERM
SORT OF SOLUTION.
WHICH IS STILL AN ONGOING
PROCESS TODAY.
AS WE WORK THROUGH THAT.
SP A.
PROVIDED.
THROUGH COORDINATED EFFORTS.
BETWEEN THE STATE OPERATIONS
CENTER IN AND OUT AND FEE ABOUT
A CLOSE TO A HUNDRED AND FORTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS. IN GRANTS.
AND LOANS TO.
BUSINESSES WITHIN THE AREA ARM
AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE.
OPERATIONS ESTABLISHED.
IN VARIOUS.
FAIRGROUNDS AND OTHER KINDS OF
SITES WERE REPORTING AND.
LA MOBILE HOME UNITS OR.
RECREATIONAL VEHICLES SOMETHING
LIKE ACTION OF A FIFTH WHEEL OR
TRAVEL TRAILER.
TO GET PEOPLE INTO THESE.
INTERIM HOUSING ARE IN IT IN AN
AREA NORTH OF CALIFORNIA THAT.
REALLY WAS LESS THAN ONE
PERCENT OF HOUSING AVAILABILITY
PRIOR TO THE FIRE HAPPENING SO
REALLY PRESENTED A SERIES OF.
OF CHALLENGES FOR US IN NORTHERN
AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. OF
COURSE A ANOTHER SERIES OF
EVENTS.
TOOK PLACE.
ALSO RESULTED IN OF OF
PRESIDENTIAL DISASTER
DECLARATION.
RESULTING IN CLOSE TO FOUR
THOUSAND AYE IT CALIFORNIANS IN
THIS OUT SOUTH REGISTERING.
CLOSE TO FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
IN.
INDIVIDUAL ASSISTANCE
DISBURSEMENT AND OVER TWO
MILLION DOLLARS AND HOUSING.
ASSISTANCE ARE ROUGHLY TWENTY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN S. B. A.
SO THERE'S A LOT OF THERE'S A
LOT OF THINGS IN RECOVERY AYE WE
SAY THAT THE RECOVERY YOU KNOW
IS RESPONSIBLE COVER REALLY
BEGINS TO GATHER WHAT WE HAVE TO
BEGIN THINKING ABOUT WHAT THE.
RECOVERY LOOKS LIKE IMMEDIATELY
WHILE WE'RE STILL DEALING WITH
THE RESPONSE A CHEAP PEN WHAT
THAT A GREAT JOB IN TALKING
ABOUT. THE FACT THAT WE APPROACH
CALIFORNIA IT THROUGH A UNIFIED
COORDINATION GROUP ARE AND AND
THE LEADERS OF OF THE PUBLIC
SAFETY ENTITIES COMING TOGETHER
AS AS ONE TEAM. OUGHT TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THESE THINGS EARLY ON
AND PUT OUR METRICS IN PLACE TO
ENSURE THAT WE'VE GOT A GOOD
PATHWAY. PERSISTS FOR SUCCESS IN
THE FUTURE.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU THAT DOUBT
WE WERE CHECKED HIT WITH SOME
EXTREMELY CHALLENGING SITUATION
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA FIRES. OUT
WITH SOMETHING LIKE WE HAD NOT
SEEN.
TO THE DEGREE IF THE SKY THE
SCALE THE SCOPE. ARE OUT OF AN
EVENT.
AND AND THESE THIS THIS AMOUNT
OF DEBRIS ARE AND WE KNOW THAT
TACTIC BEGIN THAT RECOVERY
PROCESS ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS
WE NEED TO DO IS WE NEED TO GET
THE DEBRIS CLEARED OUT OF A
COMMUNITY THAT'S THAT'S. GOTTA
BE JOB ONE AS WELL AS GETTING
PEOPLE INTO OF OBVIOUSLY.
SAFE AND SECURE OUR HOUSING SO.
BUT WHEN YOUR WEIGHT WEIGHT
WHEN YOU'RE FACED WITH THE
AMOUNT OF UP OF BOB BLOCKS THAT
WE WE WERE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
IT WAS A COMPLEX DOT BEING. CAST
IT WASN'T JUST IN US AND AU MA
MENDOCINO OR LAKE IN NAPA BUT WE
ALSO WERE AND YUBA. NEVADA.
BUTTE AND PLOW SIR AND SO OUR
ROLE.
IT'S PART OF THE DEFY
COORDINATION GROUP AT THE STATE
OPERATIONS CENTER WAS TO MAKE A
STRATEGIC DECISION ON HOW BEST
WE COULD COLLECTIVELY EAT THIS
ELEPHANT AS A WHOLE. AND BEING
ABLE TO GO IN AND RAPIDLY MOVE
FORWARD TO DEAL WITH.
THE DEBRIS CLEARANCE HOW EARLY
ON I SET SOME RELATIVELY.
STRINGENT.
METRICS THAT THAT WE WANTED TO
GET THESE COMMUNITIES CLEANED UP
TURNED TO OUR PARTNERS A CAL
RECYCLE.
CAO RECYCLE AND DEPARTMENT
TALKED ACCEPTED PATROL.
HAVE BEEN PHENOMENAL OUR
PARTNERS AND WE ASK THEM TO DO A
LOT.
IN BEING ABLE TO GO OUT AND AND
WORK ON DEBRIS OCCURRENCE
OPERATIONS.
NINETY PERCENT OF THE FIRES THAT
WE DEAL WITH THAT THAT RESULT IN
STRUCTURAL LOSS IN THE STATE.
THAT ARE BEYOND THE CAPABILITY
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT BUT BELOW
THE ABILITY TO GET FEDERAL
ASSISTANCE FALL WHAT I CALL
TWEETERS IT'S A STATE
RESPONSIBILITY. AND SO WE TURN
TO CAL RECYCLE A LOT TO GO UP
AND DOWN THE STATE TO DO THESE
DEBRIS CLEARANCE OPERATIONS.
UP WE MADE THE DETERMINATION
THAT WE WOULD SPLIT.
THE REQUIREMENTS AND DOWN THE
NORTHERN.
COUNTIES OF OF OF BEAUTY AND.
AYE NEVADA AND YUBA IMPOSTER
WOULD BE HANDLED BY IDT S. IN
CAL RECYCLE AND THE OTHER
COUNTIES.
AND.
SONO MOB. LAKE NAPA AND
MENDOCINO WE WOULD TURN TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND HAVE
FEMALE TASK THE U. S. ARMY CORPS
OF ENGINEERS. TO BRING IT
RESOURCES UNDER THEIR CONTRACTS
TO BE ABLE TO TO.
BEGIN THAT PROCESS WE WOULD SET
THE METRICS IN THE REQUIREMENTS
AND THAT WE WOULD WORK TOGETHER.
BUT ALL THROUGH THAT PROCESS OUT
BY REPRESENTATIVES OF OF OUR
COUNTY CYCLE IN THE TNC WORK
CLOSELY WITH ALLIES.
AND THE COURT ENGINEERS TO SET
THE REQUIREMENTS EVERYTHING FROM
CONTRACTING TO.
STANDARDS AND REQUIREMENTS THAT
NEEDED TO BE MET BUT DTS SEE.
AND THEIR PARTNER A U. S. EPA I
HAD THE RESPONSIBILITY OF GOING
IN AND CLEARING OUT ALL OF. THE
HOUSEHOLD HAZARDOUS WASTE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT PAINS AND
PESTICIDES AND PROPANE AND ALL
THIS KIND OF STUFF. THAT NEED TO
BE CLEAR BEFORE WE COULD
ACTUALLY BEGIN THE DEBRIS
OPERATION THAT IN ITSELF WAS A
MONUMENTAL TASK.
FOLLOWING THAT WE RAPIDLY MOVED
IN TO START THE DEBRIS
OPERATIONS AND AND. I CAN WILL
TALK A BIT ABOUT HOW HOW THEY
GOT THE THAT THEY DID THAT.
.
AND YOU KNOW A REALLY IN NAM IN
THE CASE OF OUR.
OF YOU BUT A BUTTE NEVADA.
OVER SIXTY THREE THOUSAND TONS
OF DEBRIS WILL OVERHAUL THE WAY.
IN THE SHORT TIME FRAME THAT
THEY THAT THEY HAVE THE RESPONSE
WE NEEDED TO DO THAT. ARM AND A
LEG UP NAPA SONOMA MENDOCINO
WE'RE STILL WORKING ON THAT THE
PRECLEARANCE I HAVE A GRAPHIC
HERE THAT. I WANT TO SHOW YOU
THAT. REALLY SOME OF THE PICS.
.
THE.
I COME TO TALK ABOUT IT IN
NUMBERS IF YOU LOOK AT THIS.
THIS GRAPHIC YOU CAN SEE THAT.
MORE THAN ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION TONS OF DEBRIS HAS BEEN
REMOVED. THAT EQUALS ALMOST ONE
AND ALL WILL THAT MORE THAN HALF
OF. US SECOND GOLDEN GATE BRIDGE
HE PUTS IT IN THE CONTEXT OF HOW
MUCH DEBRIS WERE ACTUALLY
MOVING.
UP THROUGHOUT THE THE.
.
FIVE COUNTY AREA AND.
THIS EFFORT HAS BEEN REALLY.
OR NOW SEVENTY NINE PERCENT
COMPLETE WE'RE GONNA MEET THE
METRIC THAT WE'VE SET FORTH. AND
IT IS NOT BEEN WITHOUT. ON A
SERIES OF CHALLENGES AND AND
DOW.
AND THAT WHAT I CALL LABOR OF
LOVE.
TO BE ABLE TO GET THAT THAT
THAT CHART DOESN'T COMPUTE FOR
ME CAN YOU TELL ME HOW MANY
SANTA MONICA APPEARS THAT WOULD
PAY.
I'M SORRY THAT'S A GOOD THAT'S A
GOOD.
I WILL I'LL MAKE ONE FOR YOU.
THAT'S ESTA.
.
SO.
TO THE STATE OVER FORTY HUNDRED
PROPERTIES HAVE BEEN CLEARED.
THERE'S THERE'S A LESS THAN A
THOUSAND REMAINING A LEGACY
SEVENTY NINE PERCENT AND THIS IS
BUT PROBABLY ONE OF THE MOST
COMPLEX.
AND CHALLENGING DEBRIS
OPERATIONS WE FAX CERTAINLY BEEN
THE BIGGEST TO PRE OPERATION
THAT CALIFORNIA'S HAD SINCE
SINCE THE NINETEEN OH SIX
EARTHQUAKE AND OUT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THAT THE REQUIREMENT OF
REMOVING DEBRIS. I CAN'T SAY
ENOUGH ABOUT THE PARTNERSHIPS
WITH OUR UP WITH WITH ALL OF
YOU.
OUR STATE LEGISLATORS OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
I EVERYBODY COMING TOGETHER.
IN THAT PLENTY ONE FIGHT EFFORT.
IT WAS REALLY THE BEST OF
CALIFORNIA.
.
SO.
THAT'S KIND OF A RAP ON THAT ON
THE ON THE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THAT AND.
HOW WE WILL WE WILL CONTINUE TO
PUSH FORWARD?
AND WE WILL ALSO MAKE SURE THAT
DOWN I MEAN I I'M HAPPY TO SAY
THAT IN COFFEE PARK.
THEIR ARTIST THEY'RE PUTTING
STICKS UP THERE THEY'RE BUILDING
THE HOMES ALREADY IN IN THAT
AREA AND THAT IS REALLY A
PHENOMENAL THING.
THEN IN NOW IN DECEMBER OF
COURSE SUCH A PADLOCK TALKED
ABOUT THE FIRES IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN FACT WELL WE WERE
AS CHEAP THAT MUCH SAID TO HIM
AND I WERE WERE TESTIFYING IN IN
FRONT OF A HEARING WITH SENATOR
JACKSON.
WHEN WHEN THAT NIGHT THE FIRES
BROKE OUT IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND WE LEFT THE HEARING AND HAD
A FEW HOURS HERE AND THAT WE
WERE ANA. HELICOPTER SOUTH.
TO BE ABLE DO THAT FOR THE NEXT
SEVERAL DAYS AND OUR.
THE FIRE WEATHER CONDITIONS
LOOK UNPRECEDENTED WE WERE
ROUGHLY THE MAJORITY OF THE
STATE WAS UNDER RED FLAG
CONDITIONS. ARE REQUIRED AS TO
ACTUALLY PROMPTED AS ACTUALLY
PUT A.
UNDERWEAR MESSAGE OUT TO TWELVE
MILLION PEOPLE IN THE EIGHT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COUNTIES.
TO TO BE AWARE.
OF THE CONDITIONS BUT IN
REALITY WE HAD FIRES THAT BROKE
OUT IN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
THREATENING THE GETTY AND AND
PARTS AT UCLA.
AND LA COUNTY NINE CA DIEGO.
INVENTOR AND OF COURSE IN SANTA
BARBARA. AND.
THAT THAT ALL OF ALL THOSE
FIRES THE BIGGEST UP OBVIOUSLY
IT WAS THE THOMAS FIRE AND.
IT WAS IT'S THE BIGGEST NOW TO
DATE IN THE STATE'S HISTORY.
ARE ALL OF THOSE OF COURSE
RESULTED IN AYE AYE AN
ADDITIONAL. FIFTEEN HUNDRED OR
SO STRUCTURES LOST.
IN ALL OF THOSE FIRES AND UP
AND AGAIN WE WE WERE LOOKING AT
THE.
AT THE TIME REALLY THE FOCUS
WAS IT SAN DIEGO COUNTY WAS.
WAS WHAT WAS VERY WELL
EXPERIENCE BUT THE NUMBER
STRUCTURES THEY WERE GOING TO
HANDLE THEIR OWN.
WORKING WITH EYES.
TO BE ABLE TO DO THEIR DEBRIS.
OPERATIONS BUT DEVON TARA.
WAS A BIT MORE UP COMPLEX AND
AND.
AND AND.
WAS A HEAVY LIFT FOR THEM AND
SO IN THIS CASE AGAIN WE TURN TO
CAL RECYCLING DTS SEE. ARE AND
THEY MOVE FORWARD TO A RAPIDLY
MOVE FORWARD I WOULD SAY.
TO TO JUMP IN AND BEGIN THE
PROCESS AND TO THIS DAY.
CAO RECYCLE IS HANDLING THE.
DEBRIS REMOVAL INVENT BETTER
COUNTY.
SIX HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX
PARCELS HAVE BEEN APPROVED AND
AND.
DATA I'LL CLOSE TO TWO HUNDRED
UP PARCELS ARE ALREADY COMPLETE
AND THAT. THERE'S ANOTHER CHART
HERE THAT THE TALKS ABOUT SOME
OF THE COMPLEX IS ONE IS THE.
MOST THESE HOMES THE MIDDLE
PARTICULARLY THE PIT DEPENDING
IF THEY'RE THEY'RE BUILT BEFORE
NINETEEN EIGHTY HAVE ASBESTOS
ARE PROBLEMS AND THAT'S PROBABLY
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE NEED
TO. TAKE THE CLEAR THROUGH ITS
NOT JUST MOVING HOUSE WILL HOW
DOES WASTE BUT IT'S CLAIMING
THAT IT'S BEST IS BEFORE WE CAN
MOVE IN AND EVERY MOVE THOSE
THOSE.
BUT THE BRIE.
AND.
AND AND THIS CHART DISH JUST
REITERATE WHAT I SAID ABOUT THE
THE NUMBER OF PARCELS APPROVED
AND THE NUMBER.
THAT HAVE BEEN A COMPLETE AND
END UP AGAIN THE METRICS THERE.
ARE THAT.
THERE THAT THIS WILL BE
COMPLETE AND AND PROBABLY EARLY
APRIL AND DOW AT THIS POINT.
EVERYTHING IS IN IN LINE TO
COMPLETE THOSE.
METRICS.
THEN OF COURSE.
.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE THAT LAST BIG
PUSH A FIRE ACTIVITY. ON THE
THOMAS FIRE AND I MEMBER THAT
WEEKEND.
WAS VERY.
VERY STRESSFUL WHEN THE WHOLE
STATE WAS REALLY IN THIS RED
FLAG AND.
THE FIRE CAME DOWN VERY CLOSE
INTO IMPACT PART SOME OF MODEST
YOU KNOW IN IN SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY AND AND.
BURNED COMPLETELY AROUND ALL
HIGH AND IT WAS REALLY IF YOU
KNOW PHENOMENAL FIREFIGHT THAT
TOOK PLACE.
THE FIRE FIGHTERS AND AND
PUBLIC SAFETY PERSONNEL
LAFORTUNE PHENOMENAL JOB.
THE PROBLEM WAS IS THAT.
THE AREA ABOVE SANTA BARBARA.
WHICH IS MOSTLY LOS PADRES
NATIONAL FOREST LIBERTY WAS
DENUDED OF ALL WATERSHED.
AND THAT SET UP A DYNAMIC.
THAT IF IT WE HAD ANY RAIN.
ALL OF THAT ALL OF THAT THAT.
THE BREED IT WAS THERE THAT ASH
THAT THAT AND THE EXPOSURE OF
THE MY WITH NO WATERSHED TO
CAPTURE WATER. COULD RESULT IN.
CATASTROPHIC FLOODING.
NOW.
WE KNEW THIS AND.
CALIFORNIA GEOLOGIC SURVEY THE
U. S. G. S. CAL FIRE A NUMBER OF
OTHER. ORGANIZATIONS.
CAO POINT PART OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE ALL COMING TOGETHER.
COORDINATED THROUGH THE STATE
OPERATIONS CENTER TO GO IN AND
DO ASSESSMENTS
BEFORE.
BUT ANY FLOODING PARTICULAR
PLACE TO IDENTIFY AREAS OF HIGH
RISK.
WHERE DOT WE ANTICIPATED HOW IT
IN PLANNING TO BOB BE ADVANCED
AND AND PREPARE FOR THAT?
AND IN FACT.
YOU HOPE THAT NO RAIN HAPPENS
COURSE YOU KNOW HOW MURPHY IS.
WE WHAT WHAT HAPPENS A STORM
BREWS HAVE HAD A STORM IT'S AT A
BARBER IN.
A SUPER LONG TIME EXCEPT NOW
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A STORM IN
SANTA BARBARA AND IT'S GOT A
TARGET RIGHT ABOVE MINE ACETO.
SO YOU CAN'T. YOU CAN'T MAKE
THIS STUFF UP SO.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS.
IT DIDN'T TAKE MUCH IT SHOULD
HAVE FOR TWO INCHES OF RAIN. AND
THAT RESULTED IN AND WHAT WE
HAVE NOT SEEN IN CALIFORNIA
BEFORE.
BUT A CATASTROPHIC MUD FLOWS
ARE OF SUCH PROPORTION.
THAT.
IT IT IT LITERALLY TOOK OUT.
LARGE SWATHS OF OF THE SEA AT
THE COUNT OF MANSIO.
AND AND RESTRUCTURE PROPERTY
LINES AND RESTRUCTURED.
THAT.
LAND DEMOGRAPHICS.
HUGE BOULDERS AND OTHER KINDS
DEPRECIABLE TWENTY FEET HIGH
TREASON SECTOR TAKING OUT HOMES
AS THEY COME CAME DOWN AND
UNFORTUNATELY. TAKING OUT ARE A
NUMBER OF LIVES.
AND.
IT IN THIS AGAIN RESULTED IN
AGAIN ONE OF ICE I SAY IT WAS
VERY COMPLEX AND AND
UNPRECEDENTED IN THE NORTHERN
FIRES WE ARE NOW IF WE WERE NOW
FACING ANOTHER UNPRECEDENTED UP
COMPLEX.
SET OF.
DEBRIS OPERATIONS WITH THIS MOD.
THE KEY THING HERE WAS THAT
DUMB.
YOU KNOW WE NEEDED TO WRITTEN
WE NEED IT TO WE WERE CONCERNED
ABOUT A SECOND STORM.
AND SO WHAT HAPPENED IS THE
CREEKS AND THE AND THE DEBRIS
BASIS HAD COME BECOME. TOTALLY
FALL AND SO WE CAN TURN TO THE
ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS UP
BECAUSE OF THEIR CONTRACT
CAPABILITY.
DTS HE WAS ALREADY GONE AND OUT
COVER CYCLE COMMITTED INVENTOR
UP.
AND WE WE TURN TO THE CORE TUBE
TO BRING IN THEIR CONTRACTORS
AND TO IMMEDIATELY START WORKING
ON THOSE TO PRE BASES WE WHAT WE
KNEW THAT IF WE HAD ANOTHER
STORM WE NEED TO LEAST GET.
THOSE THOSE THE BASINS CLEARING
THOSE CREEKS CLEAR TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE THE ROLE THAT THE RIGHT
OFF.
AND SO WE IDENTIFIED ELEVEN A
DEBRIS BASINS.
AND DUCKED AND THE TO DATE TEN
OF THOSE LAWS HAVE BEEN CLEARED.
ARM AND WE ALSO IDENTIFIED.
TEN A CREEK SYSTEMS AND FIVE OF
THOSE TEN CREEKS HAVE BEEN.
CLEARED THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE.
YOU KNOW THERE THERE THERE
THERE IS A LOT MORE DEBRIS IT'S
SITTING ABOVE MONNA SETO GOD YET
TO COME DOWN AND SO WHAT WE WERE
WE WERE REALLY RAPIDLY.
MOVING FORWARD TO GET THAT THAT
DONE.
AND.
WORKING WITH ALL THE STATE
LOCAL AND FEDERAL AGENCIES AND
EVEN PRIVATE SECTOR.
TO MAKE THIS ALL COME TOGETHER
SO YOU CAN SORT OF IMAGINE.
THAT.
AT ONE TIME WE HAVE WE
COLLECTIVELY.
MANAGING THREE YOU KNOW
CATASTROPHIC EVENTS IN THREE
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE STATE.
AND.
IT.
ALL OF THIS ACTIVITY THAT'S BEEN
DONE THE HOUSING THE DEBRIS THE
DEBRIS OPERATIONS GETTING ALL
THE SWEET WE SORT OF ALLIES HAVE
HAVE ALL BEEN DONE IN IN A FIVE
MONTH PERIOD AND DOUBT. I KNOW
WE ALL WORKING GOVERNMENT.
SO YOU CAN UNDERSTAND THAT.
THAT.
THAT THAT'S HARD TO REALLY SORT
OF COMPREHENSION BUT.
BUT IT IS SOMETHING THAT.
CAN BE DONE AND.
IT'S IT'S BASED UPON.
A COLLABORATIVE A COORDINATED
APPROACH OF GREAT GREAT
RESOURCES AREN'T WILLING TO.
TO FIGHT THE FIGHT. ARE SO
WITHOUT I THINK I'LL STOP HERE
AND.
ALTERNATE OVER TO CAN AND YOU
CAN FOLLOW UP WITH ANY
ADDITIONAL IF.
THANK YOU I THINK YOU IF I COULD
JUST TAKE A MOMENT TO BOOT UP OF
A POLICE STATION.
AND MAYBE I COULD THANK YOU.
GREAT HERE WE ARE.
AND THIS WORKS.
WE'RE GONNA FIND OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS ON A.
KENDIRAS OF WITH A CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR RECOVER CYCLE.
.
I AM VERY GRATEFUL TO DIRECTOR
GIL OUR DUTY AND IS AND IS NOT A
COMMENTS AND I WILL. ECHO SOME
OF THE SENTIMENTS OF.
THE EXTRAORDINARY COLLABORATION
COOPERATION WITH.
HELLO YES AND OTHER PARTNER
AGENCIES I'M AS I GO THROUGH.
MY PRESENTATION MY INTENT TODAY
IS TO TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT OPERATIONALLY WHAT WE DO
YOU FOR A GREAT DEAL ABOUT
NUMBERS AND METRICS.
BUT I DON'T THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND OUR PROCESS
AND WHAT'S INVOLVED. IN THE
DEBRIS REMOVAL OPERATION.
AND SORT OF OUR OPERATING
PRINCIPLES IN DOING THAT BUT
ALSO OUR FOCUS AND WHAT WE'RE
REALLY TRYING TO DO ON THROUGH
OUR THROUGH A PROCESS.
SO. PURSUANT TO.
GOVERNOR'S PROCLAMATION THE
STATE EMERGENCY IT ESSENTIALLY
IS AS NECESSARY TO ASSIST LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND PROTECTION PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
SAFETY AND AND YOU'RE GONNA HEAR
ME REFERENCE THAT NUMEROUS
TIMES.
WE ARE TASKED WITH ARRANGING FOR
MATERIALS AND SERVICES AND AND
BASICALLY PROVIDING RESOURCES TO
REMOVE DANGEROUS DEBRIS.
THAT MISSION IS TO PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY FROM
THE IMPACTS OF ASH DEBRIS AND
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS IN HEARD OF
SOME OF WHAT THAT IS.
WHEN A FIRE OCCURS WHEN A
STRUCTURE IS BURNED.
LEAD IS RELEASED MERCURY RICH IS
RELEASED AND THEN THERE'S ALSO A
LOT OF RELEASE OF MATERIALS THAT
EXIST WITHIN THE SOILS
UNDERNEATH THAT PARCEL.
.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUILAR CURIE.
REPRESENTING LAKE YOU
UNDERSTAND ALL TOO WELL.
FOR FIRES IN TWO YEARS AND AND
WE'VE STRUGGLED OFTEN.
AND IN THOSE CLEANUPS BECAUSE OF
ARSENIC AND LEAD AND MERCURY AND
OTHER CAN HEAVY METALS THAT REST
WITHIN THAT SOIL BECAUSE OF THE
HISTORY OF MINING.
AND THE HISTORY OF OFTEN
BUILDING ON TOP OF OLD BURN.
FROM DECADES PAST.
THAT COMES UP TO THE SURFACE.
WE NEED TO REACH A BACKGROUND
LEVEL WE NEED TO RESTORE A SAFE
PROPERTY A SAFE COMMUNITY BACK
TO THOSE RESIDENTS.
AND SO WE ARE ALSO VERY MUCH A
TASK WITH ADDRESSING THAT BUT
ALSO HELPING TO FACILITATE
ACCELERATE THE RECOVERY PROCESS.
PROVIDING THE MEANS BY WHICH
COMMUNITIES CAN BEGIN TO TO
REBUILD.
TO THAT POINT.
I WAS THAT I WAS INVENTORY LAST
WEEK ATTENDED AN ALL HANDS
MEETING OF OF THREE HUNDRED CREW
THREE HUNDRED LABORS.
WHO ARE OUT THERE DOING IT?
AND I ASKED THEM YOU KNOW WHY DO
AND THE RESPONSE.
ENTHUSIASTICALLY FROM THE THE
CRUISE WAS WE ARE REBUILDING
COMMUNITY.
AND I THINK THAT THAT'S THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT.
WE WE DON'T OFTEN HEAR ABOUT.
COMPASSION AND EMPATHY FROM
GOVERNMENT BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT UNDERSTAND THAT THE
LEVEL OF COMPASSION AND HUMANITY
THAT WE TRY AND BRING TO THIS TO
HELP REBUILD THESE LIVES.
SO.
MY APOLOGIES TO DOCTOR PARISH
FOR NOT INCLUDING.
BUT THE DEPARTMENT CONSERVATION
ON THIS LIST BUT.
YOU HEARD DIRECTOR KILLERS EACH
ONE TEAM ONE FIGHT NOTHING
THAT'S VERY MUCH HOW THIS
HAPPENS.
IT'S WITH OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS
IT'S WITH LOCAL PARTNERS
REALLY EMPOWERING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO TO BE TO BE IN
THE DRIVER'S SEAT ON HOW THIS
WORKS WORKING WITH TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS AND TRIBAL LIAISONS
AND TRIBAL MONITORS TO MAKE SURE
THAT AS PART OF OUR RECOVERY.
OPERATION WE ARE NOT DISTURBING
SACRED SITES AND WE ARE MANAGING
THOSE SITES AS EFFECTIVELY AS
POSSIBLE LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS
LOCAL ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES SOLID
WASTE ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
HELPING US IDENTIFY LANDFILLS
WHERE MATERIAL CAN GO. AND THEN
A HOST OF STATE PARTNERS
CALLAWAY YES KELLY PA.
NOT ENOUGH CAN BE SAID.
ABOUT THE LEADERSHIP THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL HAS DEMONSTRATED THEY
HAVE SET THE PACE IN THE OF SET
THE TONE FOR THE HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS HERE. AND AND I I'M
I'M GRATEFUL TO HEAR FROM OTHERS
THAT THAT THAT IS BEING
ACKNOWLEDGED.
OUR FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES AT
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE FOR
HELPING US TO FINANCE ALL OF
THIS.
SO.
WE CONDUCT THIS UNDER THREE
INTERTWINED OPERATING
PRINCIPLES.
THE FIRST IS SAFETY.
ENSURING THE CREWS ENSURING OUR
TEAMS ENSURING THE RESIDENTS AND
THE COMMUNITIES.
THEIR SAFETY IS PARAMOUNT DURING
AND AFTER OPERATIONS AND I'M
GONNA SHOW YOU SEVERAL OF IMAGES
FROM WORK THAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW INVENTORY WHICH HELPS
DEMONSTRATE THIS POINT.
THE SECOND OPERATING PRINCIPLE
IS DOCUMENTATION.
IMMEDIATELY ONCE WHERE TASK AND
ONCE WE MOBILIZE.
THE FIRST THING THAT WE DO IS
ASSESS WE DOCUMENT THE SITES WE
HAVE A CONTRACTOR WHO GOES OUT
MEASURES THE SIZE OF THE PARCELS
BEGINS TO LOOK AT THE TYPES OF
DEBRIS THAT IS THAT IS THERE. TO
HELP US UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH A VERY DETAILED
LEVEL. AND THEY ALSO CONDUCT THE
FIELD MONITORING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE TONNAGES THAT ARE
COMING OUT ARE WELL DOCUMENTED
THIS IS FOR FISCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY BUT IT'S ALSO FOR
OPERATIONAL ACCOUNTABILITY SO
THAT WHEN UP A RESIDENT RETURNS
WHEN WE RETURN THAT PROPERTY TO
THE COUNTY.
THAT WE'VE DEMONSTRATED WHAT IT
IS WE WERE SUPPOSED TO DO AND WE
HAVE VALIDATED THAT WE HAVE DID
INDEED DO THAT. LASTLY A
COMMUNICATION WITH THE RESIDENTS
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WITH OUR
PARTNER AGENCIES AND WITHIN THE
TEAMS TO MAINTAIN AWARENESS AND
PROBLEM SOLVE SO THAT EVERYBODY
IS FUNCTIONING IN A SAFE. AND
ENGAGED ENVIRONMENT.
SO.
THERE'S A PRE PLANNING THAT GOES
ON ONCE WHERE TASK THERE'S AN
ACTIVE AND ONGOING ENGAGEMENT
WITH HELLO YES PART OF THAT IS
DOING THE PRELIMINARY
ASSESSMENT.
IS UNDERSTANDING WHAT WE'RE
FACING HOW MANY POTENTIAL
PARCELS WHERE THEY ARE SOME OF
THE GEOGRAPHY THAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH AND AGAIN IN THE IMAGES
YOU'RE ABOUT TO SEE. A LITTLE
LATER IN THIS PRESENTATION
YOU'LL GET A SENSE OF
COMPLICATED GEOGRAPHY THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH INVENTORY.
ITS DIALOGUE IN COLLABORATION
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS LETTING
THEM KNOW WHAT IT IS WE'RE GOING
TO DO IN HELPING TO EMPOWER THEM
TO TAKE LEADERSHIP ROLES. THEY
ARE ACTUALLY PART OF THE FACE OF
OUR OPERATION AT THE DEBRIS
REMOVAL OPERATIONS CENTER
SOMEONE A RESIDENT WALKS INTO
SUBMIT A RIGHT OF ENTRY FORM
WHICH I'LL EXPLAIN IN A MOMENT.
THEY SEE SOMEONE FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CITY OR COUNTY THAT
WALKS THEM THROUGH THE PROCESS
ON TO HELP THEM UNDERSTAND WHAT
THEY'RE SIGNING UP FOR WHEN THEY
SIGNED UP FOR THIS VOLUNTARY
PROGRAM.
WE CONDUCT COMMUNITY MEETINGS WE
GO OUT AND MEET WITH SURVIVORS
PEOPLE WHO.
HAVE LOST EVERYTHING AND WE
ENGAGE DIRECTLY WITH THEM TO
HEAR ABOUT THEIR PROPERTIES TO
ANSWER THEIR QUESTIONS ABOUT OUR
PROGRAM. AND TO STAY FOR HOURS
AFTERWARDS TO TALK WITH
INDIVIDUALS LOOKING AT THEIR
PHOTOS YOU KNOW HERE'S MY
SITUATION HERE'S MY RETAINING
WALL WHAT CAN YOU DO FOR ME.
AND WE ENCOURAGE THEM TO TALK TO
US TO REACH OUT TO THE DEBRIS
REMOVAL OPERATIONS CENTER SO
THAT WE ARE THERE FOR THEM TO
ANSWER THEIR QUESTIONS.
AND AND HELP THEM.
AND THEN LASTLY WE'RE DEVELOPING
OPERATIONAL PLAN STAFFING PLANS
AND SCHEDULES CONTRACT DOCUMENTS
IN PREPARING SOLICITATIONS.
ARE CONTRACTING PROCESS VARIES
DEPENDING ON STATE OR FEDERAL
MONEY.
AND THE FEDERAL PROCESS TAKES A
LITTLE BIT LONGER BECAUSE OF OUR
ACCOUNTABILITY TO FEMA
GUIDELINES.
FORGIVE ME IF YOU CAN'T SEE THIS
BUT THIS IS.
IT BASICALLY OUR HISTORY SENSE
A TWO THOUSAND SEVEN OF DEBRIS
REMOVAL OPERATIONS YOU CAN SEE
THAT.
IN THE FIRST.
COUPLE YEARS THAT WE DID IT
THERE WAS THE ENCORE A FIRE IN
THE SAN BRUNO.
DISASTER.
AND THEN THERE WAS A BIT OF A
LULL BUT SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN
WERE REALLY FOCUS YOUR ATTENTION
SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN. TO TODAY.
THE FIRES HAVE
GROWN IN GREATER INTENSITY.
THE PROJECTS
HAVE BECOME LONGER THAT TONNAGES
REMOVED MY COMPLIMENTS TO.
DIRECTOR GIL ADDICTION HAVING A
MORE UPDATED DATA POINT ON THE
ON THE WIND FIRE.
IN TOTAL YOU'RE LOOKING AT
THIRTY SIX OF THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS.
IN DEBRIS REMOVAL SEVEN HUNDRED
AND SIXTY ONE CLOSER TO EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND TONS OF
MATERIAL I JUST WANNA HIGHLIGHT
A COUPLE OF POINTS HERE.
THE MAGNITUDE OF THE DEVASTATION
THE NUMBER OF PROPERTIES IS NOT
NECESSARILY A DRIVING FACTOR IN
TERMS OF COST.
YOU'LL NOTE THAT THE BUTTE FIRE.
FORGIVE ME THE THE.
YES THE BUTTE FIRE WAS EIGHT
HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE PARCELS
BUT THAT WAS NEARLY A HUNDRED
AND TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
COST THOSE CALAVERAS COUNTY.
IT'S IMPORTANT UNDERSTAND THAT
EVERY FIRE IS DIFFERENT EVERY
EVENT IS DIFFERENT NONE OF THEM
ARE SIMPLER BUT SOME ARE NONE OF
THEM ARE SIMPLE BUT SUMMER
SIMPLER THAN OTHERS THE
CHALLENGE WITH CALAVERAS.
WAS. WHAT YOU HEARD FROM
DIRECTOR PIMLOTT?
HIS THE SPREAD OF DEBRIS THESE
WERE LARGE PARCELS.
WITH.
.
FUND PERMITTED STRUCTURES THAT
WERE SIMPLY BUILT BY THE
RESIDENTS THERE THERE WERE A LOT
OF COLLECTORS SO IT WAS VERY
COSTLY IN TERMS OF BE ACCESS TO
THESE AS WELL AS THE SHEER
VOLUME OF MATERIAL. SO THERE'S
NO REAL GAUGE IT'S JUST ALL
BASED ON WHAT BURNS.
.
BUT YOU'LL SEE THAT SEVERAL
WITHIN LAKE COUNTY AND THEN
OBVIOUSLY THE THOMAS FIRE AND
THEN WE WERE PART OF THAT MUCH
MUD SLIDE AND A DEBRIS BASIN
REMOVAL EFFORTS. IN SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY.
THESE ARE SOME OF THE MOST
RECENT ADVANCES AS I HAVE
ALREADY BEEN DISCUSSED.
OUR PARTICIPATION IS THERE ON
THE LEFT A WITH BUTTE NEVADA YOU
BUT WILL SO OFTEN REFERRED TO AS
THE INLAND BRANCH OF THE
NORTHERN FIRES.
THAT WAS AN EIGHT WEEK EFFORT
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY STRUCTURES
I BELIEVE.
JUST TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF HOW
WE TRY TO ENGAGE AND CONNECT
WITH THE COMMUNITY THIS WAS
DURING THE MONTH OF DECEMBER.
.
IN.
COOPERATION WITH SOME OF ARE
CONTRACTING CRUZ CAL RECYCLE
STAFF.
ADOPTED THIRTEEN FAMILIES AND
MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAD
SOMETHING OF A CHRISTMAS EVEN
THOUGH THEY HAD LOST EVERYTHING
AND SO THEY TO PASS THE BOAT TO
KIND OF GIVE THESE. GIVE THESE
FOLKS.
SOME SEMBLANCE OF A OF A
HOLIDAY.
.
WE'RE INVOLVED IN A SMALL
PORTION OF LAKE COUNTY AND THEN
THE MOST RECENT EFFORTS OF
TRINITY BEEN TORN SANTA BARBARA
WHAT'S NOT CLEAR FROM THE SENATE
THINK NEEDS TO BEEMPHASIZED IS
THESE ARE OVERLAPPING EVENTS.
WHILE WORST JUST FINISHING ONE
ANOTHER AND WILL BEGIN AND SO
THERE'S A LOT OF MOBILIZATION
NEEDS TO GO ON THERE'S A LOT OF
TIME IN DETAIL.
THAT WE NEED TO ENGAGE AND TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE SAFELY
MOBILIZING AND ADDRESSING THE
NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITY.
JUST BRIEFLY ON THE VENTURA
FAIRGROUNDS.
EFFORT AT WITH DEBRIS BASINS
WE'VE COMPLETED THIS EFFORT.
.
ON OVER THE WEEKEND.
TWO THOUSAND LOADS TWENTY EIGHT.
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED THIRTY
TWO CUBIC YARDS OF MATERIAL OF
ITS PARTS FOR IN TERMS OF SOIL
ROCK WOULD WASTE AND METALS.
AND WE DID THIS.
WE MOBILIZED WITHIN SEVENTY TWO
HOURS AND THIS WAS OVER THE
COURSE OF A ONE MONTH TO KIND OF
CLEAR THIS AREA. OF ONCE AGAIN
AND EXTRAORDINARY JOB BY.
.
THE OF THE TEAM I AM VERY PROUD
TO OVERSEE. AND HANDLING THE
THIS MATTER.
HERE'S A PHOTO OF THAT DEBRIS
REMOVAL OPERATION ARE EXCUSE ME
THE OF PROCESSING AND TRANSFER.
THAT WE WERE DOING ON THE
VENTURA COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS AND
YOU CAN SEE.
THE HEAVY EQUIPMENT THAT'S
INVOLVED THE TRUCKS THAT ARE
COMING INTO THIS.
THE MATERIAL IS SORTED.
AND.
WHILE IT IS HEAVY EQUIPMENT IT
IS AN IMPRESSIVE THING TO WATCH
THESE OPERATORS MANEUVER THROUGH
THIS MATERIAL AND AND TEASE OUT
WOOD AND ROCK AND MATURE FROM
BIG PILES WITH THIS HEAVY
EQUIPMENT THEY THEY REALLY ARE.
EXTRAORDINAIRE PROFESSIONALS.
WHO DO THIS?
AND SO THIS THIS IS A TYPICAL
AMERICAN TRANSFER PROCESSING THE
MUD.
AS MOST YOU MAY KNOW WAS.
DISPERSED TOO UGLY TO BEACH.
THE WOOD WAS. SENT OFF TO CHIP
VERY FACILITY IN THE ROCK WAS
PART OF A A RECYCLING I'M
EFFORT.
I REALIZE YOU CAN'T SEE THIS
SINCE YOU MENTION HAS BEEN TELL
US A BESIDES THE AND THE MUD
GOING TO DELETE A BEACH WHERE
ELSE I MEAN THAT THERE'S A HUGE
AMOUNT OF DEBRIS CORRECT WHERE
ELSE DID IT GO.
EGGHEAD BECAUSE THAT'S PART OF
OUR CHALLENGE RIGHT NOW IS WE
STILL HAVE A LOT.
OF THIS REMAINING AND WHERE CAN
WE PUT THIS AND WATER WHAT ARE
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT IS YOUR
QUESTION RELATIVE TO THEM THE
MUD.
BECAUSE WITH MY DARTED THAT THE
DEBRIS FROM THE.
PRIVATE PROPERTIES THAT'S GOING
TO TO LANDFILLS ALIKE TIGERS AND
SOME OTHER OUTLYING LAND SO
YOU'RE JUST DOING THE DEBRIS
CLEARANCE FOR PUBLIC PROPERTY IS
PRIVATE PROPERTY YOU'RE DOING
RED EYED ANGELA CORRECT AREN'T
ANY ARE YOU SENDING IT TO TO HE
GOES. PART OF IT IS GOING THERE
AND CRY WAS THE DECISION MADE
WHERE IT GOES
THAT'S PART OF THE COLLABORATION
THAT GOES ON WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WE WORK WITH THE
LOCAL ENFORCEMENT AGENCY. TO
HELP DETERMINE WHAT ARE THE
APPROPRIATE LANDFILLS THAT CAN
HANDLE THAT WHAT IS THEIR
CAPACITY.
AND SO AGAIN IT'S PART OF THAT
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENT ENGAGEMENT
SO THAT THEY ARE THAT WE ARE
REACHING OUT TO THEM THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IS REACHING OUT TO
THEM. AND SO WE WON'T FORCE
OURSELVES ON A ON A LAND FILL IT
HAS TO BE SOMETHING THAT THEY'RE
WILLING TO ACCEPT AND SO IN SOME
CASES WE DO.
RENT AND ISSUES WHERE LANDFILL
MAY NOT HAVE THE KIND OF
CAPACITY THAT WE'RE GOING TO
NEED AND SO WE WORKED WITH
ANOTHER NEIGHBORING.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO DO THAT AND
SO SOME OF THE COSTS THAT YOU
SUFFER CALAVERAS FOR EXAMPLE.
WAS MOVING THAT MATERIAL AWAY
FROM LANDFILLS THAT DIDN'T HAVE
THE CAPACITY AND TAKING IT.
A SEVENTY MILES FURTHER BECAUSE
THAT'S WHERE THE MATERIAL COULD
BE HANDLED WHEN YOU SAY LOCAL
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WHO YOU'RE
WITH RENTAL TYPICALLY THAT THESE
ARE.
.
LOCAL ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
AGENCIES THE LOCAL ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES ARE THOSE THAT OPERATE.
ON AND OVERSEE SOLID WASTE
OPERATIONS WITHIN WITHIN THEIR
JURISDICTIONS THEY'RE IN EFFECT
OUR AGENT I'M ON THE GROUND THE
STATE DOESN'T DIRECTLY.
HANDLED. IT WE WE PARTNER WITH
THEM BUT THEY ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR CERTIFICATION AND OVERSIGHT
OF SOLID WASTE FACILITIES CHOI
APOLOGIZE IF THIS IS BREAKING
THIS UP BUT I HAVE A BURNING
QUESTION THAT. HASN'T YET TO BE
ANSWERED.
AND THAT IS OF DEALING WITH THE
MUD NAM PUT ON TO LEAD A BEACH.
I I HAVEN'T YET GOTTEN A
STRAIGHT ANSWER ON WHETHER OR
NOT THAT. MODE WAS.
HAD ANY ELEMENTS IN IT THAT
WERE POLLUTING THE OCEANS
POLLUTING THE BEACH I DO MY
UNDERSTAND IS THAT PERMIT FOR
THAT HAS HAS EXPIRED RIGHT BUT
THERE IS A LOT OF CONCERN YEAH
AND A LOT OF CONSTERNATION AND I
KNOW. ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE KNOWN
AS HAD A NUMBER OF CAUSES WELL
WE DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER FOR THAT
CAN YOU GIVE US THAT ANSWER.
WHAT I UNDERSTAND
BECAUSE A LOT OF THIS FALLS
WITHIN THE PURVIEW OF THE
REGIONAL WATER BOARD AS WELL AS?
SENATE BARBARA COUNTY IS THAT
SOME TESTING HAS BEEN DONE.
BUT I CAN'T TELL YOU WITH ANY
CONFIDENCE THE DEFINITIVE LIST
OF THAT TESTING BECAUSE THAT
JUST HAS BEEN SOMETHING THAT
WE'VE BEEN DIRECTLY ENGAGED AND
SO WHO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT.
THE AND THE DECISION WAS MADE BY
THIS THE BOARD LIPSKY'S ME THAT
THE COUNTY SANTA BARBARA COUNTY
AND THE REGIONAL BOARD HAS BEEN
ENGAGING WITH THEM ON THIS.
S. I APOLOGIZE I DON'T HAVE A
DEFINITIVE RESPONSE FOR YOU
ADDRESS NOT ARMS AND OUR JESSE
IS THIS MAY BE SOMETHING GOING
FORWARD BECAUSE EVERYBODY SAYING
TO THE BEST OF MY KNOWLEDGE AS I
UNDERSTAND IT I BELIEVE.
AND THE PUBLIC ISN'T VERY HAPPY
WITH THAT SORT OF TENTATIVE.
EVERYTHING ELSE HAS BEEN
BRILLIANT I HAVE TO SAY BUT OF
COURSE IT'S ALWAYS THAT ONE
THING UNDERSTOOD ANDAND IT'S A
LEGITIMATE CONCERN SO I DON'T
KNOW AS ITSELF TO GIVE US HER AS
I UNDERSTAND IT.
.
THE PUBLIC WORKS DEPARTMENT AT
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY.
.
BYE BYE STANDARD PROTOCOL
FOLLOWING STORMS AND OTHER KINDS
OF EVENTS THAT. MOVE DEBRIS DOWN
INTO THESE CATCH BASINS ARE THEY
ARE ROUTINELY AFTER THESE
EVENTS.
WAS THEY CLEAN THESE CATCH
BASINS OUT DO SORT OUT.
THE MUD DEBRIS AND THEY HAVE BY
PRACTICE.
.
PUSH THAT MIGHT DEBRIS AL ON THE
GULLY TO BEACH.
IN THAT AREA THEY DONE IT
BEFORE THAT'S THAT'S THEIR
STANDARD OPERATING PRACTICE.
IN THIS CASE ARE THEY HAD
ALREADY MOVED TO DO THAT IN AND
BEGAN THAT PROCESS. OF WHEN THEY
PUT PERMITS IN PLACE AND ENGAGE
WITH THE WATER.
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD THE CALVET PART IN OF OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE ERA. AYE ELL
THE DIFFERENT.
AT THE TEASE THAT HAD TO BE
RESPONSIBILITY FROM FOR MANAGING
EITHER THE FISHERIES OR ABOUT A
COASTAL AREA. AND WERE GIVEN THE
THE PERMITS TO PROCEED AND AGAIN
BASED UPON.
I THINK PREVIOUS STANDARD
OPERATING PROCEDURE.
.
AS
AS YOU KNOW WAS I GOT DOWN THERE
AND LOOKED INTO THAT'S IT YOU
KNOW IT IT I DID NOT YOU KNOW
WHAT THAT LANDFILLS AND
AVAILABLE AND NOT KNOWING
EVERYTHING THAT WAS IN THE. SOIL
AT THE TIME GIVEN THE.
AMOUNT OF. DESTRUCTION THAT TOOK
PLACE IN STRUCTURES AND MAYBE
SOME SEPTIC TANKS AND OTHER
KINDS OF UP.
INFRASTRUCTURE OF LOS.
WHAT WAS CONCERNED ABOUT THAT?
THEM IN THE ANYTHING ANY
MATERIAL WAS IN THE IN THE OF
SOIL THERE WAS SOME TESTING THAT
WAS DONE THAT SHOWED.
HIGHER LEVELS OF.
AS I UNDERSTAND IT ALIBI THAT
SCENE THAT.
ACTUAL.
STUDIES THEMSELVES BUT
ANECDOTALLY UNDERSTOOD THERE WAS
SOME HIGHER LEVELS OF E. COLI.
THAT WAS A IN THE SOIL BOB BUT
AS I UNDERSTOOD OF THE PUBLIC
WORKS OFFICE IT WAS WITH IN
THOSE NORMAL RANGE OF OF HIGHER
E. COLI THAT THEY SEE AFTER
EVERY.
KIND OF EVENT LIKE THIS SO.
NEVER THE LESS THEY HOW BLAH
THE PERMIT IT'S NOT BEEN.
RENEWED AND AND AND THEY DID
NOT REQUEST TO BE BUT IT'S NOT
LIKE IT AT THE STATE ACTED THAT.
THE THE LOCAL AUTHORITY DECIDED
NOT TO RENEW THAT PERHAPS WE CAN
GET SOME ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
ON THIS WHEN.
OF THE RELEVANT STATE AGENCIES
PER BEFORE THE COMMITTEE OUT
EVERY CREE JUST LETTING MY SEAT
UP TO REMIND ME TO A MITCHELL
WHO ESOS QUESTIONS WITH GREAT
THANK YOU THE BRITISH DON'T A
REASONABLE QUESTION SENATOR.
THINK THINKING.
SO THIS IS INTENTIONALLY A VERY
DENSE DOCUMENT AND I REALIZE YOU
CAN'T READ IT BUT THIS IS WHAT
REFLECTS SORT OF THAT THE DEGREE
OF DETAIL THAT GOES ON WITH WHAT
WE DO.
AND THIS WAS AGAIN TETHERED TO
THE.
.
THE MUD. SORTING PROJECT.
SO.
HERE'S OUR PROCESS.
IN VARIOUS STEPS
GREAT HOPES.
GO BACK.
.
AGAIN DETAILS HE COMES IN AND
REMOVES HE HAZARDOUS MATERIAL I
THINK WAS ALLUDED TO PROPANE
TANKS.
THERE'S OFTEN AMMUNITION.
GAS TANKS OTHER OTHER HAZARDS
THAT ARE PRESENT AND SO THEY
MAKE THE FIRST EFFORT TO REMOVE
THE HOUSEHOLD HAZARDOUS WASTE.
AND THEY ARE GENERALLY DOING A
VERY THOROUGH JOB.
BUT TO BE FAIR TO THEM.
OFTENTIMES OTHER HAZARDS ARE
BURIED UNDER ASHEN OTHER
MATERIALS IN ART REVEALED UNTIL
WE ACTUALLY GO IN AND BEGIN TO
SORT.
ONE OF THE MOST DRAMATIC THINGS
THAT WE EVER FOUND WAS A GRENADE
LAUNCHER AND ACTUAL ROCKET.
UNFORTUNATELY.
IT WAS INACTIVE BUT.
SAFETY PROTOCOLS WE SHUT IT DOWN
WEEKS ESTABLISHED A PERIMETER
CONTACTED.
LOCAL SHERIFF SHERIFF CONTACTED
LOCAL AIRFORCE BASE THEY CAME
OUT. IT WAS FINE THEY REMOVED IT
BUT IT DID AT FOR A BIT OF DRAMA
THAT DAY IN A LITTLE BIT OF A
SLOWDOWN.
SO THE HAZARDOUS MATERIAL IS
REMOVED THAT UPON RECEIPT OF A
RIGHT OF ENTRY FORM WHICH IS
THAT PROPERTY OWNERS PERMISSION
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
BEGIN.
REMOVING MATERIAL FROM THEIR
PROPERTY. WE DO ASIDE ASSESSMENT
AS I MENTIONED WE BEGIN TO
MEASURE.
ENGAGE WHAT THAT PROPERTY HAS
ITS ITS FOOTAGE ARM.
MOORINGS.
RETAINING WALLS FOUNDATIONS
EVERYTHING THAT'S THEIR THAT WE
KNOW WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO COME
IN AND ADDRESS.
THERE'S AN ASBESTOS SURVEY AND A
REMOVAL AND THEN VEHICLES ARE
ARE REMOVED AND CHIMNEYS AND
CHIMNEYS BECAME QUITE A QUITE A
PHENOMENON FOR US IN VENTURA
WAIT. NEARLY EVERY HOME AND HAD
A CHIMNEY AND SO THAT ADDS A
LAYER OF COMPLEXITY AND AND
SAFETY RISK FOR US SO WE HAD TO
PARK ARE AT IN. BONN.
PROFESSIONALS WHO TAKE DOWN
CHIMNEYS AND AND REMOVE THAT
MATERIAL.
BECAUSE THERE ARE HAZARDS
ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE OFTEN
ASBESTOS.
WE'RE TAKING WAY METALS ASH
DEBRIS AND CONCRETE WE REMOVED
THE FOUNDATION THIS IS A
PRACTICE THAT THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS ADOPTED.
ARE READ OF THE SCIENCE IN THE
LITERATURE ON THIS IS THAT UNDER
THESE EXTREME HEAT SITUATIONS
THE INTEGRITY OF THAT CONCRETE.
IS NOT SOUND IT'S GONE IT NEEDS
TO BE REMOVED AND THIS AGAIN IS
WHAT ADDS TO THE COST IN THE
VOLUME OF WHAT OF WHAT WE'RE
REMOVING.
ONCE THE PARCEL IS COMPLETELY
CLEARED WE DO SOIL CONFIRMATION
SAMPLING.
PART OF OUR ASSESSMENT WAS TO
MEASURE BACKGROUND LEVELS WHAT
WAS THE LEVEL OF HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS HAS HEAVY METALS. IN
THAT AREA PRIOR TO THE FIRE.
AND WE MATCH THAT THROUGH OUR
SOIL CONFIRMATION SAMPLING.
WE COME IN SOMETIMES WE SCRAPE
SEVERAL INCHES DOWN TO GET THE
SOIL CLEAN WE TESTED IF IT
RETURNS HOT WE CONTINUE TO
SCRAPE ON AS I MENTIONED IN LAKE
COUNTY WE WERE DIGGING AS DEEP
AS TENDENTIOUS SOMETIMES. TO
ULTIMATELY RESTORE TO THOSE
BACKGROUND LEVELS BUT THAT IS
OUR COMMITMENT TO RETURN THAT
PROPERTY. I'M SAFELY. A FINAL
INSPECTION IS CONDUCTED AND THEN
THAT PROPERTY ONCE ALL THE OF
EROSION CONTROL AND EVERYTHING
IS PUT INTO PLACE.
IT IS RETURNED TO THE COUNTY.
AND THEN RETURNED TO THE
PROPERTY OWNER.
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE LOOKING OUT
INVENTORY YOU'VE YOU'VE SEEN
SOME OF THESE NUMBERS WE HAVE
SIX HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX
SITES REGISTERED.
AT THIS POINT WE ASSESSED SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEVEN.
YOU'LL NOTE THAT DUMB THE OTHER
A FEW SITES THAT WERE NOT
ELIGIBLE THEY MAY HAVE BEEN. A
COMMERCIAL PROPERTY OR THEY MAY
HAVE BEEN ONLY A PARTIAL BURN
AND SO WE WE. TRY AND STICK WITH
JUST A TOTAL DESTRUCTION.
SITES WITH THE.
WITH BALK AS BEST AS
I THE NUMBER PARCELS THAT WE'VE
COMPLETED AND THEN TO PROVE FOR
REDEVELOPMENT AND SO WORRIED
ABOUT A TWENTY THREE PERCENT
COMPLETION RATE THIS BEGAN IN.
THE MIDDLE OF JANUARY AND AS
YOU HEARD WERE HOPING.
IT IF ALL GOES WELL TO BE DONE
BY THE FIFTEENTH OF APRIL.
EARLY APRIL.
NEWTON.
SO HERE ARE SOME EXAMPLES OF
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT.
AS I MENTIONED SUMMER SIMPLER
THAN OTHERS.
THIS IN MANY WAYS IS IS A BIT OF
A SIMPLER PART OF PARCEL.
THERE'S A FEW HAZARD TREES AND
THINGS THAT ARE AROUND THAT.
BUT THAT SHOULD BE A RATHER
STRAIGHTFORWARD. MAYBE A COUPLE
OF DAYS.
TO TAKE THAT PARCEL NAM AND AND
RESTORE IT.
BUT THEN YOU START TO RUN INTO
SOME MORE COMPLEXITY.
THIS IS AT THE BOTTOM OF
HILLSIDE WERE STANDING ATOP A
DESTROYED PROPERTY AND THEN DOWN
THE HILLSIDE YOU SEE ANOTHER
DESTROYED PROPERTY.
I TALKED ABOUT SAFETY IT'S NOT
JUST SAFETY FOR THE PERSON
RETURNING YOU'LL SEE THAT THERE
ARE.
INTACT HOMES.
NEXT TO THE COMPLETELY DESTROYED
HOMES AND IN SOME CASES AND I
MET SOME OF THESE NEIGHBORS ARM
JUST LAST WEEK. THEY'RE LIVING
IN THESE HOMES WHILE THERE IS
DEBRIS REMOVAL OPERATIONS GOING
ON ACROSS THE STREET.
AND SO WE HAVE TO ENGAGE A HIGH
DEGREE OF SAFETY.
AND PUBLIC HEALTH PROTECTION
DUST CONTROL AIR MONITORING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT CAUSING
ANY HARM TO THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
STILL THERE.
THIS ISN'T VERY DRAMATIC.
SITE.
THE DRIVE NOW WOULD DRIVE WAY TO
KNOW WHERE.
THERE WAS A HOME AT THE END OF
THIS DRIVEWAY.
IT WAS BUILT ON TO THE HILLSIDE.
THE FIRE CAME THROUGH DESTROYED
ALL THE MOORINGS AND ALL THE
PEERS THAT WERE HOLDING THAT UP.
IF YOU STAND ATOP THAT DRIVEWAY
IT'S ROUGHLY FIFTEEN FOOT DROP.
AND THEN A FORTY FOOT LEDGE.
OF A DESTROYED HOME.
AND THEN THERE IS ANOTHER LEDGE
THAT ROLLS DOWN.
INTO A NEIGHBORHOOD WHERE THERE
ARE SOME INTACT HOMES AND OUT
AND AND NOT OTHERS.
THIS IS THE DRAMATIC.
EFFECT OF OF WHAT WE SEE THIS
IS THE HORRIFYING NATURE.
OF WHAT WENT ON.
THESE ARE THESE ARE LIVES THESE
ARE HOMES THESE ARE MEMORIES
THAT ARE NOW GONE AND AND IT'S
HARDFOR USTO. ON NOT DISTANCE
OURSELVES FROM FROM THAT.
THIS IS ANOTHER SITE THERE IT
ACTUALLY HAD SOME STEEL FRAME
CONSTRUCTION.
AND A CHIMNEY THIS ONE WE HAVE
NOT.
EVEN BEGUN WE HAVE EVEN ASSESS
THE SITE BECAUSE OF THE.
LANDSCAPE COMPLEXITY OF THE
LEDGE THAT IT'S ON BECAUSE OF
THE PRESENT HAZARDS THAT ARE
THERE FOR ANY CREW GETTINGON
THEIR. THIS IS GOING TO BE A
VERY COMPLICATED SITE FOR US.
YOU SAW THE DRIVEWAY THAT
DROPPED OFF.
THIS IS A VIEW FROM JUST DOWN
THE STREET.
LOOKING TO THAT DRIVE WAY AND
THIS IS THIS THE STATE OF OF
WHAT.
OUR CREWS ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
DEAL WITH.
IT'S VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO GET
ANY HEAVY EQUIPMENT IN THERE.
AND WHAT ARE CREWS ON THE GROUND
ARE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IS HOW
pAND SOME OF THAT MAY HAVE TO BE
HAND REMOVAL. ON THAT'S A TIMELY
TIME CONSUMING AND COSTLY
EFFORT.
BUT IT HAS TO BE CLEANED YOU CAN
SEE THE PRESENT HAZARDS OF
DAMAGE TREES YOU CAN SEE THE
LANDSCAPE AND YOU CAN SEE IN THE
IN THE FOREGROUND TO THE RIGHT
THERE.
THERE'S A NEIGHBORHOOD.
THERE'S THEIR HOMES THAT ARE
INTACT.
THIS IS SOMEWHAT SIMPLER.
IT'S FLAT BUT.
THEY'RE HAZARDS THERE IN TERMS
OF THE TREES IN TERMS OF THE.
SMOKES AT THE CHIMNEYS.
.
THAT MAY BE A LITTLE SIMPLER FOR
US BUT AGAIN DOES THAT IS THE
BUT THE WIDE VARIETY AND RANGE
OF WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH. THIS
IS THAT SIMPLY AN AIR MONITOR
THESE ARE PLACE THROUGHOUT THE
NEIGHBORHOODS TO MAKE SURE THAT
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS ARE FLOATING
AROUND IN THE AIR AND THAT
THEY'RE BEING THAT THEY'RE BEING
MEASURED. AND THAT SIGNAGE THERE
PUT BY THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
WARNING PEOPLE OF THE SITE. THIS
IS A TYPICAL OPERATION.
YOU SEE THE HEAVY EQUIPMENT.
YOU SEE THE CREW MEMBER MEMBER.
IN THE WHITE TIE VICKI HAS A
RESPIRATOR HARD HAT HE IS FULLY
PROTECTED.
THE CREW MEMBER AT THE FRONT
THAT'S THE MONITOR. IS KIND OF
WATCHING THE THE PROGRESS
DOCUMENTING IT.
THERE IS A WATER TRUCK ADJUST TO
THE LEFT OF THE BACK OF THEIR TO
KEEP DUST CONTROL.
AND THEN THAT THE BLUE TENTED
AREA THERE THAT'S WHAT'S CALLED
THE DECONTAMINATION ARE IN NO
ONE LEAVES THAT SITE.
WITHOUT TAKING OFF ALL OF THEIR
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT A WITHIN
THAT AND LEAVING THAT BEHIND
THERE'S ALSO WHAT'S CALLED
EXCLUSION ZONE A RED ZONE WHERE
NO ONE WHO.
IS ALLOWED INTO THAT UNLESS
THEY'RE WEARING THE APPROPRIATE
THAT THE APPROPRIATE EQUIPMENT.
AND THIS IS WHAT REMAINS WHEN
WE'RE DONE.
THIS IS A CLEAR PARCEL. IN FACT
THEIR.
I DON'T SEE ANY.
.
TEST FLAG SO THAT THIS SOIL HAS
BEEN CLEARED THIS SITE IS READY
UPON TO BE RETURNED TO THE
RESIDENT. AND READY TO REBUILD
YOU CAN SEE THAT WE DO LEAVE
CERTAIN THINGS BEHIND ON WALLS
AND AND OTHER OTHER ASPECTS OF
IT BECAUSE THAT THOSE CAUSE
GREATER HARM TO THE NATURAL
LANDSCAPE AND AND INCREASED
COSTS UNNECESSARILY.
IF WE REMOVE DOZENS OR VERY
JUDICIOUS IN HOW WE TAKE THINGS
OUT.
.
SO THAT'S MY PRESENTATION.
I INCLUDED THIS PICTURE OF A
BOGAN VIA BECAUSE WHILE WE WERE
THERE WE WERE SEEING LIFE
ACTUALLY RETURNING. AND SO I
WANTED TO END THIS ON A VERY
HOPEFUL AND OPTIMISTIC NOTE.
AND TURNED TO DOCTOR PACKAGE.
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION
DUCK PERCHED.
IT'S GUERRA OF RUNNING A LITTLE
BIT LATE. BRIEF YES I'M ALRIGHT
AND YOU DON'T. BOB.
WELL WE'RE GONNA TRY AND FINISH
THIS BY NOON AND HAVE US A THREE
MORE SPEAKERS AFTER THIS.
TO GIVE EVERYBODY A SENSE OF
WHAT OUR TIME FRAME HAS
.
THE MORNING F. PERMANENTLY. PLUG
JOHN PARISH STATE GEOLOGIST AYE
I WILL.
HIS BRIEF AS POSSIBLE HERE IN
THE UNDERSTAND THAT WERE
WONDERED AT THAT TIME
RESTRAINTS.
PARDON MY BACK IF I TURN AROUND
EVERY ONCE IN AWHILE.
WELL IN THIS.
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT?
ON WON'T GIVE YOU. A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF WHAT TO THE DEBRIS
FLOWS OF MONEY FLOWS ARE AND HOW
THEY START AND WHY THEY GET
VICIOUS.
SOMETIMES.
THESE ARE OF COURSE ISN'T THAT
THAT THERE ARE CALIFORNIA'S
OTHER GREAT.
HAZARDS WHENEVER WE TALK ABOUT
CALIFORNIA WE TALK ABOUT
EARTHQUAKES.
EVERYWHERE AND US TSUNAMIS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT WILL.
WE DO HAVE SOME OTHER.
GEOLOGICAL HAZARDS IN STATE AND
TO WE'VE HAD THEM FOR QUITE SOME
TIME BUT I WON'T BORE YOU WITH
TO TWELVE MILLION YEARS OF
HISTORY OF THESE. PARTICULAR ONE
SINCE WERE UNDER TIME
CONSTRAINTS.
.
OF THEIR OWN.
THERE SHOULD BE OPEN.
SO WITH THAT.
PAPA.
GOING TO WRITE.
RIGHT.
PAGE.
THESE ARE THE TYPE OF DEBRIS
FLOWS THAT OF THAT WE ENCOUNTER
IN THE STATE IN THEIR THEIR OLD
REPOSE BUT THERE'S. THE ROCK
FALL POST FIRE DEBRIS FLOWS
THERE'S THAT ALLUVIAL FANS THAT
WE HAVE THAT ARE ALL BUILT OUT
LONGER. MOUNTAIN FRONTS.
AND THEN THERE'S THE FLOOD
PLAINS THAT WE SEE THESE FLOWS A
DUMPING INTO. THESE ARE ALL
NATURALLY OCCURRING รณ WITH IN
THE STATE AND THEY ALL OCCUR TO
THE VARIOUS DEGREES DEPENDING ON
IF THERE'S A FIRE. THAT HAS
AFFECTED THOSE AREAS.
A FIRE IN THE AREA MAGNIFIES THE
INTENSITY OF THOSE DEBRIS FLOWS
IN MUD FLOWS. OF THE HUNDREDS
AND HUNDREDS OF TIMES.
OTHERWISE THESE TEND TO OCCUR
NATURALLY.
WHEN WE GET A HEAVY RAINSTORM
IN OF SOME OF THESE AREAS.
VIDEO POPULATION VULNERABILITIES
IS BECAUSE WE ARE BUILDING IN
TO.
SOME OF THESE AFFECTED AREAS
OTHER WE'RE NOT HAZARDS UNTIL WE
BUILT OUR OUR COMMUNITIES UP
INTO THE AREAS. AND OF THE
SEQUENCE OF FIRE AND RAIN.
HAS ENHANCED THE OF THE
CRITICALITY AND THE INTENSITY OF
THESE.
DAMAGES WHEN THEY OCCUR BUT
THIS IS NINETEEN THIRTY FOUR
MONTROSE.
YOU CAN SEE HOW FAR AWAY FROM
THE CANYON MOUTH. A LOT OF
DEBRIS HAS COME IN THESE AREAS.
WELL WE HAVE A LOT OF WILDFIRES
AS YOU HEARD EARLIER TODAY AND
THEY ARE OCCURRING IN AND AROUND
OUR COMMUNITIES.
WHAT THESE FIRES DO IS?
FATE WHEN THEY BURN ACROSS THE
LANDSCAPE IS THEY ACTUALLY
CHANGE THE SOILS. O. WE BURN OFF
THE BRUSH WE BURNED THE THE
TREES BECAUSE THE BRUSH IS VERY
INTENSE AND. THESE TWO INTENSE
FIRES WE TALKED TO GET OILS IN
THE IN THE SOIL AS WELL AS THE
ROOTS.
CHANGE AND GIVE SOME OILS AND
THE SOILS THEMSELVES TEND TO.
UNDERGO CHEMICAL CHANGES AND WE
GET OZONEIN THERE CALLED A
HYDROPHOBIC STONE.
THAT'S OWN IS IMPERMEABLE TO
WATER.
AND WHEN WE GET THESE INTENSE
RAINS AFTERWARD THE WATER IS NO
LONGER ABSORB INTO THE GROUND.
AND THERE'S NOTHING TO BREAK UP
IT'S RUNOFF ON THE SURFACE OF
THE GROUND SO WE GET THESE GREAT
TO.
TORRENTS OF WATER OF FROM VERY
INTENSIVE RAINFALLS AS THAT
WATER. RUNS OFF THE GROUND IT
STARTS PICKING UP EVERYTHING IN
ITS PATH.
ABOUT THREE INCHES OF WATER
MOVING AT THIRTY MILES AN HOUR
WILL WILL PICK UP A SEMI
TRAILER.
AND MOVE IT.
SO WHEN WE HAVE A LARGE BURN
AREA LIKE WE'VE HAD HERE IN THE
ABOVE MONTH ACETO WE SEE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WATER
RUNNING DOWN THE CANYONS AND
IT'S PICKING UP EVERY PIECE OF
DEBRIS. CAN AND IN COLLECTING
YET UNTIL JUST THE MOUTH OF THE
CANYON AND THEN IT'S IT SPREADS.
OUT OVER THE.
THE LANDING ZONE.
BULLETS LOOK GOOD CALIFORNIA
GEOLOGICAL SURVEY DOES IS WE ARE
TASKED BY OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES AND AND CAL FIRE.
TO GO OUT.
OFTEN WHEN THE GROUND IS STILL
HOT
AND MAP THE EXTENT OF THE FIRE.
AS WELL AS SAMPLE THE GROUNDS OF
THE HERE TO SEE WHAT KIND OF.
HA HYDROPHOBIC SOILS MIGHT BE
THERE TO WHAT DEGREES OF THESE
EXIST.
AND TO.
MAP WHAT WE CALL.
OF VALUE AT RISK AREAS.
ALL OF THESE DATA ARE WE DOING
THIS ON A VERY SHORT TIME. WE
WORK ABOUT FOURTEEN HOUR DAYS
AND WE HAD TO EVERYONE FROM FIVE
OF OUR OFFICES IN THE FIELDS TO
DO THIS.
THAT DATA IS SENT BY FIELD
COMPUTER IT STREAM TO OUR
HEADQUARTERS WERE.
WE HAVE GIS CREWS WHO PUT ALL
THAT DATA TOGETHER AND STREAM IT
BACK TO THE FIELD SO THAT
EVERYONE HAS ALL THE DATA THAT
THERE. OF SEVERAL TIMES A DAY.
AND HAS ALL THAT IN FRONT OF
THEM FOR THE DECISION MAKERS TO
USE.
OF WE ALSO WORK WITH THE USGS
AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO TRY TO
MODEL AND EXPLAIN WHERE ALL OF
THIS IS.
.
THE DANGER IS GOING TO BE THE
IDEA OF DOING THIS IS TO TRIAGE
THE DAMAGE.
SO THAT
ASSUMING THERE'S NOT GOING TO BE
RAINFALL IN TWELVE HOURS IS WAS
OCCURRING HERE. THE ENGINEERS
WILL HAVE TIME TO COME IN AND
BUILD DEFENSES AGAINST.
DEBRIS FLOWS THAT MAY BE COMING
LATER SEVERAL WEEKS WE HOPE FOR
SEVERAL MONTHS LATER.
TO DEFLECT OF THE DEBRIS FLOWS
AWAY FROM THE ESTABLISHMENTS AND
THAT'S THE TRIAGE THAT IS DONE.
IN THE CASE WE SEE IN MONTICELLO
WE HAD ABOUT TWELVE HOURS WORTH
OF TRIAGE TO DO IT JUST WASN'T
POSSIBLE FOR ANYBODY TO GET.
ANYTHING DONE THERE.
THEN YOU CAN SEE THERE'S AN
INDIVIDUAL WITH A HOUSE THAT.
IS CONVENIENTLY BILLED BELOW A
CANYON OR THAT SO OF BEEN BURNED
A BIT AND THAT IS A HIGH RISK.
OF HOME RIGHT THERE THAT IS
GOING TO GO WITH THE DEBRIS
FLOW.
AND DOWNED ON THE LOWER PICTURE
YOU CAN SEE WE HAVE THE. THE
VARS THE VA ARE REAL THROUGH
THE.
YEAH.
THAT'S REAL FOURTH REAL FIVE. M.
OF THOSE HOUSES WERE BUILT.
IN THE BASE OF OPINION THAT
CANYON HAS NOW BURNED AND WE'RE
MAPPING THAT AREA TO SAY THIS IS
AN EXCEPTIONALLY HIGH RISK AREA.
IF THERE IS ANY RAIN THAT'S
DROPPED ON IT BECAUSE THERE'S
LOOSE LAND FILL UP WITH TOP.
AN INDIAN INDEED.
IF THERE IS.
THAT IT RAIN HERE THOSE HOUSES
WILL GO IN THIS PROBABLY NO
ENGINEERING WAY TO SAVE THEM
RIGHT NOW. YOU WANT LONGER DRY
SPELL WHERE YOU CAN PLANT
SOMETHING ON THE SIDES OF THE
HILLS TO TRY TO.
OF HELP THESE AREAS.
THERE'S JUST SOME PICTURES THAT
WE SEE DEBRIS FLOWS THESE.
THIS ARE THE ONES AND THEN BONTA
SETO ND YOU CAN SEE. THE SIZE
OF THE ROCKS IN THE CARS IN THE
TREES THOSE ROCKS WAY FOUR
THOUSAND POUNDS
CAR WEIGHS ABOUT FOUR THOUSAND
POUNDS.
AND A LOT OF THESE WERE FOUND
TWENTY FEET UP IN TREES.
WHEN THESE DEBRIS FLOWS CAME OUT
OF THE CANYONS WHERE THEY WERE
CONFINED. THEY WERE TWENTY FIVE
TO THIRTY FIVE FEET HIGH.
S. BEFORE THEY SPREAD AND SO
THEY HAVE A GREAT DEAL OF.
ABOUT TWELVE MILES AN HOUR OF A
THIRTY FOOT WALL OF DEBRIS
HITTING. THE DEBRIS IS WHAT DOES
THE DAMAGE MORE SO THAN THE
WATER BECAUSE THE DEBRIS. TEARS
DOWN BUILDINGS WHEN IT CRASHES
INTO THEM.
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT IT DOES
SWEEPS THE STREETS CLEAN OF
EVERYTHING.
HERE ARE MUDFLOWS NOW VIS
THIS HYDROPHOBIC ZONE IN THE
SOIL.
IS NOT REMOVED AFTER THE FIRST
HEAVY DEBRIS FLOW IN FACT THESE
HYDROPHOBIC ZONES CAN LAST
SEVERAL YEARS.
AND WHAT HAPPENS IS AFTER YOU
CLEAN OUT THE ROUGH DEBRIS YOU
MAY START CLEANING OUT MUD FLOWS
LATER ON.
BECAUSE THE DEBRIS IS GONE BUT
YOU'RE STILL A ROADIE OF THE
SURFACE AND YOU CAN HAVE THESE
TREMENDOUS MUDFLOWS.
COME DOWN AND YOU CAN SEE ON THE
BOTTOM HERE THAT NEAR
BAKERSFIELD.
THERE'S A A SEMI TRAILER THE
AND THE HIGHWAY WAS JUST BURIED.
SO THIS HAPPENED VERY FAST AND.
WITH WITHOUT WARNING AND YOU
DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE TO BE
NEAR A A.
A BURN ZONE YOU CAN BE MILES
AWAY AND STILL HAVE THESE TAKING
EFFECT.
AND THEN OF COURSE THOUGH IT ONE
OF THESE OTHERS IS ROCK FALLS OF
INTENSE WATER GETS IN THE JOINTS
OF ROCKS THAT UNDERCUTS THE
CLIFFS AND YOU HAVE THESE GIANT
ROCK FALLS THAT OCCUR.
IF THE ROCK FALL OCCURS IN THE
EVENING. OWE YOU HAVE THESE
BOULDERS GOING TO A THREE
THOUSAND POUNDS OUT ON THE
STREETS AND IT'S VERY DANGEROUS
FOR NIGHT DRIVING DOWN THE
HIGHWAY CITY CRASH INTO THESE.
OTHERS THIS THE POOR PERSON IN
THE CAR IN THE PHOTO BELOW IS
ACTUALLY SWEPT OFF THE ROAD BY
ROCK FALL IN AND KILLED IN THAT
THE OF CURRENT.
SO THESE ARE VERY.
DESTRUCTIVE.
EVENTS THAT OCCUR.
AND LASTLY LLUVIAL FANS NOW
THERE'S A VERY LARGE ALLUVIAL
FAN DOWN INYO COUNTY.
THIS WAS A DEGREE FLOW THAT
STARTED FIVE AND A HALF MILES
AWAY AT THE CANYON.
WHAT IT DID TO SPREAD OUT OVER
THAT ALLUVIAL FAN AND DOWN LORD
RIGHT YOU CAN SEE THE MOUNT
WHITNEY OF FISH HATCHERY THAT
WAS DESTROYED BY THIS FIVE MILES
AWAY?
THIS IS THE KIND OF THINGS THAT
WE NEED TO MAKE NOTE OF BECAUSE.
IF WE'RE GOING TO PLAN OUR
COMMUNITIES WE NEED TO PLAN THEM
TO MITIGATE FOR THESE TYPES OF
DISASTERS THAT OCCUR.
THERE'S A LOT OF.
DEVELOPMENT GOING ON IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TO BUILD ON
THESE ALLUVIAL FANS AND BECAUSE
THEY SAY IT'S DESERT AND IT'S
DRY. WILL IT MAY BE BUT IT RAINS
IN THE HILLS AND YOU GET THESE
ALLUVIAL.
WASHES THAT COME OUT BUILDING
THE FANS.
SO IF THERE'S A NOTE THAT THAT.
CGS HAS TO TAKE AWAY FROM FEES
IT'S TO INFORM LOCAL
COMMUNITIES.
TO REBUILD WISELY AND SAFELY AND
KNOWLEDGEABLE THE.
USING THE BEST ENGINEERING
METHODS TO MITIGATE SOME OF
TREMENDOUS OF.
DEBRIS FLOWS THAT OCCUR SO THAT
WE DON'T HAVE THEM OCCURRING
AGAIN TAKING LIVES AND COSTING.
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN AND.
IN PROPERTY AS WELL AS BUSINESS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HAVE WERE A WELL. WELL
BEHIND SCHEDULE BUT.
WILL TRY TAKE COMPLIMENTS FOR
FOR QUESTIONS AND IF YOU COULD
TO KEEP YOUR QUESTIONS AND TO
THE ANSWERS AS CONCISE AS
POSSIBLE PRECIADO.
TWO QUESTION OF COURSE I'VE GOT
A HUNDRED BUT JUST TO THE LAST
ONE. UP ONE IS THAT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT IN JAPAN
THEY HAVE.
DRAMATIC A WEATHER EVENTS AND
HAVE CREATED SOME KIND OF A
CONTAINMENT.
SYSTEM.
FOR WHERE AFTER FIRE THAN THEY
HAVE A MUD FLOW THAT OCCURS THAT
THAT ESSENTIALLY FORCES THAT THE
DEBRIS IF YOU WILL TO GO DOWN
LOW ENOUGH THAT IT DOESN'T HAVE.
THE ABILITY TO COME BACK UP. AND
TO DESTROY AREAS OF OF THAT YOU
KNOW. COMMUNITIES AND SO FORTH.
DO WE HAVE SOMETHING LIKE THAT
HERE IS THERE SOMETHING WE COULD
DO AS WE TRY TO REBUILD SOME OF
THESE AREAS. AS WE DEAL WITH THE
DENUDED HILLSIDE TO NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS A DENUDED
HILLSIDES. IN ABOUT MANSIO IN
ALL HIGH AND ON ON THE FREEWAY
THE ONE A ONE FREEWAY.
WHERE JUST SOME RAIN COULD
BRING THEM ALL DOWN TO WE HAVE
ANY SORT OF CONTAINMENT
MECHANISMS THAT ARE LIKE
CULVERTS BUT? THAT ARE MORE
DRAMATIC SIMILAR TO WHAT I
UNDERSTAND THEY USE IN JAPAN IF
I'M NOT CERTAIN AS DRAMATIC AS
JAPAN'S BUT WE DO HAVE COLBERT'S
A OF WE DO HAVE A CONTAINMENT
DOME.
BASINS THAT.
MANY COMMUNITIES BUILD I DON'T
THINK THE CONTAINMENT SO THAT
THEY HAD HERE WOULD'VE STOPPED
VIS ENTIRELY BUT THEIR WORK
CONTAINMENT.
AREAS THERE THAT DID FILL RIGHT
AWAY.
BUT THE FLOOD WAS JUST TOO MUCH
TO FOR THESE.
THE OTHER IS.
WE DO A LOT OF OF WATERSHED OF
WORK AND WE NEVER RECOMMEND
CULVERTS.
BECAUSE COLBERT'S TEND TO JAM WE
ALWAYS RECOMMEND BRIDGES.
ACROSS OF THE MORE EXPENSIVE
COURSE IN LAYING A CULVERT BUT
WE HAVE PHOTOS WHERE THE DEBRIS
HAS SIMPLY JAMMED INTO THE
CULVERT. AND THEN THE FOLLOWING
TO BREED JUST GOES OVER THE
ROADS. HOWEVER IF YOU BUILD
BRIDGES ACROSS.
FIFTH THE PRETENSE THAT FLOWS
STRAIGHT ON THROUGH WHEN YOU
DON'T BACK UP ON ONE SIDE OF THE
ROAD SHOWS FOR ANY REASON WHY WE
DON'T CONSIDER THE JAPANESE
ENGINEERING APPROACH WHERE. YOU
DO HAVE TO ASK.
CALTRANS AND.
AND THOSE FOLKS ON WELL ARE YOU
FAMILIAR WITH THEM TO YOU KNOW
WHAT WHAT I'M TRYING TO REFER TO
KNOW A LITTLE BIT YES SO THEY%
DON'T USE CULVERTS AS MUCH THEY
DO TEND TO USE BRIDGES AND
DIVERSIONBASINS DIVERSION
BASINS I THINK IT'S THE PROPER
NAME. RIGHT AND MY LAST QUESTION
IS GIVEN.
THE OF THE WORK THAT WAS DONE
AFTER THE MONTECITO FIRE. ARM
THAT AND THE MAPPING AND SO
FORTH.
THE IT IT WAS A REAL CONCERN
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THE AREAS
RIGHT BELOW THE FIRE.
WERE CLEARLY SUBJECT TO TO
FLOODING INTO DEBRIS. BUT OUT SO
MUCH OF THE DAMAGE OCCURRED.
FARTHER DOWN AND WHAT WAS NOT A
MANDATORY EVACUATION AREA CAN
YOU EXPLAIN WHAT THE THINKING
WAS SERVED THERE GET WHAT THE
CONSIDERATIONS WERE I MEAN NO
ONE KNOWS WHAT MOTHER NATURE IS
GOING TO DO NECESSARILY BUT.
WHAT WAS THERE SOME
CONSIDERATION FOR THE FACT THAT
THEY AS YOU MENTIONED THAT? YOU
CAN TO IT YOU KNOW FIVE AND A
HALF MILES
HA OF MUD FLOW I MEAN THAT'S A
LONG DISTANCE IN MONTECITO.
DOESN'T QUITE GO FIVE AND BUT.
WHAT WHAT WAS OR WASN'T
CONSIDERED THAT PERHAPS WE CAN
LEARN FROM GOING FORWARD WELL I
I DON'T REALLY KNOW I KNOW WOULD
WE MAPPED WHERE THOSE OF VALUE
AT RISK AREAS?
AND EXISTING ALREADY WERE FEMA
FLOOD ZONES THAT WERE IN THOSE
AREAS.
BUT WE TURN ALL THAT
INFORMATION OVER TO THE LOCAL
AUTHORITIES BECAUSE FOR ONE
THING WE'RE NOT EQUIPPED TO MAKE
THOSE TYPES OF DECISIONS WE
DON'T KNOW THE. COMMUNITY
STRUCTURES AND THE AREAS AND
THOSE PEOPLE DO THEY THEY KNOW
THEIR COMMUNITIES THEY KNOW THE
STRUCTURES THINK THEY HAVE THE
AUTHORITIES TO DO THOSE THINGS.
WE TRY TO PROVIDE THEM WITH THE
BEST INFORMATION WE CAN A WHAT
WE THINK THE HAZARD IS GOING TO
P.. AND TO LET THEM WORK OUT HOW
THAT THE BEST BELIEVE THEY CAN
THEY CAN HANDLE THAT SO IN THIS
WAS AN ENORMOUS ENORMOUS. OF
STORM I DON'T THINK ANYONE
REALLY ANTICIPATED IT WOULD BE
THIS HUGE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OFFER YOUR
PRESENTATIONS VERY.
INFORMATIVE AND AND AND THE
LIMON A ELIMINATING.
AND WE'LL LOOK FORWARD TO MORE
DIALOGUE.
AS THE MONTHS GO BY.
AND WILL NOW CALL UP OUR FINAL
PANEL JEFFREY CHAMBERS
DR JEFFREY CHAMBERS THE AD
ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR AT OF THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA. TOMALIN
SKI METEOROLOGIST WITH THE U. S.
POOR SERVICE. AND TO OUR FORMER
COLLEAGUE PEDRO NAVA NOW CHAIR
OF THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
WELCOME TO. ALL OF YOU.
WE HAVE FORMALLY ABOUT A HALF
HOUR LEFT ON OUR SCHEDULE.
I'LL STICK AROUND AS.
I AWELL PAST TWELVE TO A
HILLSIDE BITE MY MY COLLEAGUES
AND OTHERS WHO ARE ABLE TO STAY.
TO BUT TO DO THE SAME IF THAT'S
POSSIBLE I DON'T WANT TO CURTAIL
YOUR PRESENTATIONS ANY MORE
THAN.
NECESSARY.
.
BECAUSE THE THINGS THAT YOU HAVE
TO TELL US ARE. IMPORTANT AND
GOING TO FORM THE BASIS FOR HOW
WE MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN.
WE DIDN'T FLIP A COIN SO.
WHOEVER AYE HOOVER WHOEVER'S
READY TO ROLL IT LOOKS LIKE YOU
ARE GOING TO GO AHEAD CHERNOV.
SURE.
OKAY.
BUT THAT WAS THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
.
THE PRESENT BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE.
FOUND TIME THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
HOOVER.
A COMMISSION AND A BLAST OF BY
THE QUALITY OF STAFF.
BUT THAT WORK DILIGENTLY LA ON
THIS REPORT OF ANY AS A CHAIRMAN
I GET TO. DELIVER THE
INFORMATION.
BUT I THINK WE ALL UNDERSTAND
THAT THE WORK REALLY IS PROUD TO
STAFF AND FOR I WANT TO THANK
THEM FOR WHAT THEY DID.
THEY ALSO PUT TOGETHER.
ELIOT CHART
WITH.
THE MEMBERS OF OF.
.
RESOURCES AND TRANSPORTATION AND
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE
ON EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT. WITH
THE ACRES THAT HAVE BEEN BURNED
OVER A PERIOD OF TIME. AND WHEN
I DO THE ARITHMETIC TODAY TURNS
OUT THAT ALL OF YOU SHARE OR
HAVE SUFFERED.
ONE MILLION FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
FOUR THOUSAND ACRES THAT HAVE
BEEN BURNED SINCE ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT. AND AND I
THINK THAT GIVES US SOME SENSE
TO THE SCOPE OF OF OF THE
PROBLEM.
THE OTHER POINT THAT I WANT TO
MAKE.
IS THAT AS.
AS WE TALK ABOUT COLLABORATION
A AND WORKING WITH THE VARIOUS
AGENCIES IN THE COMMUNITY ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT SHOULD NEVER BE
FAR. FROM OUR MINDS WHEN WE
DISCUSSED WHAT TO DO MOVING
FORWARD AYE PASSED TO IN MY
EXPERIENCE INCLUDE THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY.
THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY AND SOME
WAYS IS GOING.
TO END UP PLAYING A LARGE ROLE
IN.
INFLUENCING
WHATEVER RECOMMENDATIONS WE ALL.
DEVELOP.
BOB BECAUSE WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'RE PREPARED UNDERWRITE
CERTAIN KINDS OF RISK WILL
DETERMINE WHETHER THAT IF
WHETHER NOT THAT AVENUE IS GOING
TO BE PURSUED AND I'LL GIVE AN
EXAMPLE.
SENATOR JACKSON.
MADE REFERENCE TO HER BILL WITH
RESPECT TO PRESCRIBED FIRE.
ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT WILL NEED
TO BE ADDRESSED WITH THAT THAT
IS THE ABILITY OF A PRIVATE
PROPERTY OWNER TO OBTAIN A
INSURANCE IF THEY CHOOSE. TO
ENGAGE IN THE PRESCRIBED FIRE
PRACTICE AND I THAT IT
CONVERSATION WITH
REPRESENTATIVES WHO HAVE TOLD
ME.
THAT THERE IS IN FACT A WAY TO
OBTAIN INSURANCE FOR A PROPERTY
OWNER OF WHO WANTS TO.
PARTICIPATE IN A PRESCRIBED
FIRE PROGRAMS.
THE OTHER PART THAT I THINK IS
IMPORTANT IS AS WETALK ABOUT.
OF THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH.
PRESCRIBED BURNS ES DE ASCHAM
PARA TWO WILDFIRES.
GENERALLY THEY COST ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS AN ACRE. A TO
MANAGE SO TO SPEAK A PRESCRIBED
BURN AWARE AS.
THE OF THE ACCEPTED NUMBERS
ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED AND THIRTY
DOLLARS AN ACRE FOR FIRE
SUPPRESSION ON A WILDFIRE. THAT
DOESN'T INCLUDE.
THE COST TO THE COMMUNITY UP FOR
EITHER LOSS OF LIFE BUT LOTS OF
STRUCTURE REBUILDING OR
INSURANCE PAYMENTS THAT ARE
MADE.
OF THE TO THE.
HOLDERS OF THE INSURANCE SO THE
NUMBERS ARE.
DRAMATIC AND EXTREME AND I
THINK.
WE CAN FOCUS ON THAT BECAUSE.
HAVING. BEEN ON THAT SIDE OF THE
DIETS WHERE YOU ARE NOW I KNOW
THAT A BIG PART OF THE
CONVERSATION MOVING FORWARD IS
GOING TO BE HOW DO WE PAY FOR
THIS. WHERE'S THE MONEY COME
FROM ARE AND SO PART OF THE
ANSWER IS PICKING OUT ANY LATER.
YOU CAN EITHER FIGURE OUT HOW TO
MOVE RESOURCES AND GET
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES. TO ENGAGE
IN PRESCRIBED FIRE AND THINNING
UP OR YOU CAN SUCK IT OUT OF THE
BUDGET WHEN YOU HAVE TO AFTER
YOU'VE HAD A WILDFIRE.
THE OTHER PART THAT IS GOING TO
PLAY. AN IMPORTANT ROLE AS THE
AIR QUALITY ANY AIRPORTS.
BECAUSE IF YOU HAVE A WILDFIRE
ALL OF WHICH IS EMITTED INTO THE
ATMOSPHERE.
DOESN'T COUNT AGAINST YOU AS A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL.
THAT BUT IF YOU HAVE A
PRESCRIBED BURN THEN YOU ARE NOW
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE PARTICULAR
MATTER. THAT COMES OUT OF THAT
FIRES THERE TO BE ACCOMMODATION
A WITH THE AIR BOARD TO APPLY
SCIENCE AND SENSORS THE AND TO
REACH AN UNDERSTANDING. THAT YOU
YOU WANT TO GET THE BENEFITS OF
PRESCRIBED FIRE. OF FOR BOTH THE
HEALTH OF THE WATER ON THEM THE
HEALTH CLUB OF THE PUBLIC.
WE HEARD A DESCRIPTION FROM.
CHIEF PIMLOTT.
ABOUT.
BUT THE HEALTHY FOREST.
HISTORICALLY FIFTY TO EIGHTY
TREES PER ACRE. BOB DID IS THE
NUMBER FOR A HEALTHY FOREST WHAT
WE HAVE NOW. BECAUSE OF THE
POLICIES ON FIRE SUPPRESSION ARE
AREAS THAT HAVE THREE HUNDRED TO
FOUR HUNDRED TREES PER ACRE.
IT IS THAT DIFFERENT.
AND THE KIND OF TREES THAT YOU
HAVE IN THOSE THREE AND FOUR
HUNDRED ARE ARE DESCRIBED OFTEN
A SHADE TOLERANT TREES.
I HEALTHY FOREST OF FIFTY TO
EIGHTY HAS LARGER TREES.
FICKER BARK.
ACTUALLY FIRE RESISTANT.
BUT WITH A THREE HUNDRED FOUR
HUNDRED YOU HAVE SHADE OF. THESE
TREES THAT GROW WELL IN SHADE
BUT THAT ACTUALLY ADD FUEL THE
DO NOT HAVE THE KIND OF MARKET
IS FIRE RESISTANT THAT CREATE A
LATTER ESSENTIALLY. SO THE FIRE
GROWS FROM THE GROUND UP TO THE
TREE TOPS THAT YOU THEN HAVE
CANOPY BURNS THAT HOP AND SKIP
UP ACROSS THE LANDSCAPE. SO.
THAT'S WHY PRESCRIBED BURN AND
THINNING BOB ARE TWO OF THE
OTHER RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE
MADE IN OUR REPORT. OUR REPORT
IS ABOUT A HUNDRED PAGES LONG.
WE WERE EXTREMELY GRATEFUL TO
THE EXPERTS WHO OFFERED THEIR
TESTIMONY AND PROVIDE US WITH
INFORMATION STAFF FREAK OF A
COORDINATED THOSE MEETINGS AS
WELL AS A REVIEW OF THE
LITERATURE. AND SAID THAT LED TO
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS.
PART OF WHAT YOU WANT TO A DO
WITH THE.
WILDFIRE ISSUES IS THAT
WILDFIRES RELEASE PM TWO POINT
FIVE TALKING OF AIR QUALITY A
INTO THE AIR TWO POINT FIVE IS
TOO SMALL.
IT GETS INTO YOUR BLOOD STREAM
THERE'S NO WAY TO PROTECT
YOURSELF FROM IT.
AND IT REALLY WORKS AT CROSS
PURPOSES FROM WHAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS IDENTIFIED. AS
THAT ONE OF THE GOALS OF
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS SO FOR
EXAMPLE.
BOB THEN TWENTY FIFTEEN.
CALIFORNIA THROUGH ALL OF ITS
EFFORTS AND IT TOOK SOME
SIGNIFICANT ACTIVITY.
REDUCE ITS EMISSIONS FROM
ROUTINE OMITTING ACTIVITIES BY
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION METRIC
TONS. AND WERE ALL VERY EXCITED
HAPPY ABOUT THAT BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE ALL SUPPOSED TO BE
DOING.
BUT IN TWENTY FIFTEEN THE RUFF
FIRE IN THE SIERRA NATIONAL
FOREST IN FRESNO. RELEASED SIX
POINT EIGHT MILLION METRIC TONS.
SO ON THE ONE HAND WE ARE
CHANGING OUR ACTIVITY AS A
CULTURE AND SOCIETY BECAUSE WE
RECOGNIZE THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GASES BUT ON
THE OTHER HAND. BECAUSE WE HAVE
NOT BEEN WORKING APPROPRIATELY
IN FORCE MANAGEMENT.
WE COMPLETELY UNDO THE BENEFITS
THAT COME ABOUT FROM REDUCTION
OF THE GREENHOUSE GASES.
WE'VE GOT.
FANS PART OF OUR RECOMMENDATIONS
ALSO REFERRED TO THE FACT THAT
FIVE PERCENT OF CALIFORNIA'S
BUDGET. GOES TO FORCE
MANAGEMENT.
ONLY FIVE PERCENT.
THAT IS A CONSEQUENCE.
OF A DECISIONS THAT WERE MADE
HISTORICALLY GOING BACK TO THE
NINETEEN HUNDREDS.
WHEN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
DECIDED THAT THEIR FIRE
SUPPRESSION POLICIES WOULD BE IF
YOU HAD A FIERY PUT IT OUT.
THAT NO FIRE SHOULD GROW GREATER
THAN TEN ACRES
A FEW YEARS LATER THEY THEN
DECIDED THAT EVERY FIRE THAT
STARTED IN THE WILDERNESS SHOULD
BE PUT OUT BY TEN O'CLOCK THE
NEXT MORNING.
THAT THEN MEANT THAT THERE WERE
NO FIRES THAT ROUTINELY SERVE
THE PURPOSE
OF ESSENTIALLY CLEARING OUT THE
UNDERGROWTH. THAT THOUGHT THEM
LED TO THE SORT OF CATASTROPHIC
FIRES THAT WERE CONFRONTING NOW.
.
ONE OF THE IMPORTANT
RECOMMENDATIONS AND I SAY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT HAS BEEN
EMBRACED BY MANY OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS HAS TO DO WITH
EDUCATION.
I'M.
WE HAD A COMMISSIONER WHEN WE
FIRST STARTED THIS STUDY.
WHO GENUINELY SAID WHY DO I CARE
ABOUT THE FOREST I LIVE IN LOS
ANGELES?
I LIVE IN THE BAY AREA I LIVE
WHERE EVER I LIVE IN AN URBAN
AREAS WHY DO I CARE.
AND IT REALLY PROMPTED US TO
BEGIN AN ANALYSIS OF THIS
SITUATION SO THAT WE. COULD
EXPLAIN WHY YOU SHOULD CARE THAT
A THIRD OF CALIFORNIA IS FOREST
THAT ALMOST SIXTY PERCENT IS
OWNED BY THE FEDS.
THAT SIXTY PERCENT OF OUR
HEADWATERS ARE LOCATED IN THE
SIERRAS. AND THAT BECAUSE OF
THESE FIRES AIR QUALITY BUT IS
IMPACTED AND THE AVAILABILITY OF
WATER IN A DROUGHT.
COULD BE INCREASED BY A CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE WITH A HEALTHY FOREST
SO WE SUGGEST LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION THAT PART OF WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE IS AN EDUCATION
OF THE PUBLIC. ALONG THE SAME
SCOPE AS THE SAVE OUR WATER
CAMPAIGN MOST PEOPLE NEVER CARED
ABOUT WHAT HE OPEN THE TAP TO
GET AS MUCH AS YOU WANT.
SUDDENLY HAD A DROUGHT REMEMBER
WHAT WE DO NEVER WASTE A GOOD
CRISIS SO BECAUSE OF THE
DROUGHT.
WE GET PEOPLE TO CHANGE THEIR
BEHAVIOR WE BELIEVE THAT ARE
APPROPRIATE EDUCATION CAMPAIGN.
IT WOULD HELP PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THE FORCE
THAT WE ARE ALL ONE STATE THAT
WERE ALL RELATED AND THAT WHAT
HAPPENS IN THE FOREST IN THE
SIERRAS. HAS AN IMPACT ON YOU IF
YOU LIVE IN SAN DIEGO LOS
ANGELES SANTA MONICA SANTA
BARBARA OR IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL.
THAT AND WITH THAT LET ME
CONCLUDE BECAUSE WE HAVE. TWO
OTHER PEOPLE WHO I THINK
PROBABLY HAVE.
.
MUCH MORE IMPORTANT STUFF TO
TALK ABOUT THAN I DO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO.
.
THANKS FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
JUSTIFY ON THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC.
YOU'RE WELCOME COULD YOU
INTRODUCE YOURSELF AND PUT MIKE
JUST A LITTLE CLOSER TO YOU SO
I'M JEFF CHAIRPERSON I'M AN
ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR AT UC
BERKELEY IN THE GEOGRAPHY
DEPARTMENT. AND ALSO FACTLY
SCIENTIST AT LAWRENCE BERKELEY
NATIONAL LABORATORY.
SO I BASICALLY STUDY HOW EXTREME
EVENTS IMPACT FLORES.
NO I'M PERMITTED OF CALIFORNIAN
BUT BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FIVE I WAS LIVING IN NEW ORLEANS
ON FACULTY AT TULANE UNIVERSITY.
AND THIS IS WHAT PATRICIA LOOKED
LIKE THE DAY BEFORE SHE MADE
LANDFALL AT THE PRO RIVER. WHICH
DEFINES THE BOUNDARY BETWEEN.
LOUISIANA AND MISSISSIPPI RIGHT
THERE.
SO. WHAT I'M GONNA SHOW YOU THE
EXAMPLE OF THE WORK THAT I'VE
DONE IN THE PAST AND HER
APPLYING THAT SOME OF THESE
CALIFORNIA PROBLEMS?
SO SUCH A WHAT WE DO IS WE USE
BEFORE AND AFTER AN INJURY SO
LET'S ZOOM INTO THE PRO RIVER
RIGHT HERE.
PRO RIVER PEARL RIVER. THAT'S
BEFORE KATRINA MADE LAND FALL
GREEN MEANS HEALTHY VEGETATION
RED MEANS DEADWOOD DEAD
VEGETATION.
BEFORE.
SUBTRACT THE IMAGES.
YOU GET A DIFFERENT IMAGE HERE.
MASK OUT ANYTHING THAT'S NOT
FOREST
ANYTHING THAT IT'S OF THE TEN
COLOR.
IS A FORCED IT PICKS UP.
AS YOU CAN SEE RESOURCE IN BLUE
NO IMPACT
NONE OF THE TREES WENT DOWN.
RIGHT NEXT DOOR THESE A. OAK
MAPLE FORESTS COMPLETELY
DESTROYED YOU CAN SEE THAT RIGHT
HERE.
CYPRESS TUPELO'S WHAT FOREST'S.
OAK MAPLE FORESTS COMPLETELY
DESTROYED.
NOW. TO QUANTIFY THIS TO SAY HOW
MANY TREES DIED AND HOW DOES
THAT VERY SPATIALLY. WE NEED TO
GET UP THE FIELD.
AND THAT'S.
SO DIFFICULT WORK.
WE MEASURED MORE COUNTY DAMAGE
RATES IN THE FIELD IS A
FUNCTION.
OF THIS CHANGE METRIC FROM
SATELLITE AND TRIGGER A.
WE PUBLISH THIS BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVEN TWO YEARS
AFTER KATRINA MADE LANDFALL IN
SCIENCE.
AND WE ESTIMATED HER PINKY TRINA
KILLED OR SEVERELY DAMAGED THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION TREES.
TOOK US TWO YEARS TO DO THIS.
WHAT WE'RE DOING NOW IS WE'RE
USING SOME MODERN TOOLS?
SO FOR EXAMPLE GOOGLE HAS THIS
PLATFORM CALLED EARTH ENGINE
THAT'S PHENOMENAL.
SO I HAD A STUDENT THAT JUST
JOIN ME AGAIN WHAT I IN
SEPTEMBER.
AND I SAID HEY LET'S SO LET'S
SPEND UP THESE TOOLS AND LET'S
RUN IT THROUGH THIS EARTH ENGINE
PLATFORM.
TO ESTIMATE THE IMPACT OF MARIA.
MCCARTY RICO.
JUST LIKE KATRINA BEFORE.
AFTER.
FOR AFTER.
THE DISTURBANCE SO AGAIN
ANYTHING IN COLOR IS FORESTED.
THIS SHOWS THE IMPACT ACROSS
ENTIRE ISLAND AND HOW THAT VERY
SPATIALLY. THIS IS ABOUT TWENTY
TO THIRTY MILLION TREES WE WON'T
KNOW PRECISELY UNTIL WE DO THE
FIELD WORK.
TO KIND OF INFORMED THAT
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE THE
SATELLITES ARE TELLING US AND
WHAT'S ACTUALLY HAPPENING ON THE
GROUND.
SO.
WHEN I WAS TO PROVIDE THIS
TESTIMONY.
AND I WAS SITTING NEXT TO MY
STUDENT AND I ACTUALLY ANOTHER
WE WERE HAVING LAST WEEK I SAID
WELL WHY DON'T WE JUST TAKE THIS
TOOL. HERE.
THAT WE HAVE DONE FOR FEDERICO.
AND THAT SHOULD SHIFTED OVER TO.
THE THE FIRES HERE THE TUBS.
THE.
NUNS IN THE ATLAS FIRES AND YOU
CAN SEE THAT. IT JUST MAPPED OUT
RIGHT AWAY YOU COULD PUT THAT
MAP OVER A BASE MAP YOU KNOW
HERE'S HERE'S THE EIGHTY THAT I
DROVE FROM BERKELEY HAVE TO HEAR
THIS MORNING.
I KNOW WHAT I ONE HEADING NORTH
OF HERE SANTA ROSA. BALLOT ZOOM
INTO THIS REGION RIGHT HERE.
JUST LIKE A NUMBER OF THE OTHER
PANELISTS WERE DESCRIBING.
THIS
VEGETATION URBAN INTERFACE IT
CAN GET REALLY COMPLEX THE WAY
THOSE FIRES SPREAD.
AND THE WAY THEY INTERACT WITH
THESE COMMUNITIES YOU CAN SEE
ALL OF THE HOMES JUST
RIDLEY DESTROYED IN THIS REGION.
WHERE THE FIRE JUMPED THE ONE A
ONE? THIS REGION A FOUNTAIN
GROWTH HERE. AND THESE TOOLS CAN
BE BEFORE PROVIDED WITHIN.
PROBABLY A WEEK OR TWO OF THIS
THESE EXTREME EVENTS USING THESE
MODERN TOOLS.
SO.
DIDN'T.
TO THE PURE THE QUESTIONS THAT
THAT WOULD HAVE TO FOCUS ON SO
HOW THE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE
CHANGING WELL. THE TEMPERATURES
ARE JUST GOING TO RISE AND WE'VE
JUST SEEN THE BEGINNING OF ITS
ACCELERATING AND SO WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING NOW IS JUST THE START.
AND.
WE'RE GONNA SEE A LOT MORE OF
THESE TEMPERATURE CHANGES THAT
THE TRICKY THING IS IS THAT
PRECIPITATION CAN KIND OF GO ONE
WAY OR THE OTHER WITH CLIMATE
CHANGE.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT ALL THE
GLOBAL CIRCULATION MODELS OUT TO
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE TWENTY SIXTY
FOR THE VAST MAJORITY OF THEM
ARE PREDICTING THAT NOT ONLY IS
GOING TO BE A LOT HARDER BUT A
LOT DRIER IN CALIFORNIA.
WHICH
IT'S IT'S IT'S IT'S VERY
PROBLEMATIC FOR YOU KNOW
SNOWPACK AND OTHER.
.
PROCESSES BUT ALSO FOR METALLIC
SO. TREE MORTALITY SO THIS IS
THE ENTIRE SCARED ABOUT US OF
FEAR ABOUT ARRANGE ANOTHER
STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR ABOUT A
YEAR IT'S IT'S A PROJECT THAT'S
FUNDED BY SOME SEED MONEY FROM
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT.
USING THAT SAME EARTH ENGINE
PLATFORM IN SOME OTHER
ANALYTICAL TOOLS WE'VE MAPPED
OUT THE ENTIRE HEARING ABOUT IT
AGAIN.
THESE THIS THIS THIS THE REDNESS
HERE INDICATES.
DISTURBANCE INDICATES
TREE MORTALITY.
IF WE ZOOM INTO THIS REGION
RIGHT HERE. THAT CENTERED ON
WHAT VOTER.
YOU SEE BURKE IT'S GOT SOME
CABINS ACTUALLY THE UNIVERSE TO
CALIFORNIA'S GOT SOME CABINS OUT
HERE.
WE HIKED UP THIS TRAIL RIGHT
HERE THIS IS CHILDREN
WATERFALLS.
AND THEN WE LOOKED OUT.
OVER HERE TO JUST SAY SO WHAT DO
THESE PATCHES.
LOOK LIKE IN THE FIELD.
HIKE UP THE STEEP SIDE HERE OUT
THE CHILL THE WATERFALLS AND I
TOOK THIS PICTURE.
SO SHOWING THE SWATHS HERE WERE
EVERY TREE WAS DEAD.
AND RIGHT NEXT DOOR.
A HEALTHY STAND.
IT'S IT'S REALLY CHALLENGING TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT YOU KNOW WHY
IS IT THAT THESE TREES ARE DYING
IN THE STREETS ARE.
AND SO THAT'S THE OTHER.
OF THE WORK THAT WE DO.
.
MY LABORATORY AT A BERKELEY LAB
IS.
YOU KNOW GETTING INSIDE THESE
PLANTS AND FIGURING OUT HOW THE
DEFENDING THEMSELVES.
WHY IS IT THAT SOME TREES CAN
RESIST THESE EXTREME EVENTS
WHILE OTHERS COULD SUCCUMB?
IF SOMEBODY MENTIONED BEETLES
IT TURNS OUT THAT THESE VOLATILE
ISOPRENOID. ACT AS ANTI OXIDANTS
IN PLANTS THEY TRY TO THINK THEY
PRODUCE THOSE CUT OUTS TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES FROM OXIDATIVE
STRESS.
JUST LIKE PEOPLE DO. BUT IT
TURNS OUT THE INSECTS
CAN TARGET AND AND SINCE THAT
SIGNAL AND SENSE WEAKNESS
AND I CAN KIND OF ACCELERATE.
THE DEMISE OF THOSE TREES.
SO THAT'S ANOTHER.
PART OF OUR RESEARCH.
PROGRAM IS BETTER UNDERSTANDING
WHY SOME TREES SURVIVE WHAT OF
THE THRESHOLD FROM STRESS TO
DEATH.
AND.
.
AND THAT'S ABOUT ALL I HAD A FEW
COMMENTS ON FORCE MANAGEMENT.
IT'S IT'S IT'S IT'S A TOUGH
PROBLEM YOU KNOW WE'RE JUST
REALLY I MEAN IF YOU LIKE I JUST
SAW. A KIND OF A GRAPH OF THE
TEMPERATURE CHANGE ACROSS THE
PLANET FROM EIGHTEEN FIFTY TO
THE CURRENT JUSTICE THE SERIES
OF IMAGES AND YOU CAN CLEARLY
SEE THE ACCELERATION OF THE LAST
FIFTEEN YEARS.
AND WE'VE SEEN WHAT. TWENTY
PERCENT OF WHERE WE'RE HEADED.
YEAH IT'S IT'S A LOT OF INERTIA
IN THE EARTH SYSTEM.
AND SO IT'S A. VERY CHALLENGING
PROBLEM.
AND THEN AS YOU KNOW THAT THAT
YOU KNOW THE STATE EDUCATION
SERVICE FIELD.
FOR THESE FACTORS.
SO BEING ABLE TO MATHIS OUT AND
BE ABLE TO FIGURE OUT HOW YOU
KNOW THAT GET VEGETATION AND THE
WITH AND AND THESE CLARA HIGH
HIGH HIGH HIGH VELOCITY WINDS.
INTERACT WITH OUR URBAN
ENVIRONMENTS IT'S CHALLENGING
THAT AT SOME OF THESE SOME OF
THESE NEW TOOLS CAN CUT OFF I
THINK HELP US TO. BETTER.
PLAN.
FOR WHAT'S WHAT'S
WHATEVER WAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION AND TO FINALLY HAVE
TIME WERE LYNSKEY WITH US FOR
SERVICE.
WARNING TOMALIN SKI SENIOR
METEOROLOGIST WITH THE US FOREST
SERVICE THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
PEOPLE.
SOME GOING TO BE PRESENTING.
THE JUST A SHORT PRESENTATION
ON CLIMATE CHANGE AND HOW THAT
WILL BE AFFECTING OUR FIRE
SEASONS IN THE FUTURE.
I WANTED TO FIRST START OUT
PRINT WITH TALKING ABOUT THE
FACTS TALKING ABOUT A WHAT HAS
ACTUALLY CHANGED. OUR OUR
CLIMATE IS DEFINITELY CHANGING
THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT IT WE'VE
I CAN NOT ONLY SEE THAT WITH THE
DATA BUT WE ALSO EXPERIENCE
THAT.
I USE THIS PARTICULAR.
LOCATION UP BECAUSE I WORK IN
RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA BEEN
WORKING THERE FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS OUT WHAT YOUR SCENE IS.
PRECIPITATION.
TOTALS EARLY TOTALS ARE GOING
BACK TO NINETEEN TWENTY FIVE SO
WE HAVE NINETY TWO YEARS OF.
OF UP PRECIPITATION OUR RECORDS
FOR THIS LOCATION AND IT'S HARD
TO SEE WITH THE.
THE THE ACTUAL VARIABILITY IN
THE HIGH ANNUAL PRECIPITATION
OTHERS A LOT OF VARIABILITY IT'S
OUR IT'S IT'S HARD TO SEE THE
ACTUAL TREND. ARE OVER THE LAST
NINETY TWO YEARS.
BUT THERE IS A TREND.
AND IT'S A SLIGHT DOWNWARD
TREND OF ABOUT THREE INCHES OVER
THE LAST.
THAT AGAIN NINETY TWO YEARS.
NOW AVERAGES ARE A TRICKY THING
BECAUSE THERE.
BASICALLY MADE UP NUMBERS
THEY'RE MADE UP OF.
THE.
HIGHS AND LOWS SO AGAIN THERE'S
A LOT OF VARIABILITY FROM YEAR
TO YEAR. OF BUT GENERALLY
SPEAKING THE AVERAGES HAVE GONE
DOWN OVER THE LAST.
APPROXIMATELY HUNDRED YEARS
AFTER THAT THIS PARTICULAR
LOCATION THERE'S A REASON WHY
I'M SHOWING YOU THIS.
INITIALLY HERE.
SO WE'RE GONNA LOOK LOOK AT THE
AND I'M GONNA GO THROUGH THESE.
MAPS YOU'RE QUITE QUICKLY UP
THE MAP ON THE LEFT IS SHOWING
WHEN WE LOOK AT CLIMATE WE LOOK
AT THIRTY YEAR BLOCKS OF DATA
AND SO. ABOUT WHAT THE MAP ON
THE LEFT IS SHOWING IS A THIRTY
YEAR BLOCK FROM NINETEENTH OF
FIFTY TO NINETEEN EIGHTY.
AND THEN ANOTHER BLOCK FROM
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE TO TWO
THOUSAND TEN SO ARE WE COMPARED
AND THIS IS ACTUAL DATA SO WE
COMPARED THOSE TWO
CLIMATOLOGICAL PERIODS. SO OLD
ESSENTIALLY A SIXTY YEAR PERIOD
HOW PRECIPITATION IS CHANGED AND
YOU CAN SEE IT'S ACTUALLY GOTTEN
QUITE A BIT DRIER ACROSS
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND
PORTIONS OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
IT'S ACTUALLY GOTTEN A LITTLE
WETTER ACROSS THE CENTRAL
PORTIONS OF THE STATE AND THIS
IS THIS IS THESE ARE ACTUAL
RECORDS.
SO THAT'S INTERESTING THAT'S TO
NOTE THAT BUT YOU CAN SEE THE
EXTREME DRYNESS IN THE NORTHERN
PART OF THE STATE.
THEN THE OTHER TWO MAPS THERE
ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF SORT OF THE
WAY THE ONE IN THE MIDDLE IS
SAME TIME PERIOD DOING THE SAME
THING. ARE EXCEPT WE'RE LOOKING
AT MAXIMUM TEMPERATURE DURING
THE SUMMER MONTHS SO YOU CAN
SEE.
A LOT AREAS PARTICULARLY CROSS
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA HAVE GOTTEN WARMER
OVER THE LAST SIXTY YEARS A
LITTLE WETTER CROSS OF THE
CENTRAL PORTIONS OF THE STATE
OPTICALLY IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY. AND NORTH OF THE BAY
AREA AND IN THE FAR RIGHT MAP
THERE IS THE SAME THING EXCEPT
LOOKING AT MINIMUM TEMPERATURES
DURING THE WINTER MONTHS.
SO YOU CAN SEE OVERALL WE'VE
SEEN MINIMUM TEMPERATURES
INCREASING A SIGNIFICANTLY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OVER THE
LAST. SIXTY YEARS.
SO WHAT I'M GONNA GO THROUGHNOW
IS JUST THAT AGAIN VERY QUICKLY
HERE LOOKING THAT A A FEW SLIDES
OF. A CLIMATE CHANGE OR HOW ARE
CLIMATE WILL BE CHANGING.
ANTICIPATED CHANGES OVER THE
NEXT OF FIFTY YEARS OR SO. I
WENT THERE WHEN THE STATE JUST
ON THE.
VERY BEGINNING HERE IS THAT.
THERE ARE MANY MANY CLIMATE
MODELS WE HAVE AT LEAST THIRTY.
GLOBAL CLIMATE MODELS THAT HAVE
BEEN STATISTICALLY DOWNSCALED TO
DIFFERENT REGIONS.
FOR THE SAKE OF SIMPLICITY
WE'VE SIMPLIFIED THE TH THE
THIRTY MODELS WE'VE KIND OF
BOILED IT DOWN TO TEN MORE
COMMON MODELS. AND WE'VE USED AN
UNSOLVABLE APPROACH SO BASICALLY
WILL WILL BE LOOKING THAT ARE
THE RESULT OF AN ENSEMBLE A A
TEN MEMBER ENSEMBLE.
.
OF RESULT HERE ARE AVERAGE.
SO THIS IS A PROJECTED.
ANNUAL PRECIPITATION BETWEEN
TWENTY SIXTEEN IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTY FIVE. AND AGAIN THIS IS
A SUMMATION OF TEN CLIMATE
MODELS
IF WE WERE TO LOOK AT THOSE
MODELS INDIVIDUALLY THERE WOULD
ACTUALLY BE DIFFERENT RESULTS.
NOT NOT TOO DIFFERENT BUT SOME
OF THE SOME OF THE MEMBERS. ARE
QUITE A BIT DIFFERENT THAT'S WHY
SAY THERE'S A LOT OF VARIABILITY
WHEN WE LOOK AT THESE CLIMATE
MODELS I THINK SOME PEOPLE FAIL
TO SHOW SHOW THAT. BUT.
AGAIN THIS IS THE.
ON AVERAGE HERE OF THE TEN.
AND SOME OF THEM MEMBERS SO
AGAIN SHOWING ARE BASICALLY
GETTING WARMER ACROSS I'M SORRY
GETTING DRIER CROSS OF THE
SOUTHERN HALF OF THE STATE AND
ACTUALLY THIS IS SHOWING. THAT
IT'S GOING TO BE GETTING WETTER
ACROSS THE NORTHERN PORTIONS OF
CALIFORNIA AGAIN THIS IS OVER A
PERIOD OF ABOUT FIFTY YEARS.
AND DOES THE TERM WETTER MEANS
SNOW AND RAIN. HE OF
PRECIPITATION SO YES AT THE
HIGHER ELEVATIONS THAT WOULD
MEAN MORE SNOW.
SO WHAT'S IMPORTANT THOUGH ARE.
WITH REGARDS TO OUR FIRE SEASONS
AS I WANTED TO BREAK THIS DOWN
INTO THE SPRING MONTHS IN THE
FALL MONTHS LOOKING THAT APRIL
MAY JUNE PERIOD. SAME THING
TWENTY SIXTEEN THROUGH TWENTY
SEVENTY FIVE SAME AND SOME ALL.
MEMBERS HERE AGAIN SHOWING
DRIER CONDITIONS IN THE SOUTH
AND ESSENTIALLY WEATHER
CONDITIONS ACROSS A MUCH OF
CENTRAL AND NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
NOW THIS IS.
JERRY NOW THAT WAS DURING THE
SPRING MONTHS THIS IS DURING THE
FALL MONTHS.
SEPTEMBER OCTOBER NOVEMBER.
AGAIN DRYER NOW HERE OVER MUCH
OF OF THE STATE WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF REALLY THE NORTHERN
A QUARTER OF NO MORE THAN A
THIRD OF THE STATE. AND THERE'S
A REASON WHY I AM SHOWING YOU
THIS AT ALL OMINOUS SUM ALL THIS
UP HERE IN JUST A FEW MINUTES.
BUT THIS IS LOOKING AT
TEMPERATURES.
MEAN MAXIM TEMPERATURE MEAN
MINIMUM TEMPERATURE.
YOU CAN LOOK IT UP ARE OUR.
LARGE VARIETY OF THESE.
OF OF DIFFERENT MAPS DIFFERENT
TIME PERIODS.
DIFFERENT.
TIMES OF THE YEAR THIS ISN'T A
VERY OF IT'S JUST SHOWING YOU A
VERY SIMPLE APPROACH HERE BUT
ESSENTIALLY.
ALL THE CLIMATE MODELS ARE
SHOWING THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
WARMING UP AS JEFF IT.
JUST MENTIONED HERE ARE NO
DOUBT ABOUT IT THERE'S.
STRONG EVIDENCE THAT SUPPORTS
THIS.
THAT OVER THE NEXT FIFTY YEARS
WILL BE WARMING UP NOT ONLY OUR
MAXIMUM TEMPERATURES BUT OUR
MINIMUM TEMPERATURES AS WELL.
AND AGAIN I'M GONNA KIND OF SUM
ALL THIS UP HERE KEVIN PAUL THIS
TOGETHER IN JUST A MINUTE. OF
THE NORTH AMERICAN MONSOON THE
NAM.
I'VE DONE SOME RESEARCH ON THIS
A LITTLE BIT.
THIS IS THIS CIRCULATION SYSTEM
THAT DEVELOPS ACROSS THE DESERT
SOUTHWEST.
OVER THE SUMMER TIME AND OF
BASICALLY BRINGS OUR LIGHTNING
ACTIVITY TO CALIFORNIA OTHER
RESEARCH SUGGESTS THAT THE NORTH
AMERICAN MONSOON WILL HAVE A
WEAKER SIGNAL OVER THE COMING
DECADES ACROSS THE DESERT
SOUTHWEST.
WHAT IS THAT IMPLY THAT IMPLIES
THAT WE'LL BE SEEING LESS
LIGHTNING ACTIVITY IN CALIFORNIA
IN THE DECADES AHEAD?
I THOUGHT THIS IS FIRE ACTIVITY.
AGAIN.
JUST SHOWING THE FACTS HERE
THAT ARE THIS IS NUMBER OF ACRES
BURNED OVER THE LAST SIXTY
YEARS.
ACTUALLY THE LAST SEVENTY YEARS
GOING BACK TO NINETEEN FIFTY YOU
CAN SEE THERE IS DEFINITELY BEEN
AN UPWARD TREND IN THE NUMBER OF
ACRES BURNED BY WILDFIRES.
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IF WE TAKE THAT SAME DATA AND
JUST APPLY A.
A TREND.
BASED UPON THE.
THE CURRENT TREND YOU CAN SEE
THAT WILL CONTINUE TO INCREASE
OUR IN THE YEARS AHEAD. ARE IN
TERMS OF NUMBER OF ACRES BURNED.
OKAY
SO HERE'S WHERE I WANNA COME TO
PULL ALL THIS TOGETHER BECAUSE
THAT SHOWED A LOT OF.
DIFFERENT MAPS AND AND.
FIGURES AND SO FORTH ONE OF THE
FACTS IN THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT WE TALK ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE AND HOW THAT.
WILL IMPACT OUR FIRE SEASONS IN
THE FUTURE.
WHAT ARE THE FACTS THE FACTS ARE
THAT MAXIM MINIMUM TEMPERATURES
ARE IN IT THAT?
THEY'VE BEEN INCREASING OVER
THE LAST.
SIXTY YEARS WE SEE THAT WE
ACTUALLY CAN MEASURE THAT WE
EXPERIENCE THAT WE CAN. WE ALL
KNOW IT'S GETTING WARMER.
IT'S GETTING DRIER ACROSS.
MANY PARTS OF CALIFORNIA CHECK
WITH THE NORTHERN PART
CALIFORNIA SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AS WELL AGAIN WE EXPERIENCE THAT
WE KNOW THAT'S TRUE. OF THE
NUMBER OF ACRES BURNED I JUST
SHOWED YOU ON THAT'S A FACT
THEIR NUMBER OF ACRES ARE
INCREASING A DETOUR WILDFIRES
THAT ARE BEING BURNED.
HERE'S WHAT'S REALLY
SIGNIFICANT.
IS THAT MOST OF CALIFORNIA'S
WILDFIRES ARE HUMAN CAUSED.
OKAY I'M INTO.
.
BRING THIS HOME HERE IN JUST A
SECOND. ABOUT THIRTY TO FORTY
PERCENT OF OUR WILDFIRES IN THE
SIERRA AND EVEN MORE OF A HIGHER
PERCENTAGE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. ARE CAUSED BY
LIGHTNING BUT BY AND LARGE MOST
OF OUR FIRES ACROSS THE SORT OF
THE THE.
MORE POPULATED AREAS OF
CALIFORNIA ARE HUMAN RELATED.
SO HERE'S SOME QUESTIONS
SENATOR.
BECAUSE MOST OF ARE WILD FIRES
ARE HUMAN RELATED.
HOW IS CLIMATE CHANGE?
AND EVEN WITHOUT CLIMATE CHANGE
HOW ARE THESE THINGS GOING TO
CHANGE IN THE FUTURE. OUR
POPULATION ACROSS THE STATE THE
DEMOGRAPHICS.
HUMAN BEHAVIOR HOW WILL CLIMATE
CHANGE IMPACTS HUMAN BEHAVIOR
ARE CONDO ME. OTHER
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
AND THEN CHANGES TO THE WILDLAND
URBAN INTERFACE REGIONS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA HOWARD THOSE THINGS
GOING TO CHANGE.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN THE
DECADES AHEAD CLIMATE CHANGE
WILL CERTAINLY HAVE AN IMPACT ON
THAT. BUT REGARDLESS THOSE
THINGS WILL CHANGE REGARDLESS OF
OF WHETHER WE HAVE A CHANGES IN
OUR TEMPERATURE PRECIPITATION
AND SO FORTH.
THESE ARE THESE CHANGES ARE
GOING IN OUR POPULATION HOW
PEOPLE BEHAVE.
OUT WHERE PEOPLE MOVE. A ARE
GOING TO IMPACT OUR FIRE SEASONS
IN THE FUTURE. IN A SIGNIFICANT
WAY.
SO.
ARE JUST LOOKING AT SOME
ASSUMPTIONS SO WE CAN MAKE SOME
ASSUMPTIONS ARE BASED UPON WHAT
WE A CAN ANTICIPATE WITH. A
CHANGES IN TEMPERATURE AND
PRECIPITATION THE REASON WHY I
SHOWED YOU. WHAT HAS ALREADY
OCCURRED AT THE VERY BEGINNING
OF MY PRESENTATION?
IS THAT IT GIVES CREDENCE TO A
CREDIBILITY TO.
ALL OF THESE CLIMATE MODELS
THAT ARE PROJECTING THESE
CHANGES IN THE FUTURE SO IT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT LOOK AT WHAT HAS
HAPPENED BECAUSE THAT NOT ONLY
GETS ITS CONTEXT BUT IT ALSO
GIVES US. A CREDIBILITY FOR
THESE CLIMATE MODEL SO
ESSENTIALLY AGAIN MAXIMUM
TEMPERATURES ARE PROJECTED TO BE
INCREASING ACROSS THE REGION.
OUR ANNUAL PRECIPITATION AMOUNTS
ARE EXPECTED TO DECREASE OVER
THE SOUTHERN HALF OF THE STATE.
AND ACTUALLY INCREASE OVER
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. OF THE
SPRING AND THE FALL MONTHS ARE
EXPECTED TO BE DRIER OVER
SOMETHING OF SOUTHERN PORTIONS
OF THE STATE.
THE NORTH AMERICAN MONTHS SINCE
SIGNAL IS.
EXPECTED TO BE WEAKER WITH WEST
OF LIGHTNING ACTIVITY.
DURING THE SUMMER MONTHS
OTHER DROUGHT FREQUENCY AND
INTENSITY MAY INCREASE OUR TREE
MORTALITY MAY BECOME MORE
COMMONPLACE. IN FUEL LOADING MAY
INCREASE IN THE NORTH.
BUT DECREASE IN THE SOUTH SO
THERE'S A LOT OF.
LIKE CITY TO.
TO THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE ARE OVER THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT'S NOT IT'S NOT CUT
AND DRY.
SO THIS IS MY LAST SLIDE HERE.
CONCLUSIONS I THINK THE LENGTH
OF OUR FIRE SEASON.
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN THAT BEING
AS SEEN IT INCREASING I THINK
IT'S GOING TO INCREASE FURTHER
IN THE SOUTH. DOES THAT MEAN
EVERY FIRE SEASON FROM HERE ON
OUT IS GOING TO BE WORSE THAN
THE NEXT NOW.
WE'RE CERTAINLY GOING TO SEE
THOSE.
THAT VARIABILITY CONTINUE BUT
THERE'S GOING TO BE AN UPWARD
TREND I THINK IN IN TERMS OF OUR
FIRE SEASONS BECOMING LONGER.
OPTICALLY ACROSS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WILL BE THE POTENTIAL
FOR MORE NGUYEN RELATED
WILDFIRES DURING THE FALL MONTHS
OVER SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WHY DO
I SAY THAT BECAUSE WE LOOKED AT
THOSE CLIMATE MODELS.
AND THEY'RE PROJECTING DRIER
CONDITIONS IN THE FALL DURING A
ACROSS SOUTHERN AND CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA.
SO OUR SANTA ANA WINDS ARE A
FREQUENT VISITOR.
TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN THE
FALL. SO WE WOULD IMPLY THIS
WOULD IMPLY THAT WE WOULD SEE
MORE NGUYEN RELATED FIRE
ACTIVITY IN THE FALL AND SO THE
CALIFORNIA. OTHER WEIGHT THE
FIRE SEASON NAY CHANGED LITTLE
IN THE NORTH BECAUSE.
IT.
OF THE PROJECTED WEATHER
CONDITIONS ACROSS NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA OTHER MAYBE FEWER
LIGHTNING RELATED FIRES IN THE
SIERRA AND OVER NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
THE POTENTIAL FOR MORE SEVERE
FIRES IN THE SOUTH.
THAT'S POSSIBLE DUE TO DRIER
FUEL CONDITIONS
AND FIRE BEHAVIOR.
MAY BECOME MORE EXTREME
ESPECIALLY IN THE SOUTH AGAIN
JUST DUE TO THOSE CRIER FUEL
CONDITIONS A SCENE ACTIVITY LIKE
A WHAT WE DID IT WITH THE THOMAS
FIRE. AND SOME OF OUR.
STATION FIRES ANOTHER.
EXAMPLE.
OF SOME SIGNIFICANT FIRE
ACTIVITY IN THE SOUTH.
AND THAT'S THE END OF MY
PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH COME
ALL REPRESENTATIONS OF BEEN
VERY.
HELPFUL AND TO PROVIDE US WITH
A LOT OF THE INFORMATION THAT
THAT THAT WE NEED TO TO MOVE
FORWARD DATA MS LIMO DID YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
THEN WHY DON'T WE.
EXCUSE OUR PANEL AND ASK IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WOULD LIKE TO
ADDRESS.
GO RIGHT AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
PAUL MASON AT THE STATE FOREST
TRUST NICE WANTED TO REINFORCE A
COUPLE OF THINGS THAT I THINK
CAN GET. QUITE ENOUGH ATTENTION
DURING THE EXCELLENT
PRESENTATIONS EARLIER. ONE IS
THAT ASWE'RE LOOKING AT OUR
FORESTED LANDSCAPES AGO AS WELL
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH THE SITUATION WHERE WE HAVE
WAY TOO MANY SMALL TREES NOT
NEARLY ENOUGH LARGE TREES. YOU
KNOW CONSEQUENCES THE PAST
MANAGEMENT FIRE SUPPRESSION.
AS WE'RE GOING IN AND THINNING
AND DOING OTHER THINGS TO READ
PRESCRIBED FIRE TO REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF SMALL TREES.
IT'S GONNA TAKE A DELIBERATE.
INTERVENTION TO MITCHELL
ACTUALLY RECRUITING LARGE TREES
AS WELL THAT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN
BY MAGIC THAT'S GOING TO NEED TO
REAP.
WORK WITH LANDOWNERS TO DEVELOP
THAT CHARACTERISTIC ON THE
LANDSCAPE.
AND THAT CAN BE REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR LONG TERM WATERSHED FUNCTION
I THINK WITH THIS LAST
PRESENTATION REALLY HIT HOME. IS
WE REALLY NEED TO GET THESE
WATERSHEDS WHERE IT'S GOING TO
CONTINUE THE MOISTURE IN THE
FUTURE INTO THE BEST POSSIBLE
CONDITION IN ORDER TO HAVE SOME
SECURITY ABOUT WERE CALIFORNIA'S
WATER CAN BE COMING FROM. BY THE
SECOND HALF OF THE CENTURY
BECAUSE THINGS ARE GOING TO BE
WARMER AND THINGS ARE IN THE
DRYER.
AS WE'RE TRYING TO PLAN FOR ALL
OF THESE.
LARGE SCALE PROJECTS
YOU KNOW THIS IS SOMETHING THE
MY ORGANIZATION PACIFIC FOR
STRESS DOES A LOT OF IT'S REALLY
HARD WHEN THE SOURCES OF FUNDING
FOR THESE PROJECTS ARE NOT
STABLE AND PREDICTABLE. WHEN
THERE'S MONEY ONE YEAR IN THE
NOT MONEY THE NEXT YEAR.
GETTING TO A POINT WHERE WE
ACTUALLY HAVE DEDICATED STATE
RESOURCES FOR ADDRESSING THIS
PROBLEM OVER THEM COMING.
FRANKLY DECADES IS GONNA BE A
REALLY IMPORTANT PART OF THE
SOLUTION. AND LASTLY I WOULD
JUST HIGHLIGHT THAT.
A THESE ARE ALL FOREST FIRES AS
MS LIMON POINTED OUT LOVE THIS
HAPPENS AND AREAS OF THE STATE
THEY'RE DOMINATED BY CHAPARRAL
AND GRASSLAND DINO FRANKLY THE
FIRES AND NAPA WERE LARGELY THAT
CONTEXT AS WELL. WE ABSOLUTELY
NEED TO BE GETTING A GRIP ON ALL
OF THE HOMES THAT ARE OUT THERE
NOT AS SORRY AREAS IN THE WILD
LANDS. THAT YOU KNOW HAVE WOOD
SHAKE ROOFS IN THESE OTHER HIGH
RISK CHARACTERISTICS
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
DEFEND HOMES THAT ARE.
NOT DEFENSIBLE
AND SO THAT IS THE PART OF
THINKING AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS TO
I AARON READ REPRESENTING CAL
FIRE FIREFIGHTERS LOCAL TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY ONE. HAVE PROUDLY
NOW FOR FORTY YEARS.
AND I WOULD JUST LIKE TO THANK
YOU FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING I
LOOK FORWARD BRINGING SOME OF
OUR FIREFIGHTERS TO TESTIFY WHEN
CALIFORNIA'S BUDGET IS OUT. OF A
IN IN THE HEARINGS COMING
FORWARD. OF WOULD LIKE TO JUST
VERY QUICKLY SAY WE'RE DOWN OVER
SIXTY ENGINES FROM JUST A FEW
YEARS AGO.
I REMEMBER THE DAYS ONLY HAD
FIVE WHAT WE CALL FIVE OH
STAFFING JUST FIVE FIREFIGHTERS
ON AN ENGINE. OF THAT DROPPED TO
FOUR THEN IT DROPPED THREE
INSTRUCTED TO.
A AND WE TRY TO HOLD A MINIMUM
OF TWO BUT FOR FOR OVERSTAFFED
EGGMAN FIRE ENGINES IS IS
PROBABLY. A A GOAL THAT WE
SHOULD THINK ABOUT TRYING TO
ACHIEVE AND YEAR ROUND STAFFING
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HAS
BECOME PRETTY ESSENTIAL A I
THINK THIS PAST YEAR HAS PROVEN
THAT. AS I LOOK FORWARD A
TALKING TO WHEN YOU GET IN THE
BUDGET LATER ON AND THANK YOU
FOR THE HEARING TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
VARIOUS JULIAN ALLEN OWSKI BALL
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BIOMASS ENERGY ALLIANCE I TO
ACTUALLY WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THIS HEARING TODAY ALL THE
INFORMATION THAT WAS SHARED IS
ESSENTIAL TO HOW WE DEVELOP
THIS.
YOU KNOW THE POLICY CHANGES WE
NEED TO MOVE FORWARD YOU KNOW MY
PERSPECTIVE AB REPRESENTING THE
BIO ENERGY INDUSTRY.
JUST IS IS A PRETTY NARROW
PERSPECTIVE AT LEAST ONE OF
THROUGH IT ON THE TABLE AS WE
EXPLORE OF WHAT WE NEED TO DO
AND YOU KNOW THE BY MASS
INDUSTRY IS ACTUALLY PRETTY
PROUD OF THE WORK IT'S BEEN
DOING. IN RESPONSE TO THE TREE
MORTALITY CRISIS WE HAVE
DEDICATED FACILITIES TAKING
PRIMARILY DEDICATED FUEL FROM
DEDICATED AREAS. IT IS PART OF
THE LARGER SOLUTION ISN'T THE
ONLY SOLUTION BUT DEADLY PART
THE SOLUTION TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS MATERIAL. GETS OUT THE
FOREST
IF IT WEREN'T FOR THESE
FACILITIES IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS
CRISIS
THAT MATERIAL BE PILED AND
BURNED. OR BE ELECTED AGREED IN
THE FOREST AND THE FUEL FOR THE
NEXT CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES.
SO IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT THESE
FACILITIES YOU KNOW UP CONTINUE
TO PLAY THIS ROLE WE WOULD
SUGGEST THAT LET'S INVOLVE A
LITTLE THIS CONVERSATION. MOVE
IT BEYOND THE TREE MORTALITY AND
JUST SIMPLY TALK ABOUT FOREST
HEALTH LIKE WE WERE DOING TODAY
TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW ADJUSTING
FOR OUR CHANGING CLIMATE. AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN SECURE
THIS INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE HAVE
IN THE GROUND TODAY FOR THE LONG
TERM.
AND THEN WE WOULD WE WOULD SAY
IT'S NOT JUST US WE NEED TO BE
TALKING ABOUT FIRE PREPAREDNESS
FIRE PREVENTION MANY THINGS THAT
YOU HEARD TODAY VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT.
WE KNOW THAT THE THE LOCALS
JUST LIKE AND CAL FIRE IS AS
ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDS AND
WE SUPPORT THAT AND BECAUSE IT'S
GOING TO BE. IT'S GOING TO BE
LOTS OF TOOLS WORKING ON THIS
TOOL SHED TED TO GET US INTO A
BETTER CLIMATE FUTURE THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK DURING THIS
HEARING I'M AARON EVANS BUT THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES.
.
AS YOU KNOW OF COURSE THE
COMBINED WILDFIRES IN OCTOBER
AND DECEMBER WERE THE MOST
DEVASTATING IN STATE HISTORY.
AND. AND AND FIRST I THINK WE
SHOULD RECOGNIZE THE AT THE
HEROIC EFFORTS OF THE FIRST
RESPONDERS STATEWIDE AND FROM
AFAR. WHOSE WORK HAS SAVED LIVES
STILL RECOVERY ESTIMATES ARE IN
THE BILLIONS AND CALIFORNIA
CITIES WERE AFFECTED AN
UNPRECEDENTED WAYS AS FIRE. TORE
THROUGH NEIGHBORHOODS.
WELL THE LEAGUE CONTINUES TO
GATHER INFORMATION ON THE EXTENT
OF RECOVERY NEEDS. THE LEAGUE'S
FIRE CHIEFS DEPARTMENT HAS
IDENTIFIED A FEW CLEAR NEEDS TO
PREVENT FUTURE DESTRUCTION.
FIRST NOTIFICATION SYSTEMS FOR
RESIDENTS MADE COORDINATION.
I'M WORD VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
EFFORTS.
TO TO WORK ON THIS ISSUE I'M
AND WOULD LIKE TO ENGAGE IN
FURTHER STAKEHOLDER DISCUSSIONS.
SECOND THE MUTUAL AID SYSTEM
NEEDS MODERNIZING.
FOR LOGISTICAL SUPPORT SUPPORT
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY PERCENT OF
MUTUAL AID WAS SUPPLIED BY LOCAL
AGENCIES.
A THIRD FIRE DEPARTMENTS IN THE
STATE NEED ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
TO ENSURE THAT EQUIPMENT AND A
STAFFING ARE AVAILABLE TO PRE
POSITION BEFORE THE FIRE SPREAD
THROUGH BEFORE FUTURE FIRES
SPREAD THROUGH NEIGHBORHOODS.
THE LEAGUE HAS BEEN WORKING WITH
THE COALITION TO REQUEST
ADDITIONAL BUDGET RESOURCES FOR
THAT. AYE THESE AND OTHER
ACTIVITIES TO THE TUNE OF A
HUNDRED MILLION.
AND FINALLY JUST TO HIGHLIGHT A
COUPLE OF MORE ISSUES THAT I
THINK ARE HIGHLIGHTED IN THIS
HEARING.
FIRST REPLACEMENT HOUSING WILL
BE NEEDED.
PARTICULARLY IN THOSE AREAS
THAT ARE ALREADY IMPACTED AND
SECONDLY TREE MORTALITY AS A
MAJOR ISSUE IN MANY PARTS OF THE
STATE AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING CONVERSATION SO THAT
AND.
QUANTIFYING THESE NEEDS ARE VERY
IMPORTANT.
AND IS ON GOING PROCESS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THIS COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR MIKE GARABEDIAN.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR WE
ORGANIZED GROUP OF FRIENDS OF
THE NORTH FORK IN AMERICAN RIVER
GROUP AND FOR THE LAST TEN YEARS
WE HAVE WORKED IT DILIGENTLY
STEADILY. ATTEMPTING TO GET LAND
USE DECISIONS THAT ARE MADE
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT WHERE AND
HOW WE BUILD. A AND I IT IT'S
JUST A FACT THAT MANY LOCAL
DECISION MAKERS DON'T SEEM
CONCERNED ABOUT PUTTING PEOPLE
IN HARM'S WAY WITH THEIR
DECISION.
OF AYE I'M GONNA MAKE FOUR FIVE
QUICK POINTS AND THERE ARE LOT
OF OTHER THINGS AND THEY WANT TO
CONTRIBUTE TO YOUR FUTURE AGENDA
SETTING IF WE CAN.
IN IN LATE TWENTY FIFTEEN OF
THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL HOOVER
THEN FIRE MARSHAL WHO WERE MADE
A STATEMENT ABOUT HOW WE NEED TO
PAY ATTENTION TO WHERE WE BUILD
AND I COMMEND JON PARIS TODAY
FOR BASICALLY. MAKING CLEAR THAT
THAT IS SOMETHING. WE HAVE TO DO
WHAT YOU DO NOT HEAR THAT A VERY
VERY OFTEN FROM STATE GOOD
GOVERNMENT SAYS IT IS STATE
OFFICIALS SO I'M VERY GRATIFIED
TO HEAR THAT HERE.
A SEQUEL SEQUENCE OF DISCLOSURE
DOCUMENT
AND I'VE SEEN MANY SECRET
DOCUMENTS AND IF IF THERE ARE
ANY THAT NEED STREAMLINING
THOUGH THEY ARE ALREADY
STREAMLINED WHEN IT COMES TO
FIRE HAZARDS AND PLANNING FOR
FIRE HAZARDS AND IN PARTICULAR.
LIKE TO SLIDE YOU SING WE'VE NO
I WAS A UPS A VOLUNTEER FIREMAN
IN UPSTATE NEW YORK FOR WE HAVE
KNOWN ABOUT FIRE BEHAVIOR AND
WHAT IT DOESN'T WHERE YOU SHOULD
OR SHOULDN'T BILL AND HOW IT
AFFECTS HOW YOU DESIGN
SUBDIVISIONS AND THAT KIND OF
THING.
WE'RE NOT APPLYING IT IN IN
LARGE PART OF THAT HAS BEEN IT
AND. WE DON'T NAY HARSH
STREAMLINING WE NEED MORE
CAREFUL APPLICATION EVERYTHING
IN HERE WHICH COULD HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED IN A CESSNA HAD TIME
IN THE. IN THE SOILS AND OTHER
REPORTS AND DOCUMENTS.
I'M NOW THE LAW IS PART OF THE
PROBLEM I JUST GIVE ONE OF A
NUMBER OF NEVER EXAMPLES THE
BOARD OF FORESTRY HAVE AND YOU
I'M SURE YOU HAVE MORE FIRE
PREVENTION. ISSUE THE WORK IN
YOUR FUTURE HEARINGS THE BOARD
OF FORESTRY NOW REVIEWS THE
SAFETY ELEMENTS OF THE NEW
SAFETY ELEMENTS OF GENERAL
PLANTS NOW WHERE DID THEY DO
THIS. THEY DO IT IN VERY HIGH
FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY AREAS AND
AS DEFINED BY STATE LAW. THEY
DON'T DO IT IN HIGH FIRE HAS ITS
VERY ERRORS THEY DON'T DO IT IN
MONEY BECAUSE THE LAW DOESN'T
PERMIT THEM TO DO THAT AND AND
THAT'S JUST. ONE EXAMPLE I COULD
GO AND OTHERS AND I WILL ATTEMPT
TO DO THAT WITH YOUR STAFF.
WANNA POINT OUT THAT THE
INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
FIRE SHEET CHIEFS FOR EVERY YEAR
NOW FOR NEVER USES HAD THEIR
ANNUAL WE CONFERENCE IN RENO IS
COMING UP IN A WEEK OR TWO. A
VERY GOOD PLACE TO GO THEY HAVE
A TWO DAY WORKSHOP THERE AND
THINK STRUCTURE IGNITION THAT
EVERY YEAR. AND IT'S SORT OF
VARIOUS IN TERMS OF WHAT THEY
THEY DID SEEM TO DO MORE LAST
YEAR IN TERMS OF PLANNING AND
WHAT WHAT PEOPLE BUT WHAT STATES
AROUND THE WEST ARE DOING IN
TERMS OF. OF FIRE PREVENTION
PLANNING SO.
ONE THANK YOU FOR THIS HEARING
I LEARNED A LOT TODAY AND HOPE
TO BE MORE INVOLVED.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
A MEASURE CHAIR MEMBERS BRIAN
WHITE HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LICENSE FORCES
SOCIALIZATION AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA. A FORCE LENTILS A
CALIFORNIA. LICENSE FORCES
ASSOCIATION WE ARE THE REGISTER
PROFESSIONAL FORESTERS OF
REPRESENT BOTH STATE AND PRIVATE
FORESTERS WHO ACTUALLY ARE THE
FOLKS LACKEY PERCENT OFF ON TV
NUMBER HARVEST PLANS. AND HOPE
MANAGED FOREST WE'VE BEEN
PREACHING THE NEED FOR FORCE
MANAGEMENT FOR YEARS AND
FORTUNATELY THE.
ON THE EVENTS THAT HAPPENED
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND EVEN BEFORE
THAT A CONTINUE TO HAPPEN AND
WILL CONTINUE TO HAPPEN. UNTIL
WE ACTUALLY DO SOME REAL
REFORMS.
THERE'S A LOT OF RESEARCH THAT
WILL BE REQUIRED TO TO DEAL WITH
THIS PROBLEM A YOU CAN THROW
MONEY AT IT AS LONG AS YOU WANT
BUT YOU HAVE TO CHANGE POLICIES.
THERE'S NO LOST ANY POLICIES
THAT JUST NEED TO HAVE WILL BE
LOOKED AT AND WE'RE RAPIDLY
INVOLVE THAT DISCUSSION HERE WE
THINK THERE'S. POTENTIAL TAX
CHANGE WITH THINGS AND FOR THE
SMALL FORCE LANDOWNERS OF THESE
ARE THE SMALL MOM AND POP.
LANDOWNERS OF IN CALIFORNIA
WOULD I LIKE TO COME THERE THEIR
LAND RICH AND CASH POOR IF THEY
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO TOOK
TRYING TO WHAT'S ON THE STUFF WE
HAVE TO REALLY RECOGNIZE AT THE
SMALL LANDOWNERS. NEED TO BE
INVOLVED IN THE DISCUSSIONS WERE
HAPPY BE A INVOLVED WITH THE
BUDGET HEARINGS AND AS WELL AS
THE OTHER GOVERNOR'S TASK FORCE
WITH TOWARD WORK.
TO SEE WHAT TIME IT IS TO MAKE
SURE YOU GET THE PROPER
GREETING.
GOOD AFTERNOON STACEY HE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT THIRTY
FIVE RURAL COUNTIES STATEWIDE.
MANY OF OUR MEMBER COUNTIES HAVE
BEEN DEALING WITH WILD WILD FIRE
AND FORCED HEALTH ISSUES FOR YOU
KNOW DECADE PLUS NOW. AND SO NOW
THAT THIS IS BECOME MORE OF A
STATEWIDE ISSUE DUE DUE TO
CLIMATE CHANGE AND ARE A FOREST
MANAGEMENT.
THIS IS HEARING CALIFORNIA. WERE
VERY GRATEFUL FOR HEARINGS LIKE
THIS NOW BECAUSE THAT WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO BE PROACTIVE AND
HELPFUL. UP AT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT LEVEL ON THESE
ISSUES.
AND THAT INCLUDES THINGS LIKE
LAND USE YOU KNOW I DON'T THINK
IT'S ANY ACT COUNTY GOVERNMENTS.
WISH TO PUT THEIR CONSTITUENTS
IN HARM'S WAY AND IN THE COURSE
OF A WILDFIRE.
AND SO WE WANT TO BE PART OF
THOSE DISCUSSIONS PART OF THE
SECRET DISCUSSIONS PART OF THE
LAND USE PLANNING DISCUSSIONS
GOING FORWARD. I THINK SOME OF
OUR COUNTIES IN AREAS THAT
HAVEN'T DEALT WITH THIS KIND OF
WILD FIRE BEHAVIOR AND ACTIVITY
BEFORE. REALIZE THAT THERE IS A
NEED TO HAVE THESE DISCUSSIONS
AND SO WE'D LOVE TO BE PROACTIVE
GOING FORWARD.
WE'VE ALSO LONG BEEN ENGAGED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S TREE MORTALITY
TASK FORCE AND SO WE ARE VERY
VERSED IN AYE. THE NEED TO END
THE COMPLEXITY OF THE ISSUE OF
TRUE MORTALITY THE ISSUE OF
FOREST HEALTH THAT THERE ARE A
LOT OF DIFFERENT THINGS THAT
NEED TO BE LOOKED AT INCLUDING
BIOMASS INCLUDING. THE.
THE COMPLEXITY OF GETTING THE
MATERIALS OFF THE FOREST THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE BLOGS PACK OF
PILED UP RIGHT NOW AND COUNTY
ROAD TURNOUTS BECAUSE THERE'S NO
PLACE TO TAKE THOSE MATERIALS
FROM DEAD TREES OFF THE FORCE.
AND SO. GOING FORWARD THIS YEAR
WE KNOW THERE ARE A LOT OF
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO LOOK AT
IT'S VERY COMPLEX.
AND WE JUST WANT TO KNOW WHAT
YOU TO KNOW THAT WE'RE HERE AND
WE'VE BEEN THAT IN THESE
DISCUSSIONS AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING.
THESE DISCUSSIONS WITH YOU THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
US YOUR COMMENTS AND INPUT ITS
APPRECIATED AND TO THANK YOU TO
OUR VERY.
EXCELLENT STAFF FOR PUTTING
TOGETHER TODAY'S HEARING.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THINK.
UP A COMMENTARY THAT WE
RECEIVED FROM ALL OF THE
PARTICIPANTS SENT YOU MS LA
MONDE FOR STICKING IT OUT FOR
THE WHOLE HEARING.
WE ARE ADJOURNED